GOOD MORNING EVERYONE WELCOME TO
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER THREE
RESOURCES AND TRANSPORTATION --
WILL -- ESTABLISHED [inaudible]
BLOOM.
HERE FONG HERE GARCIA MULLIN
PATTERSON REYES [inaudible]
RIVAS.
WE HAVE A QUORUM -- WILL BEGIN
WITH THE VOTE ONLY CALENDAR AND
LET ME -- ANNOUNCE -- BEFORE WE
MOVE ON TO OUR FOLKS THAT WE
WILL NOT BE TAKING UP ISSUE
FOURTEEN TODAY THAT'S THE CHP
ORGANIZED CRIME BCP THAT SAID
THAT I INDIVIDUAL ITEM.
IS PULLED -- BUT WE DO HAVE A
NUMBER OF ITEMS THAT WE CAN TAKE%
UP IF THERE IS A MOTION ON
COLLECTIVELY ON ITEMS.
1-457-810-1112 THIRTEEN AND
FIFTEEN WE CAN [inaudible]
RIGHT VOTE.
BLOOM I FONG -- SCEA MULLIN
PATTERSON RAMOS [inaudible]
RIVAS.
THANK YOU.
NOW IS THERE A MOTION ON ISSUE
NUMBER TWO BUT ONLY ISSUE
[inaudible]
TOO THANK YOU [inaudible]
HELLO I FONG.
GARCIA MULLIN PATTERSON RACE
[inaudible]
RIVAS.
THANK YOU WILL HOLD THAT TO OPEN
FOR ADD ONS -- ISSUE NUMBER
THREE IS OUR MOTION.
THANK YOU BLOOM I FONG.
GARCIA MULLIN PATTERSON RACE.
RIVAS.
AND WILL HOLD THAT ONE OPEN AS
WELL WE'LL HOPE IT'LL HOLD UP IN
ALL OF THESE FOR A ADD ON VOTES.
ISSUE NUMBER SIX DO WE HAVE A
MOTION [inaudible]
BLOOM I FONG.
GARCIA MULLIN PATTERSON RAMOS
[inaudible]
RIVAS.
AND FINALLY A ISSUE NINE IS
THEIR EMOTIONAL ISSUE.
NINE BLOOM HI.
FONG.
GARCIA MULLIN PATTERSON RADIUS
[inaudible]
RIVAS.
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH WE WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO ITEMS TO BE HEARD
OUR FIRST DEPARTMENT CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION.
RF WE HAVE TWO ISSUES ISSUE --
ONE WHICH WILL BE HOLDING OPEN --
A RELATES TO PROJECT DELIVERY
WORKLOAD AND THE NAY REVISED.
THE MORNING PLEASE PROCEED.
THE MORNING JR BLOOM SEVEN
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JIM DAVIS AND
I AM SPECIAL ADVISER TO WRECK TO
DIRECTOR BERMAN IT CALTRANS.
AND WITH ME IS COURT PAULSON OR
DIVISION CHIEF OF BUDGETS.
CALTRANS REQUEST AN INCREASE OF
EIGHT POINT EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS IN FORTY EIGHT FULL TIME
EQUIVALENTS FOR PROJECT DELIVERY
WORKLOAD. FOR THE FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY PROPOSED
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
THIS PROPOSAL INCLUDES
INCREASING WORKLOAD TO DELIVER
PROJECTS TO MEET SENATE BILL ONE
REQUIREMENTS.
TOTAL WORKLOAD RESOURCES
REQUESTED THE TRADITIONAL 90%
STATE STAFF IN 10% ARE.
MARKET TEXTURE IN ENGINEERING
CONSULTANT RATIO.
AFTER AFTER A DECADE OF
DECLINING WORKLOAD.
PHYSICAL YEAR TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN MARK THE FIRST MAJOR
INCREASE IN THE CAPITAL IS
SUPPORT PROGRAM.
DUE TO SB.
ONE CALTRANS DEVELOPED AND
EXECUTED AN AGGRESSIVE
RECRUITMENT PROGRAM TO MEET
INCREASING STAFFING NEEDS.
BY THE END OF THE CURRENT FISCAL
YEAR THE COS PROGRAM IS
ESTIMATED IT WILL HAVE
SUCCESSFULLY HIRED ALMOST
FIFTEEN HUNDRED EMPLOYEES TO
MEET WORKLOAD DEMANDS.
THE TOTAL RESOURCES REQUESTED
ALLOW CALTRANS TO PRESERVE AND
IMPROVE ON THE HUNDREDS OF
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS INVESTED IN
THE STATE HIGHWAY SYSTEM.
WHICH IS THE FOUNDATION THE
STATE'S ECONOMY ENABLING
EFFICIENT MOVEMENT OF PEOPLE
GOODS AND SERVICES.
WITH THIS PROPOSAL THE CS
PROGRAM WILL BE ABLE TO CONTINUE
ITS COMMITMENT TO DELIVER
PROJECTS TO CONSTRUCTION.
AND OVERSEE THE CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS CURRENTLY FUNDED OR
PROGRAMMED.
OR EXPECTED TO BE FUNDED BY THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION OR BY ITS OR BY OUR
LOCAL PARTNERS.
RESOURCES CONTAINED IN THIS
REQUEST ARE CRUCIAL COMPONENTS
IN THE DELIVERY OF TRANCE
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS.
ENSURE THE CONTINUEDECONOMY.
AND LIVABILITY OF CALIFORNIA.
AND NOW HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE.
THANK YOU -- AT THE THE FINANCE
LETTER INDICATES THERE WILL BE A
FUTURE NEED.
FOR MORE -- A COS STAFF FOR A IS
THERE AN UNDERLYING CAUSE A A
CAUSE FOR THE FIVE ABSOLUTELY
SENATE BILL ONE REALLY DOUBLES
THE AMOUNT OF FUNDING FOR THE
SHOP.
AND COMMENSURATE WITH THAT
FUNDING WILL CONTINUE TO GROW SO
WE CAN PLAN DESIGN AND BUILD
THOSE CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS.
THE CREW THERE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS I KNOW -- LA -- AS
COMMENTS MISS PETERS.
THANK YOU JUST COMPUTERS AT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE AND
SO WE DON'T HAVE ANY CONCERNS
WITH THE NINETEEN TWENTY BUDGET
PROPOSAL HERE -- I DO JUST WANT
TO POINT OUT IN TERMS OF THE
INCREASE THAT YOU'RE LOOKING AT
ITS -- FORTY EIGHT FULL TIME
EQUIVALENTS BUT A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY THREE STAFF POSITIONS AND
THIS IS REALLY JUST TAKING DOWN
THE AMOUNT OF OVERTIME NOW THAT
CALTRANS HAS.
HIRED FOLKS IN SORT OF RESTORING
OME OF THE HISTORICAL AND
PERCENTAGES OF HOW THEY DIVVY UP
OUR WORKLOAD AMONGST THE
RESOURCES.
ARE WE DON'T HAVE ANY CONCERNS
WITH THAT WE WOULD JUST POINT
OUT THAT AND GIVEN THAT THE
DEPARTMENT IS VERY LIKELY TO
COME IN WITH.
A VERY SUBSTANTIAL AND STOPPING
INCREASE IN THE NEXT -- MAYBE A
YEAR OR TWO OR THREE AND AFTER
THAT -- I BELIEVE IT WAS FIFTEEN
HUNDRED POSITIONS THEY'VE HIRED
UP THIS YEAR.
AND THIS IS SORT OF A PAUSE AND
IT GIVES THE LEGISLATURE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE A LOOK AT
HOW SOME OF THE MANY OVERSIGHT
AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
AND THINGS THAT THE LEGISLATURE
HAS PUT IN PLACE ARE FUNCTIONING
BEFORE AND YOU'RE ASKED TO
APPROVE A REQUEST FOR ANOTHER
THOUSAND OR TWO THOUSAND
POSITIONS.
ON IN THE COMING YEARS AND SO
SPECIFICALLY WE WOULD
RECOMMENDED THAT YOU AND I DROP
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORT LANGUAGE
REQUIRING THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION. TO DO SORT OF A LOOK
BACK ON A SAMPLE OF PROJECTS TO
SAY WHAT WAS THE BUDGET FOR THE
PROJECT ESTIMATED TO BE AND WHAT
ACTUALLY HAPPENED AND HOW DOES
THAT COMPARE WITH THE THE LEVEL
OF RESOURCES ASSUMED AGAIN THAT
IN THE ANNUAL BUDGET ASSUMPTIONS --
FOR THOSE PROJECTS TO IT TO GET
THE LEGISLATURE SOME ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION.
AND HOPEFULLY COME FOR THAT AND
SOME OF THE ESTIMATES IN THE
DATA QUALITY HAD IMPROVED.
I THE DEPARTMENT HAS TAKEN AND
NUMBER OF STEPS INTERNALLY TO
IMPROVE THEIR ESTIMATING AND
THEIR DATA QUALITY AND RESPONSE
TO CONCERNS THAT OUR OFFICE HAD
RAISED.
AS WELL AS IN RESPONSE TO A
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION --
WORKING GROUP THAT LOOKED AT
THIS ISSUE AND FOUND THAT THERE
WERE CONCERNS ABOUT AND HOW
PROJECT BUDGETS ARE ESTIMATED
AND HOW THE ANNUAL FUNDING
REQUEST FITS INTO THAT.
AND SO WE THINK CAN NOW THAT YOU
HAVE TASK THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION WITH DOING THIS
PROJECT LEVEL OVERSIGHT -- UNDER
SB ONE AS WELL AS PRIOR
LEGISLATION THIS IS A GOOD
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO BENEFIT FROM THAT NEW
OVERSIGHT THAT THE CDC IS DOING
BY HAVING THEM TAKE A LOOK AT A
SAMPLE OF PROJECTS -- AND REPORT
BACK TO GIVE THAT ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION AND HOPEFULLY
COMFORT LEVEL IN INFORMATION
YOU'LL NEED WHEN YOU'RE ASKED.
TO APPROVE AND POTENTIALLY VERY
SIGNIFICANT INCREASES IN THE
COMING YEARS -- AND HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS GREAT THAT
SOUNDS LIKE A SOUND SOUND ADVICE
TO INCLUDE SOME -- REPORTING
LANGUAGE GOD DOES THE APARTMENT
FINANCE HAVE ANY COMMENTS -- NOT
AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU -- WILL AT THERE'S NO --
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
WILL HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN AND WE
WILL TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE
AND FOR AFTER ISSUE NUMBER TWO
ON I'M SORRY I DIDN'T SEE YOUR
HAND GO UP.
MS REST.
JUST AS A THOUGHT AS THIS AND
OTHER OTHER ITEMS OTHER ISSUES --
THAT ARE BEING BROUGHT UP WHEN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT NEW STUFF.
I WOULD ONLY ASK THAT WE LOOK AT
DIVERSITY -- DEBT AS WE ARE
HIRING NEW PEOPLE THAT WE WOULD
DO LOOK SERIOUSLY AT DIVERSITY
AND I'M NOT SINGLING OUT
CALTRANS I THINK THAT'S TRUE FOR
ALL OF OUR DEPARTMENTS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER THANKS FOR THE
COMMENT.
AND US WILL MOVE ON NOW TO ISSUE.
TO THE INDEPENDENT OFFICE OF
AUDITS.
AN INVESTIGATION IS TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE.
GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS WILLIAM
LEWIS I'M THE ASSISTANT DIRECTOR
OVER THE END HAD OFFICE OF
AUDITS AND INVESTIGATIONS.
AND I HAVE WITH ME TODAY JEAN
SHEER WHO'S THE CHIEF COUNSEL
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION.
SO THE INDEPENDENT OFFICE OF
AUDITS INVESTIGATIONS OFFICE OF
INSPECTOR GENERAL DEPARTMENT
TRANSPORTATION REQUEST LANGUAGE
BE ADDED TO THE ROAD.
REPAIR AND ACCOUNTABILITY ACT OF
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THAT
PROVIDE SIMILAR PROTECTIONS OF
CONFIDENTIALITY.
CURRENTLY PROVIDED BY STATUTE TO
THE STATE CALIFORNIA STATE
AUDITOR AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCES OFFICE OF STATE AUDITS
AND EVALUATIONS.
THE ROAD REPAIR AND
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT OF TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN CHAPTER FIVE
STATUTES.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN OR WE
CALL IT SB ONE CHAPTER IN
GOVERNMENT CODE SECTION.
FOURTEEN FOR SIXTY ONE VESTED
THE OAG WITH FULL AUTHORITY TO
EXERCISE ALL RESPONSIBILITIES
FOR MAINTAINING A FULL SCOPE.
INDEPENDENT AND OBJECTIVE AUDIT
INVESTIGATIVE PROGRAM
[inaudible]
HOWEVER.
THE SPECIFIED POWERS
RESPONSIBILITIES IDENTIFIED IN
SB ONE FOR THE AG DID NOT
PROVIDE FOR A FULL ACCESS. TO
INFORMATION OR FOR THE
PROTECTION OF INFORMATION DEEMED
CONFIDENTIAL BY LAW.
THE INTENT OF THIS PROPOSED
LEGISLATION IS TO ENSURE THAT
BOTH THE IG AND THE LEGAL
DIVISION OF THE STATE TO PUT
TRANSPORTATION APARTMENT ARE
ABLE TO CONDUCT THEIR
INDEPENDENT INVESTIGATIONS
WITHOUT FEAR OF COMPROMISING
CONFIDENTIAL INFORMATION. TO
ACCOMPLISH THIS WE PROPOSE
HARMONIZING THE AUDIT STATUTES
FOR THE CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR
THE OFFICE OF STATE AUDITS AND
EVALUATIONS AND THE OFFICE OF
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL.
THIS PROPOSED LANGUAGE IS
SIMILAR AND TO THE PROTECTIONS
ALREADY STATUARY PROVIDED TO THE
STATE AUDITOR AND TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCES OFFICE OF
STATE AUDITS AND EVALUATIONS.
IF CONFIDENTIALITY OF DOCUMENTS
CANNOT BE TO PROTECTED IT WILL
HAMPER THE O. I. G.'S ABILITY TO
CONDUCT COMPLETE AND THOROUGH
AUDITS AND INVESTIGATIONS.
A LINE IN THE STATUTORY LANGUAGE
IS NOT INTENDED TO BROADEN THE
AUTHORITY THE ORGY BUT TO AVOID
POTENTIAL CONFUSION BETWEEN
VARIOUS.
STATE AUDIT STATUTES.
THE STATUTES REFERENCED IN SB
ONE PERTAIN TO THE OTHER
RESPONSIBILITY AND AUTHORITY
ASSOCIATED WITH AN INTERNAL
AUDIT ORGANIZATION.
AS SUCH THAT ALL THE PROGRAM
WOULD BE AFFORDED THE
CONFIDENTIALITY PROTECTIONS OF
THAT DEPARTMENT.
HOWEVER BECAUSE SB ONE
SPECIFICALLY CREATED THE ID TO
BE AN INDEPENDENT OF THE
DEPARTMENT.
THE INTERNAL AUDITING STATUTES
IN SB ONE ARE NOT APPLICABLE TO
THE EXISTING INDEPENDENT OFFICE
OF AUDITS AND INVESTIGATIONS.
AND THEREFORE THE PROTECTIONS OF
CONFIDENTIAL RECORDS IS NOT
PROVIDED.
A COMMON UNDERSTANDING AS TO
WHAT DOCUMENTS ARE SUBJECT TO
AND WHICH ARE EXEMPT FROM
DISCLOSURE WOULD BENEFIT BOTH
THE IG AND THE DEPARTMENT'S
LEGAL COUNSEL.
BY AVOIDING CONFUSION THE O. I.
G. AND THE DEPARTMENT CAN FOCUS
MORE ON RESOURCES AT THEIR CORE
MISSIONS.
RATHER THAN ON DISCLOSURE
DISPUTES.
AND FINALLY PROMOTING PUBLIC
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
IS A CORE VALUE OF THE IG AND
THE DEPARTMENT.
SO THEREFORE THE PURPOSE OF THIS
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE IS TO
PROVIDE THE NECESSARY
PROTECTIONS TO ENSURE THAT
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
CAN CONTINUE.
WITHOUT COMPROMISING
CONFIDENTIAL INFORMATION.
WITHOUT THE ASSURANCE OF
CONFIDENTIALITY HE IG IS UNABLE
TO PROTECT THE CONFIDENTIAL
INFORMATION OBTAINED.
FROM THE DEPARTMENT NECESSARY TO
PERFORM THE RESPONSIBILITIES
OUTLINED IN SB.
ONE WE'RE AVAILABLE TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE.
THANK YOU -- SO I THINK THAT THE
ANSWER TO MY QUESTION MIGHT BEEN
BURIED AND THAN THAT --
STATEMENT THAT YOU JUST GAVE --
BUT THE QUESTIONS RAISED WHY --
THE IG NEEDS MORE PUBLIC RECORDS
AUTHORITY THAN THE STATE AUDITOR.
CURRENTLY HOUSE SO REALLY WE'RE
NOT LOOKING TO HAVE ANY MORE
AUTHORITY WE ACTUALLY LOOKED AT
THE STATE AUDITOR'S STATUTE AND
ALSO THE DEPARTMENT FINANCES
OFFICE OF STATE AND EVALUATIONS
AND REALLY TRY TO TAKE.
FROM THERE THE SIMILAR TYPE --
LANGUAGE THAT WE USE IN THIS
TRAILER BILL TO MAKE SURE THAT
WERE PROVIDED THE ACCESS TO BE
ABLE TO OBTAIN THE RECORDS.
AND ALSO TO BE ABLE TO GET
MAINTAIN THAT LEVEL OF
CONFIDENTIALITY SO YOU'RE SAYING
THAT.
WE WILL NOT ONLY WE DON'T FEEL
THAT MORE AUTHORITY YEAH WE
DON'T FEEL THAT THIS TRAILER
BILL AS PROVIDING ANYMORE
AUTHORITY LEAST IT AS WE'RE
LOOKING AT IT -- IN FACT A LOT
OF THE LANGUAGE IS VERY SIMILAR
TO THAT OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I DON'T KNOW HOW -- TO
RESULTS THAT TOWARDS THE PINYIN
A LOT AND WE'RE HEARING THAT
THEY'RE THIS THIS MORNING THAT
THAT -- SOMETHING THAT I THINK --
OUGHT TO BE EXPLORED MORE SO
THAT WE MAKE SURE THAT THE
THERE'S HARMONY BETWEEN -- A THE
STATE HONOR AND AND AND THE
AUTHORITY THAT TO AND WE'RE MORE
HAPPY WE'VE DONE I'LL -- SECTION
BY SECTION ANALYSIS AND WE'RE
VERY MORE HAPPY TO SIT DOWN WITH
YOUR STAFF AND BE ABLE.
TO SHARE CHAU WHAT WE'RE LOOKING
AT AND THEN OF COURSE THE LARGER
QUESTION -- IS -- WHETHER OR NOT
THIS -- ISN'T BETTER -- DEALT
WITH IN A POLICY COMMITTEE SINCE
IT DOES.
NOT APPEAR -- TO OF FACILITATE --
NEW POLICY -- BUT I THINK THAT
THAT IT'S POSSIBLE THAT LA --
AND DEPARTMENT OF FINANCEWANT
TO ADD SOME COMMENTS SO -- BUT
I'LL GIVE YOU AN OPPORTUNITY TO
RESPOND TO THAT ISSUE AND TELL
US WHY YOU THINK -- IT'S MORE
APPROPRIATE HERE AS OPPOSED TO A
POLICY COMMITTEE IMMEDIATELY
AFTER BIRTH -- THE OTHER
COMMENTS JUST BRIEFLY WE
WOULDN'T RAISE ANY CONCERNS WITH
THE TRAILER BILL.
LANGUAGE -- OBVIOUSLY WITH A
DEPARTMENT AS LARGEST CALTRANS
HAVING AND YOU KNOW WELL
FUNCTIONING OVERSIGHT SYSTEMS IN
PLACE IS A GOOD THING.
I'M YOUR STAFF HAS NOTED AS YOU
ALREADY INDICATED MISTER CHAIR
AND THAT THIS MIGHT BE A BETTER
FIT TO GO THROUGH THE POLICY
PROCESS IF YOU KNOW IF YOU HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT -- HOW THE
AUTHORITY FOR CALTRANS A LINES
IN MEASURES UP WITH OTHER
SIMILAR THIRTIES IN OTHER
DEPARTMENTS I'M CERTAINLY THE
POLICY COMMITTEE PROCESS WOULD
BE ABLE TO THAT THOSE THINGS AND
PROVIDE DOT COM -- FOR BUT IT'S
TOTALLY WITHIN THE DISCRETION OF
THE LEGISLATURE READY WANT TO
PURSUE THIS THROUGH THE BUDGET
PROCESS IN THE POLICY PROCESS.
THANK YOU.
YOU HAVE COME.
HERE THE NEWMAN ON DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I JUST LIKE TO NOTE THAT
WHETHER THIS MOVES TO THE POLICY
PROCESS OF THE TRAILER BILL
PROCESS THE ADMINISTRATION'S
POSITION.
IS THAT IT'S IMPORTANT THAT THE
LANGUAGE -- THAT WAS ULTIMATELY
INCLUDING STATUTE MEETS THE
GOALS THAT I MISTER LEWIS JUST
OUTLINED IN ITS PRESENTATION.
UNDERSTOOD THANK YOU FOR THAT --
SO -- POLICY OR BUDGET.
WELL THE READ ONE WAY IN ON THAT
YEAH THE REASON WHY WE'RE HERE
TODAY IS BECAUSE WHEN WE SAW
THAT WEAKNESS OR THE POTENTIAL
CONFLICT WITH THE HAVING THAT
CONFIDENTIALITY.
STATUTES WE FELT SOONER WAS
BETTER AND THAT'S YOU KNOW
CERTAIN WE CAN WORK THROUGH THE
POLICY PROCESS AND TAKE --
AFFORD THAT ACTION BUT WHAT YOU
WILL BE SEEN AS SOMETHING VERY
SIMILAR COMING THROUGH THAT
POLICY -- PROCESS.
SO I DON'T KNOW IF THAT
CLARIFIED YOUR RESPONSE BUT IT I
KNOW WHEN -- YOU MEAN ORTEGA --
FOR ME THE INSPECTOR GENERAL HAD
AN OPPORTUNITY TO MEET WITH
GINGER THEY TALKED ABOUT THAT
WITH THE DIFFERENT METHODOLOGIES
AND THIS WAS JUST.
THE JEWS OPPORTUNITY WE WOULD
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY BRING
SOMETHING BEFORE THE LEGISLATURE
AND SHARE WITH THEM THE CONCERNS
WE HAVE ABOUT WHAT LANGUAGE IS
IN THE SB.
ONE SET YOUR NOW AND THEN JUST
TO ADD TO THAT -- WE ARE
CURRENTLY [inaudible]
EXPERIENCING OPERATIONAL
CHALLENGES IN THIS REGARD --
IT'S NOT A IT'S NOT A
SPECULATIVE IN THE FUTURE
PROBLEM IT IT ACTUALLY EXISTS
NOW AND SO THAT'S WHY WE THOUGHT
ARENA THOUGHT THAT THIS WOULD BE
THE APPROPRIATE METHODOLOGY TO
GO DOWN THIS PATH I UNDERSTAND
IT'S NOT REALLY A FISCAL ISSUE.
BUT BY HAVING IT -- BE PART OF A
TRAILER BILL SUCH AS THIS --
WE'D BE ABLE TO ADDRESS AND
RESOLVE THE INTERNAL CONFLICTS
THAT WE HAVE CURRENTLY.
DO YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS AS
REYES.
MISTER CHAIR I AGREE WITH THE
COMMENTS THAT YOU HAVE PROVIDED
MY THINK THAT.
IT DOES APPEAR SOMETHING THAT
WOULD BE -- MORE APPROPRIATE IN
POLICY TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITIES
TO HAVE FOR THE DISCUSSION ON IT.
OTHER EXAMPLES I KNOW THAT THE
COMMENT WAS THAT IT'S NEEDED NOW.
OTHER EXAMPLES OF WHERE.
THE ABSENCE OF THIS HAS CAUSED
PROBLEMS.
SO IN A NORMAL SITUATION YES TO
ANSWER YOUR CANS QUESTION YES I
CAN GIVE YOU SOME EXAMPLES IN
THE NORMAL SITUATION WHEN THE
STATE AUDITOR'S REACH OUT TO
CALTRANS AND WOULD LIKE TO GET
INFORMATION AS PART OF AN AUDIT
THAT THEY HAVE GOING ON WE ARE
ABLE TO FREELY.
SHARE THAT WITH THEM -- WITHOUT
WAIVING ANY PRIVILEGES FOR
EXAMPLE I'VE BEEN ASKED IN THE
PAST -- BY THE STATE AUDITOR'S
FOR INFORMATION THAT'S ATTORNEY
CLIENT COMMUNICATION PRIVILEGED
AND SO IS VERY HIGHLY
CONFIDENTIAL BUT I'M ABLE TO
SHARE THAT WITH THE STATE
AUDITOR'S AS PART OF THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY TO DO AN AUDIT.
CURRENTLY WE HAVE SEVERAL
INVESTIGATIONS GOING ON IN THE
DEPARTMENT THAT LEGAL IS
INVOLVED WITH I'M UNABLE TO
AUTHORIZED MY ATTORNEYS TO SHARE
ANY INFORMATION WITH THE IG.
BECAUSE TO DO SO WOULD WAIVE THE
PRIVILEGE BECAUSE THERE AND IN
THERE EVEN THOUGH THEY'RE WITHIN
THE DEPARTMENT THEY'RE AN
INDEPENDENT I MEAN THEY'RE
SITTING IN CALTRANS.
THE ORGANIZATIONAL STRUCTURE HAS
DRAMATICALLY CHANGED UNDER SB.
ONE WHAT USED TO BE OUR INTERNAL.
AUDITING PROGRAM IS NO LONGER
INTERNAL THEIR NEXT THEY'RE AN
EXTERNAL THEIR INDEPENDENT THEY
HAVE INDEPENDENT
RESPONSIBILITIES TO REPORT.
OUT OF THE DEPARTMENT AND
THEREFORE WERE I TO AUTHORIZE
ANY OF OUR ATTORNEYS TO RELEASE
INFORMATION. TO ASSIST THE O. I.
G. N. ONGOING AUDITS AND
INVESTIGATIONS I WOULD BE
BREACHING THE ATTORNEY CLIENT
PRIVILEGE -- AND THAT'S THAT'S A
PROBLEM.
SO [inaudible]
RESTAURANT -- YOU MENTIONED IN
YOUR ANSWER THAT -- THE OFFICE
OF INSPECTOR GENERAL IS WITHIN
THE AGENCY AND THERE'S BEEN
SEVERAL -- EFFORTS TO CREATE A
EXTERNAL AND INSPECTOR GENERAL
OUTSIDE THE AGENCY TO OVERSEE A
WHICH I THINK THE LA
ACCOUNTABILITY.
TO HOW DOES THE OFFICE OF
INSPECTOR GENERAL CURRENTLY
OPERATE WITHIN THE CAL IT WITHIN
CALTRANS IS IT.
INDEPENDENT TRULY YES IT
ABSOLUTELY IS SO THERE ARE NO
OTHER FOR ANY CLIENT PRIVILEGE
WITH THEM WHATSOEVER -- THEY
DON'T SEEK LEGAL ADVICE FROM US
FOR EXAMPLE -- THEY ARE AND ALL
IT BILL SPEAK TO IT BUT THEY ARE
INDEPENDENT.
AS OTHERS ARE THERE SPECIFIC
FIRE LAWS THAT EXIST THAT THE
CREATED WITHIN WITHIN WITHIN
YOUR OPERATION TO ENSURE THE
INDEPENDENCE.
WELL THERE'S FIRE WALLS TO
ENSURE THE CONFIDENTIALITY -- WE
DON'T SHARE CONFIDENTIAL
INFORMATION WITH THEM CURRENTLY
BECAUSE OF THE PROBLEM THAT THAT
WE'RE DISCUSSING HERE TODAY AND
AS FAR AS THE ALL AS FAR AS THE
AUDIT FUNCTION YES WE AND ALSO
HONOR INVESTIGATION FUNCTION WE
ARE INDEPENDENT BECAUSE WE HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO CHOOSE WHAT
WE OUGHT.
WE NO LONGER HAVE THE DEPARTMENT --
YOU KNOW CERTAINLY THE
DEPARTMENT CAN ADVISE US AND
SHARE WITH US THE CONCERNS THEY
MAY HAVE.
WE CAN USE AS WE DEVELOP OUR
RISK ASSESSMENT AND THEN.
THERE ARE OTHER PLAN BUT NO
LONGER DO WE HAVE TO HAVE THE
DID DEPARTMENT I DIRECTOR
SIGNING OFF ON A LOT OF MY WE
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO CONSULT
WITH THEM GET INFORMATION.
BUT THE AYE AYE INDEPENDENT
OFFICE ABOUT ITS INVESTIGATIONS
UNDER THE DIRECTION OF AN
INSPECTOR GENERAL HAS FULL
AUTONOMY DID AUDIT WHAT THE BILL
IS NECESSARY TO PROVIDE THAT
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
TO THE LEGISLATURE TO ACT
CALLOUSED -- AND ALSO TO THE
PUBLIC.
IF I COULD ASK DELEO CAN YOU
SHED SOME LIGHT IN TERMS OF THE
BEST PRACTICES OF OF WHETHER AN
EXTERNAL AN INSPECTOR GENERAL IS
PREFERENTIAL TO ONE AS WITHIN AN
AGENCY -- BUT WE CAN FOLLOWUP
WITH YOU ON MORE OF THAT BUT I
THINK HE JUST SPEAKING GENERALLY
AND IN ORDER FOR THAT IT'S AN
INSPECTOR GENERAL OR REALLY ANY
SORT OF OVERSIGHT AND TWO T. --
AS I THINK AS LONG AS IT'S
STRUCTURED IN A WAY WHERE YOU
HAVE THE INDEPENDENCE AND THE
INFORMATION THAT IS COMING OUT
IS.
AND YOU KNOW HELPING TO IDENTIFY
ISSUES AND AND GIVING THAT SORT
OF THE CHECKS AND BALANCES
THERE'S DIFFERENT WAYS THAT IT
CAN BE STRUCTURED -- WENT WHEN
AN ENITY IS COMPLETELY OUTSIDE
OF AN ORGANIZATION THAT AND YOU
CAN CERTAINLY MAKE IT CLEANER
MAY BE EASIER TO SEE AND LINES
OF OF ON INDEPENDENCE.
BUT AS LONG AS IT'S STRUCTURED
IN SUCH A WAY WHERE YOU HAVE --
CHECKS AND BALANCES AND ITS
FUNCTIONING AND THE OVERSIGHT
ENTITY IS ABLE TO REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND TO THE PUBLIC ON
ON WHAT ITS FINDINGS ARE THERE
THERE'S DIFFERENT WAYS THAT YOU
CAN STRUCTURE IT.
LOOKING AT OTHER INSPECTOR
GENERAL'S IN OTHER AGENCIES HOW
ARE OTHER AGENCIES STRUCTURE.
I'M WE CAN GET BACK TO YOU ON
THAT ONE AND WITH SOME SOME MORE
INFORMATION AND BEST PRACTICES
IF YOU COULD PROVIDE -- SOME
INFORMATION IN TERMS OF OTHER
INSPECTOR GENERAL'S IN AND WHICH
ONES ARE EXTERNAL AND WHICH ONES.
IT IS OUR HOUSE WITHIN THE
AGENCY I THINK THAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL FOR ALL OF US TO SEE
WHAT THE BEST STRUCTURE WOULD BE.
APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU.
IF THERE'S NO -- FOR THE
QUESTIONS WE'LL HEAR FROM THE
PUBLIC ON ISSUES ONE AND TWO AND
THEN WE CAN PROCEED TO A VOTE --
TO I'LL LET YOU KNOW JUST AS THE
IF THIS MIGHT HELP INFORM THE
REMAINDER THE DISCUSSION WHAT
I'M THINKING IS -- RATHER THAN --
FOLLOWING THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION TO REJECT THAT WE
HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN -- WITH THE
DIRECTION -- TO COMMITTEE STAFF
AND TO THE OFFICE -- TO TRY TO
WORK TOGETHER -- TO HARMONIZE
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT WE'VE --
BEEN BEEN TALKING ABOUT SEE IF
WE CAN DO THAT OF I CAN
UNDERSTAND THIS FROM.
OF FROM BOTH PERSPECTIVE AT
LEAST I THINK I'M BEGINNING --
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT THE ISSUES
ARE AND AND TO I COULD SEE I
COULD SEE BOTH SIDES OF IT SO
GIVING A LITTLE BIT.
MORE TIME AGO FOR THIS WOULD
ALSO ALLOW THE LA -- TO PROVIDE
SOME ADDITIONAL INFORMATION TO
US.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
THE BAKER WITH THEIR AND RE
DISSOCIATES FOR THE PROFESSIONAL
ENGINEERS IN CALIFORNIA
GOVERNMENT.
WE'D LIKE TO SUPPORT THE VERY
MODEST -- CAPITAL OUTLAY SUPPORT
INCREASE OF FORTY EIGHT
POSITIONS BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY.
WE WANTED TO COMMEND THE
DEPARTMENT FOR THE OUTSTANDING
JOB THAT THEY DID ON HIRING AND
THE LAST YEAR -- WHEN THIS
COMMITTEE MET LAST YEAR I THINK
THAT THERE WAS A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF CONCERN BY BOTH THE?
COMMITTEE THE STAFF AND AND US
THAT THEY WOULD HAVE
DIFFICULTIES REACHING THOSE
HIRING LEVELS AND THEY REALLY
HAVE -- IN CREATIVE AND HAVE
DONE A GOOD JOB MEETING THE
HIRING GOALS THAT YOU ALL SETS
WE WANTED TO THANK HIM FOR THAT.
ALSO JUST ON ASSEMBLYMEMBER
REYES COMMENTS ON DIVERSITY --
THE DEPARTMENTS ALSO DONE A VERY
GOOD JOB HIRING A VERY DIVERSE.
GROUP OF ENGINEERS OUR CURRENT
PRESIDENT IS A FEMALE OUR PAST
PRESIDENT WAS A FEMALE IS A
FEMALE -- WE'VE HAD LEGISLATORS
OF COME TO OUR MEETINGS AND SAID
IT LOOKS LIKE GOING TO A YOU AND
MEETING IN.
SO AGAIN THE DEPARTMENT HAS A
GOOD JOB AND SHOULD BE COMMENDED
ON BOTH THOSE THINGS THANK YOU
FOR THAT.
AND THAT APPEARS TO BE THE ONLY
A SPEAKER ON THESE TWO ITEMS --
IS THERE -- CONSENSUS AROUND TO
HOLDING THIS ITEM OPEN WITH THE
DIRECTION -- TO WORK AS A
PREVIOUSLY INDICATED EVERY OKAY
WITH THAT RIGHT THEN THAT'S WHAT
WE'LL DO HOLD THE ITEM OPEN --
SEE YOU AGAIN IN A FEW WEEKS.
WE'RE NOW MOVING ON TO THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY -- AND
ISSUE NUMBER THREE THE PROJECT
UPDATE REPORT.
WELCOME SURE BROUGHT MY REPORT
WITH ME.
GOOD MORNING CAN FOLLOW ALONG.
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
SET MY NAME'S BRIAN ANISE --
I'VE RECENTLY BEEN APPOINTED BY
GOVERNOR NEWSOME AS THE CHIEF
FINANCIAL OFFICER AT HIGH SPEED
RAIL.
ABBOTT PENNY MY START DATE THERE
I COME TO YOU TODAY IS THE
SECRETARY OF TRANSPORTATION --
I'M ALSO JOINED ON MY LEFT HERE
BY RUSSELL FONG WHO'S THE
CURRENT CFO AT HIGH SPEED RAIL
AND HE'S MOVING OVER TO THE CFO.
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT TO
HELPFULLY THEIR EXPANSION AND IN
HOUSING ACTIVITIES THEY'RE GOING
TO DO OVER THERE -- THE TWENTY
NINETEEN PROJECT UPDATE REPORT
WAS RELEASED ON MAY FIRST AND
RECONFIRMS GOVERNOR NEWSOME'S
APPROACH TO HIGH SPEED RAIL.
A VERSION THE FIRST LAID OUT IN
THE STATE OF THE STATE IN
FEBRUARY THAT VISION GETS HIGH
SPEED TRAINS ON THE GROUND IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE LIVES WITHIN
OUR FISCAL MEANS AND REMAINS
COMMITTED TO THE VISION OF HIGH
SPEED RAIL CONNECTING THE BAY
AREA IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
THE PROJECT UPDATE REPORT
ADDRESSES STATUTORILY REQUIRED
REPORTING ELEMENTS SUCH AS
UPDATES ON COST ACCOMPLISHMENTS
AND RISKS.
ADDITIONALLY THIS YEAR'S PER OR
PROJECT UPDATE REPORT INCLUDES
INFORMATION THE AUTHORITY
COMMITTED TO PROVIDE AT THE TIME
OF LAST YEAR'S BUSINESS PLAN.
FIRST THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
BUSINESS PLANET INDICATED A
FUNDING GAP FOR THE VALLEY TO
VALLEY SEGMENT.
THAT WAS THE COST OF TIMELY AND
PACHECO PASS FROM YOUR EYE TO
MADERA.
AT THE AUTHORITY INDICATED THE
TWENTY NINETEEN PROJECT UP THEY
WERE POOR WOULD INCLUDE AN
ANALYSIS OF EARLY HIGH SPEED
SERVICE -- IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
SAN FRANCISCO SEGMENT.
THAT ANALYSIS INDICATES THE BEST
SEGMENT FOR EARLY INTERVENTION
SERVICE IS THE MERCED TO
BAKERSFIELD SEGMENT.
THAT SEGMENT WOULD DECREASE TRIP
TIMES BY NINETY TWO HUNDRED
MINUTES AND ABOUT DOUBLE RAIL
RIDERSHIP ACROSS THE ACE SAN
JOAQUIN AND NEW HIGH SPEED RAIL
SERVICE [inaudible]
SECOND.
A TRAIN OPERATOR REVIEWED THE
CAPITAL COST ESTIMATES AND
PERFORMED A BENCHMARKING
EXERCISE FOCUSED ON CAST COST
CATEGORIES THAT ARE NOT LOCATION
DEPENDENT SUCH AS TUNNELS.
VIADUCTS AND BRIDGES.
AND COMPARED THAT TO COST
EXPERIENCE IN GERMANY WHICH IS
WHERE THEY DETAILS FROM.
AT THAT ANALYSIS SUGGESTED SOME
OPPORTUNITIES FOR COST SAVINGS
WHICH WILL BE FURTHER EXPLORED
DURING PRELIMINARY ENGINEERING
AND FINAL DESIGN PHASES.
LASTLY THE AUTHORITY COMPLETED A
MORE RIGOROUS RISK EVALUATION
AND MADE UPDATES TO CENTRAL
VALLEY COST ESTIMATES.
THESE ESTIMATES INCREASE THE
CONTINGENCY FROM ABOUT FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION TO ABOUT ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION.
AND INCLUDED SOME SCOPE
INCREASES.
AB THREE HUNDRED SIXTY TWO
MILLION AND COST INCREASES FOUR
HUNDRED SEVENTY SEVEN MILLION.
THESE.
INCLUDE.
ITEMS SUCH AS INTRUSION BARRIERS
LEGAL SETTLEMENTS AND TRACKS AND
SYSTEMS.
THIS PROJECT UP THE REPORT
FOCUSES THE EXISTING FUNDING
RESOURCES THE STATE HAS
IDENTIFIED TO GET A SECTION OF
HIGH SPEED RAIL UP AND RUNNING.
THEY CAN DEMONSTRATE THE
VIABILITY OF THE BROADER PROJECT.
SPECIFICALLY THE REPORT PROPOSES
BUILDING THE FRESNO SHE'S ME
MERCED FRESNO BAKERSFIELD LYING.
A BUILDING BLOCK PROJECT THAT
MATCHES THE AVAILABLE FUNDING WE
HAVE BASED ON THE BEST
INFORMATION WE HAVE TODAY.
AT THE SAME TIME THE PROJECT UP
THE REPORT MAINTAINS EXISTING
COMMITMENTS TO BOOK AN PROJECTS.
AND COMPLETION OF ENVIRONMENTAL
DOCUMENTS ON THE ENTIRE SAN
FRANCISCO TO ANAHEIM SIX SECTION.
WHEN THESE INITIAL INVESTMENTS
ARE COMPLETE THE STATE WILL HAVE
A VERY SUBSTANTIAL INVESTMENT IN
UPGRADING RAIL IN THE STATE?
CALTRAIN ELECTRIFICATION IN THE
BAY AREA ON A FIFTY MILE SEGMENT
INITIALLY USED BY CALTRAIN BUT
LATER I SHARED WITH HIGH SPEED
RAIL THIS INVESTMENT INCREASES
SPEEDS CAPACITY IMPROVE THEIR
QUALITY.
CENTRAL VALLEY HIGH SPEED RAIL
EARLY INTERNS SERVICE ON A
HUNDRED SEVENTY ONE MILES.
MAKING THE MAJOR SOUTHERN SAN
JOAQUIN CITIES OF OUR SAID
FRESNO BAKERSFIELD GETTING HIGH
SPEED TRAINS OPERATING IN
CALIFORNIA.
IN ACHIEVING SUBSTANTIAL
MOBILITY ECONOMIC AND AIR
QUALITY BENEFITS.
LOS ANGELES UNION STATION RUN
THROUGH TRACKS IN ROSECRANS MARK
OR GRADE SEPARATION.
INCREASING SPEEDS IN CAPACITY
THROUGH LOS ANGELES INITIALLY
BENEFITING METROLINK CAM
SURFLINER AMTRAK.
BUT LATER SHARED WITH HIGH SPEED
RAIL. TO GOVERNOR NEWSOME REMAIN
SUPPORTIVE OF THE VALLEY TO
VALLEY VISION OF HIGH SPEED
GROUND BELIEVES THE CENTRAL
VALLEY BUILDING BLOCK.
IS A TANGIBLE FIRST STEP TO
REALIZING THAT VISION. TO MAKE
THE FALL SAN FRANCISCO TO LA LA
ANAHEIM SYSTEM A REALITY WE
FIRST NEED TO BUILD A WORKING
SEGMENT. TO DEMONSTRATE HIGH
SPEED RAIL TO CALIFORNIANS.
THIS PROJECT UP THE REPORT ALSO
FULLY EMBRACES THE AUDITOR'S
FINDINGS FROM THE NOVEMBER
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NOT IT.
CLEANING SIGNIFICANT
TRANSPARENCY OVERSIGHT AND
MANAGEMENT REFORMS.
INSPIRATION IS ALREADY MADE THE
PROJECT MORE TRANSPARENT AND
ACCOUNTABLE.
BY POSTING CHANGE ORDERS ON THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL WEBSITE.
ADDITIONALLY THIS PROJECT UPDATE
REPORT INCLUDES THIS THOROUGH
DISCUSSION OF RISK INCLUDING
RISK RELATED TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU.
CAN YOU GO INTO A LITTLE BIT
MORE DETAIL ABOUT HOW.
YOU -- WHAT WHAT THE PARAMETERS
WERE THAT WERE USED -- AFTER THE
EARLY OPERATOR -- OPTIONS SURE.
WELL THIS WAS BASED OFF THE THE
CALL IN THE TWENTY EIGHT
BUSINESS PLAN TO LOOK AT THE
VALLEY TO VALLEY SEGMENT
REALIZING THE CURRENT FUNDING
WASN'T SUFFICIENT TO FULLY BUILT
VALLEY TO VALLEY.
WITH THAT GAP IN THE MIDDLE OF
THAT THE TUNNEL SUPER JACO SO
THE ET -- FOCUSED BOTH ON THE
SAN FRANCISCO TO GILROY SEGMENT.
AND THE CENTRAL VALLEY SEGMENT.
AND LOOKED AT WHAT THE BENEFITS
WOULD BE OF HAVING A HIGH SPEED
OPERATION ON THOSE SEGMENTS AND
OF COURSE IN THE BAY AREA -- YOU
HAVE THE CALTRAIN SERVICE THAT
WOULD BE RUNNING -- ON THOSE
SAME -- ALIGNMENTS IN IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEYRECOGNIZING THE
ACE AND THE SAN JOAQUIN SERVICE --
LA -- DID YOU WANNA MAKE SOME
COMMENTS LATER HAILING CHRISTY
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE WE HAVE IDENTIFIED SIX
MAJOR ISSUES FOR LEGISLATIVE
CONSIDERATION -- PRELIMINARILY
I'M SO BROUGH BRIEFLY SUMMARIZE
THOSE FOR YOU THAT'S ACCESSIBLE
YES -- SO AS WAS INDICATED BY
THE AUTHORITY.
THIS PROJECT UPDATE REPORT
REFOCUSES THE PROJECT IT
REFOCUSES IT ON A SEGMENT
BETWEEN MERCED IN BAKERSFIELD.
THIS IS BASED IN PART BY THIS
ANALYSIS THAT THAT WAS CONDUCTED
BY THE EARLY TRAIN OPERATOR --
WE WOULD KNOW HOWEVER THAT THE
THAT ANALYSIS IS HIGHLY
DEPENDENT ON SOME THE
ASSUMPTIONS THAT THAT REALLY
TRAIN OPERATOR MADE IN TERMS OF
HOW THIS.
US SERVICE WOULD INTEGRATE WITH
EXISTING OTHER SERVICES
INCLUDING A SEND AN AMTRAK AS
WELL AS THE CUSTOM CAPITAL
PROJECT THAT WE NEED TO OCCUR I
FOR EXAMPLE HAVING SHARED
STATION AT MERCED WHICH IS NOT I
AM CURRENTLY -- I SO CERTAINLY --
SHOULD THESE ASSUMPTIONS NOT
MATERIALIZE THAT COULD AFFECT
BOTH THE RIDERSHP AND REVENUE
PROJECTIONS THAT ARE ASSUME.
THE SECOND ISSUE WANTED TO FLAG
IS THAT WE BELIEVE THE ACTUAL
COST OF THE PROJECT COULD
POTENTIALLY BE HIGHER THAN ARE
ESTIMATED.
I'M PART OF THIS IS JUST
INTRINSIC TO ANY LARGE MAKE UP
PROJECT WHICH IS OF COURSE --
SUBJECT IS SUBSTANTIAL
UNCERTAINTY I THIS PROJECT ALSO
HAS SOME UNIQUE RISKS INCLUDING
REGARDING SCHEDULING -- WHICH
COULD INCREASE COSTS -- FOR THE
MORE WE JUST WANTED TO ALSO HIGH
LATE -- AN ASPECT OF THE FORTIES
ASSUMPTIONS FOR HOW IT HAS COME
TO ITS ITS ESTIMATE SO IT'S
INDICATED THAT -- IN THE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN PLAN IT'S AT
THE BASELINE BUDGET SUCH THAT
THERE'S A 10% CHANCE THAT --
THAT BASICALLY THE THE PROJECT
WILL COME IN AT OR BELOW THAT
BASELINE BUDGET -- IT'S NOT
REVISED THAT APPROACH TO TO
BASICALLY ASSUME A 70% CHANCE
THAT THE PROJECT WILL COME IN AT
OR BELOW THAT COST ESTIMATE BUT
ONLY FOR MERCED TO BAKERSFIELD.
WE HAVEN'T RE LOOKED AT THE
ENTIRE PROJECT COST AND WE
BELIEVE THAT IF YOU DID THAT FOR
THE ENTIRE PROJECT YOU PROBABLY
END UP WITH THAT A HIGHER COST
ESTIMATE AND THAT IS REFLECTED
FOR THE ENTIRE.
WHO HELPED HOW COULD YOU DO THAT
IF YOU DON'T KNOW -- AT THIS
POINT THE THE ROCK HASN'T BEEN
DETERMINED SO.
SO THEY DO HAVE SOME PRELIMINARY
YEAH THAT THAT'S A VERY GOOD
QUESTION THEY THEY HAVE SOME --
COST ESTIMATES THAT THEY PUT
TOGETHER FOR PHASE ONE IN
PREVIOUS BUSINESS PLANS OF FOR
EXAMPLE -- THAT TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN BUSINESS PLAN.
IDENTIFIED ABOUT SEVENTY SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS OF A TOTAL COSTS
THAT WAS ASSUMING A ROUTE --
THAT WOULD YOU THE ROUTE THAT
SORT OF BEEN DISCUSSED I
CERTAINLY THEIR REFINING THAT
THE SPECIFICS OF IT BUT I THINK
THE GENERAL ROUTE HAS BEEN --
YOU KNOW HAS BEEN -- LAID OUT
SUCH THAT THEY FELT COMFORTABLE
THAT THEY COULD IDENTIFY THAT
PROJECT COST -- CERTAINLY
THERE'S MORE -- THERE'S A
GREATER RANGE OF POTENTIAL COSTS --
FOR THOSE ASPECT THAT HAVEN'T
BEEN BEEN PRECISELY NAIL DOWN TO
THOSE SEGMENTS THAT -- THEY
HAVEN'T FIGURED OUT EXACTLY THAT
PICKED THE CORRIDOR ARE SUBJECT
MORE UNCERTAINTY BUT THEY WERE
STILL ABLE TO PROVIDE A RANGE
AND AT A POINT ESTIMATE.
BUT THE POINT ESTIMATE I THINK
OUR OUR POINT IS THE POINT
ESTIMATE WAS SAT ON IT.
USING A LESS CONSERVATIVE
METHODOLOGY THAN THEY'RE USING
NOW FOR MERCED TO BAKERSFIELD
AND IF THEY APPLIED THAT MORE
CONSERVATIVE METHODOLOGY TO THE
ENTIRE COST ESTIMATE.
BUT WE BELIEVE THAT THE COST AS
IT WOULD BE HIGHER THAN THAN NOW
WHAT THEY'RE SAYING IS AT
SEVENTY NINE BILLION DOLLARS
BECAUSE THERE'S AT A ROUGHLY TWO
BILLION DOLLAR COST.
THAT THAT THE US 70% -- ESTIMATE
ABOVE OR BELOW IS.
KIND OF INTERESTING BECAUSE IT'S
SUCH A OF A LARGE NUMBER -- IT.
IT IT'S A IT'S IT COULD BE 70%
HIGHER 70% LOWER OR IS A 70%
CHANCE THAT IT COULD BE HIGHER.
OR LOWER OR IS THAT SKEWED TO IN
ONE DIRECTION OR ANOTHER IT
SEEMS LIKE IT WOULD BE.
YES TO MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
THE WAY THEY DID IT BEFORE THEY
BASICALLY -- DID A SIMULATION A
MODELING EXERCISE TO LOOK AT
SORT OF WHAT ARE THE CHANCES
THAT THE COST ESTIMATES WOULD
WOULD.
BE IT WOULD FALLING DIFFERENT AT
DIFFERENT LEVELS BASICALLY AND
PREVIOUSLY THEY TOOK THAT SORT
OF I'M GONNA DISTRIBUTION AT
THAT LEVEL OF LITTLE BIT OF
TECHNICAL.
KIND OF EXERCISE BUT AND THEY
BASICALLY SET THE POINT ESTIMATE --
ASSUMING THAT ESSENTIALLY --
THERE'S ONLY A 10% CHANCE THEY
WOULD STAY WITHIN THAT THAT
BUDGET THAT'S PRETTY LOW I MEAN
WHEN THERE'S A 90% CHANCE ARE
GONNA GO OVER BUDGET RIGHT.
AND THAT'S THAT'S A THAT'S A
PRETTY THAT'S NOT A VERY
CONSERVATIVE ESTIMATE SO THEY'VE
INDICATED THAT NOW BASED ON BEST
PRACTICES THE REVISING THAT
ASSUMPTION AND NOW THEY'RE
TAKING A MUCH MORE CONSERVATIVE
APPROACH -- AND TAKING A 70% SO
NOW THEY'RE ASSUMING -- A
CONTINGENCY SUCH THAT THERE'S A
70% CHANCE THEY'LL STAY AT OR
BELOW THAT COST ESTIMATE.
THAT SEEMS VERY REASONABLE TO US.
MISS HURT YEAH I KNOW IT'S AT OR%
BACK OR BELOW SO NOW THEY'RE
DOING 70% AT OR BELOW THAT COST
AFTER I I NEED MAY HAVE NOT MADE
THAT CLEAR I APOLOGIZE BUT
THAT'S A MUCH.
THAT DOES SEEM LIKE A MUCH
PREFERABLE KIND OF ASSUMPTION
IT'S IT'S CERTAINLY MORE
CONSERVATIVE THAN THAN THE 10%
APPROACH -- BUT WE WOULD AND WE
WOULD KNOW THAT THEY ONLY APPLY
THAT METHODOLOGY. TO MERCED TO
BAKERSFIELD NOT TO THE ENTIRE
PROJECT SO IF YOU DIDN'T IF YOU
HAD APPLIED THAT METHODOLOGY TO
THE ENTIRE PROJECT.
I YOU WOULD LIKE WE HAVE A
HIGHER COST ESTIMATES WOULD I BE
CORRECT IN ASSUMING THAT'S
BECAUSE THERE IS A LOT -- AS AS
WE SIT HERE NOW WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT A PROJECT THAT -- TO AS IT
MOVES FORWARD INTO THOSE OTHER
AREAS IS FAR LESS PREDICTABLE --
FORCE AS HERS SITTING HERE NOW
SO YEAH I AND I BILL EIGHTY TO
KIND OF USE THAT THAT MORE
CONSERVATIVE NUMBER.
OF APPLIES HERE BUT IT.
WOULD BE DIFFICULT TO APPLY TO
THE LONGER TERM -- YET THEY DO
HAVE THEY DO HAVE A RATIONAL
WITHIN THE BUSINESS AND I THINK
IT'S SOME ALONG THOSE LINES AND
THEY CAN PROBABLY SPEAK TO THAT
IN MORE DETAIL.
HOWEVER I THINK WE WOULD WE
WOULD ARGUE THAT ACTUALLY YOU
MIGHT WANT TO I THINK HOW THAT
CONSERVATIVE APPROACH FOR THOSE
VERY AND CERTAIN AREAS AS WELL --
BECAUSE THERE'S I MEAN YES YOU
CAN HAVE A LARGER RANGE IN TERMS
OF YOUR YOUR POSSIBLE COST BUT
IN TERMS OF SETTING YOUR POINT
ESTIMATE FOR BUDGETING PURPOSES.
WE STILL BELIEVE THAT IT MAKES
SENSE TO SET THAT SUCH THAT
THERE'S A RELATIVELY SMALL
CHANCE TO GO OVER THAT BUDGET
BECAUSE WHEN YOU KNOW WE DON'T
WANNA -- WE WANNA MAKE SURE
WE'RE REALISTIC IN SETTING THAT
BUDGET A SO THAT THE LEGISLATURE
REALLY HAS A SENSE OF WHAT IS
COMMITTING.
TO SO I I THINK I INTERRUPTED
TELL YEAH.
AS FOR THAT BUT BEFORE YOU MOVE
ON WHEN -- LA WAS COMPLETED --
HER REMARKS MR ANAS MAYBE YOU
CAN RESPOND TO THAT PARTICULAR
ISSUE OF WHETHER OR NOT WE CAN
APPLY A MORE CONSERVATIVE --
APPROACH TO COST -- AT ESTIMATES
FOR THE FUTURE SEGMENTS.
SO AT THE I APOLOGIZE -- IT SO
THE THIRD MAJOR ISSUE THAT WE
WANTED TO FLAG FOR FOLKS IS THAT
WE BELIEVE IT'S UNCLEAR WHETHER
THEY'LL BE SUFFICIENT FUNDING TO
COMPLETE THE MERCED TO
BAKERSFIELD SEGMENT -- AND
PARTLY THAT'S BECAUSE OF THIS
COST UNCERTAINTY CERTAINLY COSTS
COULD BE HIGHER IT'S ALSO
BECAUSE THERE'S SOME UNCERTAINTY
ON THE REVENUE SIDE AS WELL --
AS WAS MENTIONED -- THERE'S A
THREE POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
IN FEDERAL FUNDING I BELIEVE THE
COMMITTEE IS AWARE OF THIS THAT --
THAT THE PROJECT HAS RECEIVED
HOWEVER THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT --
HAS THREATENS TO RESCIND THESE
DOLLARS AND SHOULD THAT OCCUR --
THAT WOULD MAKE IT MUCH MORE
DIFFICULT FOR THE PROJECT TO BE
FULLY FUNDED -- ADDITIONALLY
THERE'S ALWAYS SOME UNCERTAINTY
WITH CAP AND TRADE REVENUES AS
THE AS THE COMMITTEE IS IS AWARE
AND I'M SO WE THINK THAT THE
ASSUMPTIONS ON THE CABIN TRADE
REVENUES ARE REASONABLE BUT BUT
SUBJECT TO SOME UNCERTAINTIES WE
WANTED TO FLAG THAT FOR FOLKS AS
WELL -- CERTAINLY TO THE EXTENT
THAT THOSE FUNDS DON'T
MATERIALIZE OUR COSTS ARE HIGHER
THE GENERAL FUND -- OTHER
FUNDING SOURCES COULD BE
REQUIRED -- FOURTH WE WANTED TO
FIGHT THAT THERE'S NO FUNDING
PLAN BEYOND MERCED TO
BAKERSFIELD AT THIS POINT SO ON
TO THE EXTENT THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WANTED TO GO BEYOND
THAT SEGMENT AND WANTED TO
EXTEND AND YOU ALL ABOUT IT
VALLEY OR DO ALL OF PHASE ONE
ADDITIONAL FUNDS WOULD BE.
REQUIRED -- LIKELY FROM THE
GENERAL FUND -- AT LEAST AND IN
WHOLE OR IN PART -- FIFTH -- WE
DID WANT TO ALSO HIGHLIGHT THAT
THE LEGISLATURE HAS VARIOUS
OPTIONS FOR MOVING FORWARD SO WE
CONTINUE TO THINK THIS IS A GOOD
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO ASSESS WHAT IT'S PRIORITIES
ARE AND HOW IT WANTS TO APPROACH
THE PROJECT.
ON THIS IS THAT A LITTLE BIT OF
A SHIFT IN APPROACH FOR THE
AUTHORITY AND ALSO JUST GIVEN
GIVEN THIS FUNDING GAP AND GIVEN.
SORT OF ALL OF THE DIFFERENT
CONSIDERATIONS FACING THE
LEGISLATURE WE THINK THIS IS A
GOOD CHANCE TO SERVE STEP BACK
AND THINK ABOUT -- WHAT AT THE
LEGISLATURE WANTS TO DO IN TERMS
OF ITS -- IT'S PRIORITIES FOR
THIS PROJECT I THEY SAID THERE
ARE THIS IS CERTAINLY ONE OPTION
BUT THERE ARE OTHER OPTIONS
AVAILABLE THE LEGISLATURE COULD
COMMIT FOR EXAMPLE TO A SHORTER
SEGMENT JUST DOING FOR EXAMPLE
THE INITIAL CONSTRUCTION SEGMENT.
COULD DO A LONGER SEGMENT -- IT
COULD IT COULD FOCUS ON HIGH
SPEED SERVICE AS IS PROPOSED IN
THIS PROJECT UPDATE REPORT OR IT
COULD -- HAVE SOME KIND OF
EITHER IN AROUND OUR LONGER TERM
SERVICE THAT WOULD BE.
LESS HIGH SPEED IT UP
POTENTIALLY OR COULD EVEN USE
CONVENTIONAL DIESEL A SERVICE
THERE VARIETY OF OPTIONS THAT
ARE AVAILABLE TO LEGISLATURE --
WE THINK THAT THEY SHOULD ALL BE
CONSIDERED AND CERTAINLY THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD EVALUATE THEM --
AND THEN FINALLY WE DO LAY OUT
SOME POTENTIAL CONSIDERATIONS AS
AS LEGISLATURE EVALUATE THOSE
OPTIONS ALL JUST VERY QUICKLY.
BRIEFLY SUMMARIZE THEM ONE IS
COST -- TO THE INITIAL
CONSTRUCTION SEGMENT IS NOW
ESTIMATED TO COST TWELVE POINT
FOUR BILLION THAT'S UP BY ONE
POINT EIGHT BILLION FROM
PREVIOUS ESTIMATES.
ON THE EXTENSIONS TO MERCED AND
BAKERSFIELD IN TOTAL ARE
ESTIMATED TO COST ABOUT FOUR
BILLION MORE.
THE SECOND CONSIDERATION IS
TRANSPORTATION BENEFITS SO WE
BELIEVE THE LEGISLATURE GOING TO
WANT TO WEIGH THE TRANSPORTATION
BENEFITS THEM ACCESSIBILITY
MOBILITY BENEFITS ASSOCIATED
WITH A DIFFERENT OPTIONS AGAINST
THEIR COSTS.
SO FOR EXAMPLE THOSE EXTENSIONS
YOU DO THOSE PROVIDE FOR BILLION
DOLLARS WORTH OF BENEFITS -- AND
THAT'S GOING TO BE THAT THE
CHOICE FACING THE LEGISLATURE.
I'M ALSO WE WE RECOMMEND
CONSIDERING EFFECTS ON LOCAL
COMMUNITIES BUT IN TERMS OF
CONSTRUCTION IMPACTS -- AND AND
DISRUPTIONS AS WELL AS ECONOMIC
BENEFITS THAT CAN BE PROVIDED --
AND THEN ALSO HIGHLIGHT THAT
THERE ARE -- THE LEGISLATURE'S
GONNA WANNA CONSIDERED ANY RISKS
AND UNCERTAINTIES ASSOCIATED
WITH THE OPTIONS THAT AGENDA
DOES A REALLY NICE JOB OF
OUTLINING A NUMBER OF THOSE --
YOU KNOW THIS COULD BE INVOLVED
COST INCREASES COORDINATION WITH
OTHER ENTITIES WE BRIEFLY
TOUCHED ON THOSE AS WELL AS A
POTENTIAL ISSUES RELATED TO
COMPLIANCE WITH PROPOSITION ONE
A REQUIREMENTS AND REQUIREMENTS
FOR FEDERAL FUNDS -- SO HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU
AB STRATEGY WANNA TAKE A CRACK
AT ANSWERING THAT EARLIER
QUESTION SURE SURE.
AND THE ISLAND IT UP TO
QUESTIONS FROM FROM THEM THAT
WAS A GOOD DESCRIPTION OF THAT
THE CHANGE IN THAT AND
PROBABILITIES AND RISK AND SO
FORTH AND THAT.
GENERALLY THE PROJECT UPDATE
REPORT DOES NOT INCLUDE AT
REEVALUATION OF ALL PROJECT CASA
TYPICALLY IS THAT BUSINESS PLANS
THAT ARE DONE IN THE EVEN
NUMBERED YEARS.
SO THE HIGH SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY
BE WORKING ON UPDATED ESTIMATES
FOR THE AT TWENTY TWENTY A
BUSINESS PLAN.
AND CERTAINLY BRING SOME OF
THESE THESE LESSONS LEARNED FROM
THE CENTRAL VALLEY INTO THAT --
INTO THAT RE ESTIMATION OF THAT
THE BROADER PHASE ONE COST.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU A MISS
PATTERSON AND YOU HAD YOUR HAND
UP FOLLOWED BY MISS RIVAS.
AND MISTER PHONE.
THANK YOU.
LET ME START WITH PAGE A FIFTEEN
OUR FOR THE FIRST TIME IT IS NOW
APPARENT IN YOUR OWN.
PLAN THAT THEY HIGH SPEED RAIL
WILL REQUIRE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
OF SUBSIDY.
AND THAT'S ON PAGE.
FIFTEEN I WANT TO READ TO YOU.
STREETS AND HIGHWAYS CODE
SECTION TWO SEVEN OH FOUR POINT.
OH EIGHT THE AUTHORITY CANNOT
SPEND THIS IS A SUMMARY THAT
CANNOT SPEND BOND FUNDS.
UNTIL IT OBTAINS A CERTIFICATION
FROM INDEPENDENT FIRM THAT THE
SERVICE WILL NOT REQUIRE A
SUBSIDY.
THE LANGUAGE IS PROUD TO
COMMITMENT BY PROCEEDS OF THE
BOND AND THEIR SEVERAL STORY
SHALL HAVE PROVIDED.
AND GOES ON TO SPECIFICALLY
OUTLINED PRECISELY.
WHAT HAS TO BE?
CONCLUDED A REPORT REPORTS
PREPARED BY -- INDEPENDENT
FINANCIAL FIRMS IT'S AFTER.
AND I CAN I DRIVE YOUR ATTENTION --
TO THE SECTION NO SUB HEADED.
D. AND I'M QUOTING.
THE PLANNED PASSENGER.
TRAIN SERVICE TO BE PROVIDED BY
THE AUTHORITY.
OR PURSUANT TO ITS AUTHORITY
WILL NOT REQUIRE OPERATING
SUBSIDY.
HAVE YOU NOT JUST DISQUALIFIED
YOURSELF FROM PROP ONE A FUNDS.
NO SIR A FEAR LOOK AT THAT PROP
ONE EIGHTY AND THE REQUIREMENTS --
AROUND THAT IN IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY -- WHEN WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON THE HUNDRED NINETEEN
MILE SEGMENT -- SINCE. TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE THAT AS WITH THE
FEDERAL GRANT ALWAYS ENVISIONED
THIS IDEA OF INTERIM SERVICER
INTERIM USE OF THAT FACILITY.
AS AS BEEN PLANS WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ON RUNNING
TRAINS ON THAT SEGMENT -- IF
THERE'S SAY ANY GAP BETWEEN YOU
KNOW HAVING THAT SEGMENT BUILT
OUT.
AND AND ADD LONGER HAVE HIGH
SPEED RAIL SERVICE SO -- WITH
LOOKED AT THAT SERVICE WITH THE
IDEA THAT OTHER OPERATORS --
WOULD BE USING THE FACILITY IN
THE INTERIM BEFORE YOU HAVE THAT
LONGER HIGH SPEED RAIL SEGMENT
THAT WOULD BE OPERATED.
DIRECTLY BY HIGH SPEED RAIL --
CONSISTENT WITH THAT REQUIREMENT --
LEGALLY -- IT'S SIMILAR TO THE
CALTRAIN EXAMPLE IN THE BAY AREA --
THERE WITH THE BOOK AND FINDS
ABOUT SAYS SIX HUNDRED MILLION A
PROP ONE A FUNDS -- HAVE GONE OR
ARE GOING TO THAT -- SEGMENT OF
CALTRAIN ELECTRIFICATION THAT
WOULD BE -- USED INITIALLY BY
CALTRAIN -- CALTRAIN RECEIVES
OPERATING SUBSIDIES TO RUN THAT
SERVICE -- LATER ON HIGH SPEED
RAIL WILL WILL BE ON THAT
SEGMENT AS WELL AS A SHARED
SEGMENT -- THERE WAS MENTION
ADDITIONALLY THERE WAS A A BILL
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MALL AND AB --
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY NINE THAT --
CLARIFIED AS SOME OF THOSE
PROVISIONS AROUND INVESTMENT OF
HIGH SPEED RAIL FUNDS THAT SERVE --
OTHER PASSENGER RAIL OPERATORS
AND THEIR INVESTMENTS THAT ARE
USEFUL FOR HIGH SPEED RAIL --
WHEN HIGH SPEED RAIL EVENTUALLY
GETS TO THOSE SEGMENTS -- BUT IN
THE INTERIM IT'S APPROPRIATE
WITH BOND PROCEEDS TO HAVE THOSE
EARLY INVESTMENTS IN THE
CORRIDOR.
AGAIN I'M I'M SPECIFICALLY
REFERRING TO OPERATIONAL SUBSIDY.
AND THE EXPRESS LANGUAGE IN THE
BOND.
WHAT YOU ARE SUGGESTING IS THAT
YOU WILL ESSENTIALLY OFF LOAD TO
AMTRAK FOR EXAMPLE IN CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA?
AND THEREFORE AMTRAK WILL HAVE
TO ABSORB -- THE THE SUBSIDY.
BUT THE LANGUAGE IS IS VERY
CLEAR THAT THE SERVICE.
PROVIDED BY THE AUTHORITY OR
PURSUANT TO YOUR AUTHORITY.
THE HAND THAT OFF. TO ANOTHER
AGENCY THAT IS GOING TO REQUIRE.
TAX PAYER AND AND CALIFORNIA
GOVERNMENT.
SUBSIDY WILL NOT REQUIRE
[inaudible]
OPERATING SUBSIDY -- TO ME THAT
LANGUAGE IS IS IS IS VERY CLEAR
AND I I THINK THAT -- THIS.
I THINK PUTS AT RISK.
AND I THINK YOU'VE ALREADY.
DISCOVERED THAT -- THERE IS
SUBSTANTIAL NOW NEW.
INFORMATION [inaudible]
THAT FUELS.
THE ONGOING LITIGATION AND
LAWSUIT OVER THE PROP ONE A
FUNDS.
WHAT I SUGGEST IS YOU'RE GOING
TO HAVE A VERY VERY HARD TIME?
OFF LOADING THAT -- TO AMTRAK OR
SOME OTHER OPERATOR BECAUSE IT
IT IT'S IT'S STILL PURSUANT TO
YOUR AUTHORITY.
YOUR YOU ARE CREATING A SYSTEM.
INITIALLY OPERATED WITH A
SUBSIDY WHICH I THINK IS
EXPRESSLY FORBIDDEN [inaudible]
BUT IT IS CLEAR YOU HAVE A
DIFFERENT VIEW ON THAT AND MY
GUESS IS THAT THIS WILL AGAIN
FEED -- LITIGATION -- I WANT --
TO WHAT TALK ABOUT [inaudible]
UP.
I WOULD I WAS REALLY STUNNED.
WHEN I WATCH AN NBC BAY AREA
INVESTIGATIVE [inaudible]
JOURNALISM [inaudible]
REPORT.
I WANT TO QUOTE -- JOE HEDGES
THE CHIEF OPERATING OFFICER.
NBC BAY AREA STORY ON APRIL
TWENTY NINTH.
SAYS I CAN'T SPEAK FOR YESTERDAY
I CAN ONLY SPEAK FOR TODAY AND
TOMORROW AND THAT IS EXACTLY
WHAT WE'RE DOING.
REPORTER ASKS WHAT ARE YOU GOING
TO BE DOING IN DECEMBER.
TWENTY TWENTY MRHEDGES SAYS
WE'RE GOING TO SEE
INFRASTRUCTURE COMPLETE WITH
PRANK PLANE.
RAIL.
ON TOP OF THAT [inaudible]
THE NBC.
REPORTER -- FOLLOW THAT UP --
AND THEN MISTER HEDGES CLARIFIED.
WHAT WE CALL PLANE RAIL?
SIMPLE RAIL THAT IS BASICALLY
CAPABLE OF RUNNING A TRAIN ON IT.
THE FOLLOW UP QUESTION FROM NBC
NOT A HIGH SPEED TRAIN.
QUOTE NO.
PROBABLY NOT.
END OF QUOTE.
ON TOP OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
WORTH OF HIGH SPEED.
CONCRETE.
YOU PLAN TO PUT.
SLOW SPEED RAIL.
AND YOU'RE CALLING THAT AN
INITIAL OPERATING SEGMENT.
NO THAT AND THAT THE QUOTE FROM.
THE CHIEF OPERATING OFFICER WAS
WAS MISINTERPRETED SO.
WHAT SAID WHAT IS REQUIRED BY
THE FEDERAL GRANT IS TO LAY DOWN
THE TRACK WORK AND THAT WAS WHAT
IS BEING REFERRED TO SO BY
TWENTY TWENTY TWO END OF?
TWENTY TWENTY TWO REQUIREMENT.
TO LAY DOWN THE TRACK LATER THE
PROJECT WAS EXPANDED WHEN WE DID
THE FUNDING PLAN AND AT LAKE
TWENTY SIXTEEN EARLY TWENTY
SEVENTEEN FOR THAT ONE A BONDS
TO INCLUDE ELECTRIFICATION.
OF THAT -- HUNDRED NINETEEN MILE
SEGMENT SO IT THAT'S THE
DISTINCTION I BELIEVE THAT WAS
BEING REFERRED TO YOU HAVE.
BY TWENTY TWENTY TWO PUTTING
DOWN THE TRACK BUT THAT TRACK IS
FULLY SUITABLE FOR HIGH SPEED
TRAINS.
THAT TRACK WON'T CHANGE WHAT
WILL BE ADDED THEN AS PART OF
THE THAT.
LATER PHASES THE ELECTRIFICATION
OF THAT WITHOUT THE
ELECTRIFICATION IT DOESN'T WORK
FOR HIGH SPEED RAIL TRUE OR NOT.
WHAT AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE WE'RE
IT'S PART OF THE COST IT'S PART
OF THE THE MERCED TO BAKERSFIELD
IS THE ELECTRIFICATION THERE
AGAIN THE THE CONCERN I AM
RAISING HERE IS CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA?
HAS BEEN THE BEGINNING PIG IN
ALL OF THIS AND WE HAVE HAD
THOUSANDS OF ACRES OF PRIME AG.
TORN UP WE HAVE -- LOTS OF OUR
STREETS AND ROADS AT THAT TORN
UP.
WE HAVE THESE CONCRETE MONUMENTS
TO HIGH SPEED RAIL.
AND YET.
BY THIS.
ADMITTANCE BY THE PLAN IN FRONT
OF US.
YOU'RE GONNA PUT PLAIN RAIL UP
THERE AND YOU'RE GONNA RUN SLOW
SPEED FOR WHAT A DECADE OR MORE.
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
KNOW WHAT'S IN THE PROJECT
UPDATE REPORT IS IS TO BUILD THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL -- CAPABLE
SYSTEM AND THE PROJECT UPDATE
REPORT INDICATES THAT -- YOU'D
HAVE SERVICE RUNNING FOR MERCED
TO BAKERSFIELD HIGH SPEED
SERVICE -- BY THE END OF TWENTY
TWENTY SEVEN AND THEN THE
EXTENSION NUMBER SAID BY THE END
OF TWENTY TWENTY AGAIN THAT.
THAT.
IS PREDICATED UPON YOUR ABILITY.
TO GET THE NECESSARY FUNDS
INCLUDING SUBSTANTIAL.
AMOUNTS OF FUNDS.
UP.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT -- I WANT.
TO DRAW YOUR TENSION AGAIN TO
THE NBC BAY AREA MAY.
THIRD STORY THESE ARE QUOTES
DIRECTLY OUT OF THE STORE THIS
IS.
SOME VERY GOOD INVESTIGATIVE
JOURNALISM AND I MIGHT SUGGEST
THAT.
WE BASICALLY GET -- ACCURACY
[inaudible]
FROM.
THE MEDIA AND FROM OUR AUDITOR
WE RARELY GET ACCURACY FROM
[inaudible]
THIS AUTHORITY.
AT THE PRESENT RATE OF
CONSTRUCTION HIGH SPEED RAIL
CANNOT MAKE THE FEDERAL DEADLINE
USE THE CONCLUSIONS OF THE STORY.
HIGH SPEED RAIL NEEDS TO BE
SPENDING A HUNDRED AND FORTY
NINE MILLION DOLLARS A MONTH TO
REACH THE TARGET DEADLINE.
AND THEY SAY AS OF MAY THIRD YOU
ONLY HIT THAT TARGET ONCE.
AND THE HIGH SPEED RAIL WAS
CONSTRUCTING THREE TIMES SLOWER
THAN THE NECESSARY.
PACE.
AND WHAT I FOUND INTERESTING WAS
IN THIS STORY ACCORDING TO THREE
HSR OFFICIALS WHO DID NOT WANT
TO BE QUOTED FOR FEAR.
OF RETRIBUTION THAT THEY'LL MISS.
AND THAT THE DEADLINE
[inaudible]
BY YEARS [inaudible]
YOU YOU.
SO I THINK I NOT ONLY ARE YOU I
THINK YOU'RE RISKING THE PROP
ONE A BUT I THINK YOU'RE RISKING
THE FEDERAL.
MONEY AND I THINK GIVEN THE
MANNER IN WHICH THESE PLANNED.
IS.
VERY ALMOST -- ANNUALLY OR
BIANNUALLY -- I THINK YOU'RE
RUNNING INTO VERY SERIOUS --
CREDIBILITY PROBLEMS WITH --
WITH THE FEDERAL.
THE GOVERNMENT BECAUSE I DON'T
THINK.
I DON'T I THINK THAT.
ANYBODY THAT LOOKS AT WHAT IS
BEFORE US HAS TO HAVE A REAL
GRAY RESERVATIONS THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO MEET THESE KIND OF
DEADLINES.
WHEN WE LOOK BACKWARDS YOU'VE
NEVER MET DEADLINES OF COST --
BUT BEFORE NEVER MET DEADLINES
OF COMPLETION.
BEFORE WHY SHOULD WE HAVE
CONFIDENCE THAT YOU CAN THE
DEADLINE.
COMPLETIONS THAT PUT IF YOU
DON'T MEET THEM WILL PUT AT RISK
BILLIONS OF A FEDERAL
[inaudible]
DOLLARS.
BUT THE THE SCHEDULE OF THE
TWENTY TWENTY TWO IS A IS A
CHALLENGING SCHEDULE BUT THE
PROJECT ON THE GROUND AND SOME
OF THE RISK AND THE INFORMATION
THE PROJECT UPDATE REPORTS SHOW
HOW WERE ADDRESSING THOSE ISSUES --
YOU KNOW IT'S IT'S MUCH MORE
GRANULAR AS THE PROJECT GOES
FURTHER ALONG -- TO THERE'S IN
YOUR AGENDA FOR EXAMPLE THERE'S
SOME ADDITIONAL INFORMATION ON
RIGHT AWAY ACQUISITION AND
THINGS LIKE THAT SO.
THERE'S YOU SEE THAT THE NUMBER
A SHRINKING -- RIGHT AWAY IS.
NEARING COMPLETION -- THE
STRUCTURES -- YOU LOOK AT THEM
ONE BY ONE AND THERE'S A LOT OF
GRADE SEPARATIONS -- THERE'S
GRADING WORK AT BETWEEN THOSE
GRADE SEPARATIONS SO AGAIN --
THE PROJECTS ADVANCING WITH THE
WORK BEING DONE WITH AT NEW.
TEAM COMING AND THE CEO ALL
OTHERS REALLY LOOKING AT MUCH
MORE GRANULAR ISSUES WITH EACH
SECTION EACH STRUCTURE.
ADDRESSING THOSE AND AGAIN
GETTING THOSE TO CONSTRUCTION AS
YOU SAY IS IS KEY AND THAT'S HOW
WE THINK OVER THE NEXT PERIOD.
REBUILD THAT CREDIBILITY IS
SHOWING THOSE STRUCTURES GETTING
UNDER CONSTRUCTION SHOWING THE
STRUCTURES GETTING COMPLETED.
YOU ARE PRESENTLY I UNDERSTAND
UNDER -- FEDERAL AUDIT.
BY THE INSPECTOR GENERAL.
MUCH OF THIS.
CONCERN WAS RAISED.
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
AUDITOR.
AND IN THE CALIFORNIA STATE
AUDITOR'S CONCLUSIONS AND REPORT --
HIGH SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY IS AT
GRAVE RISK.
OF CLAWBACK.
THIS HAD TO DO WITH THE EARLY
SPENDING -- LETTING OUT
CONTRACTS WHEN THE AUTHORITY
KNEW PRECISELY THEY DID NOT HAVE
THE PROPERTY UPON WHICH TO DO
THE CONSTRUCTION.
LOTS OF DELAYS AND AND THE
AUTHOR CONCLUDED THOSE WITHOUT
FUNDAMENTAL REASONS FOR THE
EARLY -- DELAYS -- YOU ARE UNDER
AUDIT ALRIGHT.
THAT HAVE YOU HAD REQUEST FOR
DOCUMENTATION ARE YOU BEING.
A FOURTH RIGHT AND TRANSPARENT
WITH -- THIS AUDIT I NOTICE IN.
YOUR REPORT THAT.
YOU ARE SUGGESTING THAT THERE IS
RADIO SILENCE AT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT -- DOES THAT NOT
INDICATE TO YOU THAT THERE IS A
SERIOUS ONGOING EFFORT HERE. TO
TAKE A LOOK AT HIGH SPEED RAIL
AND DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT.
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS SHOULD BE
CLAWED BACK BECAUSE OF THE PAST
PERFORMANCE AND THE LIKELIHOOD
THAT THE FUTURE PERFORMANCE IS
GOING TO MISS.
OUT ON DEADLINE.
ARE YOU
AWARE OF THE AUDIT AND ARE YOU
PARTICIPATING IN DOCUMENT
REQUESTS OR INFORMATION
[inaudible]
YEAH.
SO WE ARE WHERE RESPONDER
OUTGOING CHIEF FINANCIAL OFFICER
WE ARE WE ARE THAT TO THAT FOR A
IS ACTUALLY BEING AUDITED FROM
THEIR SIDE AND PART OF THAT
AUDIT IS LOOKING AT HIGH SPEED
RAIL INVOICES -- TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION ABOUT PERFORMANCE -- IT
WHAT I CAN SAYS WE WE ARE HAD
NOT TOUGH STRETCH RIGHT NOW ON
OUR PERFORMANCES BELOW WHAT OUR
EXPECTATIONS ARE.
WHEN WE WENT TO THE BOARD BACK
IN JUNE TO ASK FOR A BUDGET OF
ONE POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS
FOR THIS FISCAL YEAR -- WE DID
HI LIKE THAT IT WAS A VERY
AGGRESSIVE BUDGET AND A VERY
AGGRESSIVE SCHEDULE -- WITHOUT
BEING SAID WHAT GOING TO SURE
YOU IS THAT WE DO REPORT TO THE
BOARD OF FINANCE AND AUDIT
COMMITTEE EVERY MONTH ON OUR
PROGRESS AND THAT THOSE NUMBERS
ARE ACTUALLY.
PROBABLY COME FROM OUR BOARD
REPORTS OF OUR PROGRESS SO WE
ARE MONITORING OUR PROGRESS ON A
MONTHLY BASIS WE DO HAVE A PLAN
IN PLACE THAT WE BELIEVE.
WILL GET US BACK ON TRACK BUT IT
IS IT AN AGGRESSIVE SCHEDULE.
ONE FIVE MISTER CHAIRMAN ABOUT --
CONTINGENCY PLAN A PLAN B..
SINCE I'VE BEEN IN THE
LEGISLATURE AND SENSE I'VE BEEN
ON THIS COMMITTEE I'VE ASKED
REPEATEDLY WHAT IS YOUR PLAN B..
IT IS APPARENT THAT [inaudible]
THE PLAN.
ENVISIONED IS NO LONGER THE PLAN.
AND IN FACT I'VE SUGGESTED THAT.
THE MANNER IN WHICH YOU SCALE
DOWN CHOPPED UP CHANGED MOVED
AROUND THIS ENTIRE.
OPERATION IS IS THAT IT'S NOT
THIS IS IN THE BUSINESS PLAN
THIS IS ESSENTIALLY A GOING OUT
OF BUSINESS PLAN.
IT DEMONSTRATES THE UNRAVELING
IN MY JUDGMENT BECAUSE OF THE
RISK FACTORS AND AND AND
PREVIOUS HISTORY.
AND SO I WANT TO REFER TO THE
AUDITOR.
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR TO
ENSURE THAT IT IS ADEQUATELY
PREPARED.
IF IT IS ON ABLE TO MEET THE
FEDERAL GRANT DEADLINE OF
DECEMBER.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO THE AUTHORITY
SHOULD BY MAY TWENTY NINETEEN
DEVELOP A CONTINGENCY PLAN FOR
RESPONDING TO SUCH A SCENARIO.
THIS WAS THE AUTHORITIES
RESPONSE.
THE AUTHORITY CONCURS WITH THIS
RECOMMENDATION I GO DOWN TO THE
BOTTOM [inaudible]
APLICA PARAGRAPH.
AND WE WILL PREPARE A
CONTINGENCY PLAN IN ACCORDANCE
WITH THE CSA.
RECOMMENDATION.
PLANNED COMPLETION DATE MAY.
TWENTY NINETEEN I SEE NO.
PLAN B. IN.
THIS REPORT.
WHAT ON EARTH IS YOUR
CONTINGENCY PLAN?
YOU HAVE RIPPED UP CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA.
WE HAVE THOUSANDS OF ACRES OF
PRIME AG LAND THAT IS NO LONGER
IN USE.
ON TOP OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
WORTH OF HIGH SPEED CONTRACT YOU
BY YOUR OWN ADMISSION ARE LAYING
DOWN.
PLAIN RAIL.
AND AND THE RESULT OF THIS IS
THAT [inaudible]
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA -- IS
EXPERIENCING UP OF REAL LET DOWN
IN A HUGE DISAPPOINTMENT AND
WHAT WAS PROMISED.
AND WHAT IS PERFORMED.
AND WHAT WE SEE.
IS THIS PLAN ESSENTIALLY
ESTABLISHES WHAT AMOUNTS TO A
SLOW SPEED.
ROCK RAIL ROAD BETWEEN
BAKERSFIELD AND MADERA AND I
THINK IT'S QUESTIONABLE WHETHER
YOU HAVE THE MONEY TO GET IT. TO
MERCED SO WHAT ON EARTH.
DON'T DONE IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
NIGHT YOU WAKE UP SAYING OH MY
GOD THIS THING HAS REAL PROBLEMS.
WHAT ARE WE GOING TO DO IF?
EVERYBODY THAT DOES ANY KIND OF
LARGE SCALE PROJECTS LIKE THIS
HAVE CONTINGENCY PLANS.
WHERE IS YOUR PLAN B.?
YOU WERE ASKED.
BY THE AUDITOR TO PROVIDE.
ONE THE AUTHORITY COMMITTED TO
PROVIDING IT.
MAY OF THIS YEAR.
HERE WE HAVE LOTS OF PAGES
COLOUR PRETTY LOTS OF LANGUAGE.
WHAT'S MISSING ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT ELEMENTS OF THE AUDIT
THAT YOU COMMITTED [inaudible]
TO PRODUCE.
IF I COULD ANSWER A COUPLE WAYS
FIRST AT THE TIME LINE FOR THAT
IS THE SIX MONTH AUTO REPLY
WHICH IS -- COMING UP IN A FEW
WEEKS YEAH.
I WOULD MENTION AS FAR AGAIN ON
ON THE RESPECTFULLY DISAGREEING
WITH YOU ON WHAT IS PROPOSED FOR
THE CENTRAL VALLEY AGAIN.
WHAT'S PROPOSED FOR THE CENTRAL
VALLEY IS ELECTRIFIED HIGH SPEED
RAIL -- THE THE MERCED TO
BAKERSFIELD SEGMENT AS AN
ELECTRIFIED SEGMENT.
IF LESS IS IS ULTIMATELY BUILT
OUT -- THERE ARE CERTAINLY EVEN
IN THE GRANT AGREEMENT --
THERE'S CONTINGENCIES FOR CUT
OVER RAIL TO AMTRAK AND THINGS
LIKE THAT.
BUT WHAT.
IS PROPOSED HERE BECAUSE I THINK
IT'S VERY CONSISTENT WITH PROP
ONE NAY IS TO BUILD HIGH SPEED
RAIL.
AND SO WHAT WE'RE PROPOSING IS
WHAT WE BELIEVE IS THE OPTIMAL%
USE OF THE FUNDS WE HAVE
AVAILABLE TO COMPLETE THE BEST A
HIGH SPEED RAIL SEGMENT THAT CAN
BE ACHIEVED WITH THE FUNDING
AVAILABLE AND AGAIN.
BELIEVE THAT SAY.
HIGH QUALITY HIGH SPEED RAIL
LINE OF A HUNDRED SEVENTY ONE
MILES SO WE STAND BESIDE SO YOU
ARE YOU ARE -- ESSENTIALLY
SAYING THAT.
JOE HEDGES AND HIS COMMENTS ON
THE PUBLIC RECORD IN AN
INVESTIGATIVE.
STORY THAT SAID YOU PUT IN PLAIN
RAIL UP THERE AND KNOW WHAT
PROBABLY WILL NOT BE HIGH SPEED.
KNOW WHO'S TELLING US THE TRUTH.
WHAT WHAT IS BEING BUILT IS IS
HIGH SPEED RAIL AGAIN IT'S GETS
TO THE PHASING?
THE TWENTY TWENTY TWO TIMELINE
DOESN'T REQUIRE THE
ELECTRIFICATION THEY CAN'T
MERRY'S BE BUILT ON THAT
SCHEDULE.
BUT THOSE ARE PART OF THE
FUNDING PLAN AND THAT IS WHAT IS
PROPOSED IS TO BUILD ELECTRIFIED
HIGH SPEED RAIL.
DO YOU HAVE IT ARE YOU PLANNING
TO BUY ANY HIGH SPEED EQUIPMENT
OR ARE ARE DOES THAT WAIT.
UNTIL SUNDAY DECK MAYBE A DECADE
FROM NOW YOU HAVE THE MONEY.
TO MAKE PLAIN RAIL HIGH SPEED.
WHAT'S WHAT'S GONNA RUN ON THIS
THING.
WHEN YOU?
OPEN IT UP AND CALL THAT AN
INITIAL OPERATING SEGMENT.
ISN'T IT SUPPOSED TO DEMONSTRATE
THE ADVANTAGES OF HIGH SPED
RAIL AND WHEN YOU PUT PLAIN
TRACK ON IT AND THERE'S A EIGHT
NINE TEN YEAR WINDOW.
WHERE WE'RE NOT EVEN SURE THAT
YOU ELECTRIFY IN THAT PERIOD OF
TIME AS MISTER PATTERSON AND IF
YOU MISTER AND IF YOU MISSED THE
DEADLINE YOU HAVE FUND ISSUES
WE'VE GOT A WE'VE GOT A QUEUE
YOU'RE ASKING QUESTIONS THAT
HAVE ALREADY BEEN -- ANSWER BUT
IF YOU WANT TO PROVIDE A A
RELATIVE ZERO THAT'S MISTER
JENNER AND THINK THE ANSWERS OF
THAT ACT.
AND YOU AND THEY ARE AT FINAL
QUESTION THE PLAN DOES INCLUDE
FUNDING FOR HIGH SPEED RAIL
TRAINS.
AND A MAINTENANCE FACILITY FOR
THOSE TRAINS [inaudible]
AS RIVAS -- CAN YOU PLEASE
EXPLAIN AGAIN EXACTLY HOW THIS
PROJECT UPDATE -- CAME UP WITH
TOTAL FUNDING AVAILABLE OF WHAT
TWENTY POINT FOUR BILLION
[inaudible]
YEAH.
SO IN THAT ARE CONSISTENT WITH
OUR TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
BUSINESS PLAN IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN BUSINESS PLAN WE HAD
RANGES OF WHAT FUNDING COMMENT
MAINLY DUE TO THE FLUCTUATION OF
CAP AND TRADE EVERY YEAR.
SO IN THIS PROJECT UPDATE REPORT
WE REALLY FOCUSED ON TWO
SCENARIOS -- WE HAVE A LOS
SCENARIO WHICH IS ABOUT TWENTY
POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS.
AND THAT BASICALLY SCENARIO
SAYING THAT CAP AND TRADE WILL
COME IN AT ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR -- WE
HAVE A HIGH SCENARIO THAT
ASSUMES THAT CAP AND TRADE WILL
COME IN AT SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR.
WHICH BRINGS THAT UP TO TWENTY
THREE POINT FOUR FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS -- ANYWHERE WITHIN THAT
RANGE WE FEEL COMFORTABLE THAT
THAT THE PROJECT WILL BE FUNDED
THE WERE SAID TO BAKERSFIELD --
BUT AGAIN IT DEPENDS ON WHAT CAP
AND TRADE COMES AND WE DO
MONITOR THAT ON A QUARTERLY
BASIS -- I CAN TELL YOU AS OF
TODAY OUR ACTUAL DOLLARS -- WERE
ACTUALLY COME IN HIGHER THAN
WHAT OUR HIGHEST PROJECTIONS ARE
WE SHOULD BE AT ABOUT NINE POINT
SEVEN FOUR BILLION DOLLARS AND
THAT'S EXACTLY WILL ROUTE TODAY --
SO CAPTURE IT IS ACTUALLY COMING
IN A LITTLE BIT HIGHER THAN A
HIGH ASSESSMENT.
HOWEVER WE CAN'T GUARANTEE THAT
AND WE DO MONITOR THAT QUARTERLY
EVERY TIME AN OPTION COMES IN
[inaudible]
YEAH -- OKAY THINKS AND CAN NOW
KEEP PLEASE WALK ME THROUGH HOW
YOU DETERMINE.
OF THE ANTICIPATED AMOUNT OF
FUNDING THAT YOU EXPECT TO BE
AVAILABLE TO COMPLETE.
THE ENTRANCE SEGMENT.
SURE SO WE HAVE RIGHT NOW WE
HAVE ABOUT THREE POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLARS IN FEDERAL FUNDS
THAT WERE VERY AWARE OF WE HAVE
THE PROPER NAY NINE BILLION
DOLLARS JUST ABOUT FOUR POINT
TWO BILLION THAT.
WE DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO OF THAT
NINE BILLION.
AND THEN THE REST IS CAP AND
TRADE THE OPTIONS THAT COME IN
EVERY QUARTER.
SO PART OF THE CHALLENGE OF OUR
FUNDING IS WE HAVE THE PROBLEM A
FUNDS OF AGAIN NINE BILLION
DOLLARS WE HAVE THE FEDERAL
FUNDS OF THREE POINT FIVE FIVE
BILLION.
BUT THAT THE CHALLENGES THE CAP
AND TRADE BECAUSE THAT COMES IN
ON A QUARTERLY BASIS -- AND WE
CAN'T REALLY PREDICT WHAT THAT
WHAT THAT DOLLAR AMOUNT IS NOW
WHAT I CAN SAY IS WE DO TRACK IT
VERY CAREFULLY.
AND IT'S ACTUALLY COMING IN
HIGHER THAN WHAT OUR HIGHEST
PROJECTIONS ARE.
SO IT IS A FORECAST ARE FUNDING
AND AND IT IS SOMEWHAT
CHALLENGING.
THANK YOU -- I SAID MAKE A
COMMENT THAT I THINK IT'S JUST
CONVENIENT THAT THE COST OF THIS.
PROPOSED INTERIM SEGMENT IS
PRECISELY EQUAL TO THEM AN
AMOUNT OF FUNDING THAT YOU
EXPECT TO HAVE AVAILABLE. TO
TWENTY THIRTY IT'S NOT TAKING
ANY.
OF COST OVERRUNS INTO ACCOUNT OR
YOU KNOW THE PROPERTIES HAVE NOT
BEEN PURCHASED WRITER THE RIGHT
OF WAYS HAVEN'T BEEN.
SECURED IS THAT CORRECT SIR SO
THAT IS PART OF WHAT WE
DISCUSSED ABOUT ARE CONTINUOUSLY
AND I GET TO TECHNICAL ON OUR
OUR SEVENTY P. SEVEN IN A P. TEN
BUT THE WAY I LOOK AT A PIECE OF
INDIA'S WE HAVE A 70% CHANCE OF
BEING ACCURATE ON OUR BUDGET.
A 30% CHANCE OF NOT BEING
ACCURATE -- THE WAY WE GOT TO
OUR BUDGET IS TO ADD ABOUT NINE
HUNDRED AND NINETY MILLION
DOLLARS OF CONTINGENCY -- WHAT
THE WAY I LOOK AT THAT IS IT'S
IT'S MONEY SET ASIDE FOR THOSE
REST THAT WE NOW WE HAVE
MEDICATIONS FOR BUT IT MIGHT NOT
WORK?
OR EVEN THOSE UNKNOWN REST THAT
WE'RE NOT AWARE OF BUT THAT'S A
BIG PART THAT'S YOU KNOW THE 70%
17% INCREASE IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY.
ABOUT 9% OF THAT IS JUST
ADDITIONAL CONTINGENCY FUNDS TO
MITIGATE THOSE RISKS THAT WE'RE
AWARE OF OR THAT WE MIGHT NOT BE
AWARE OF KATE.
SO.
I REPRESENT THE THIRTY NINTH
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT WHICH WHICH
THE THE SEGMENTS THE SOUTHERN
SEGMENT OF THE RAIL THE ORIGINAL
VISION -- WERE TO GO THROUGH --
AND SO CAN YOU PLEASE EXPLAIN
HOW THIS PROPOSAL BENEFITS
DISTRICTS LIKE MINE OR ANYTHING
SOUTH.
OF BAKERSFIELD [inaudible]
SURE.
WHAT THE F.?
IF THIS IS.
THE STRUCTURE OF STATEWIDE RAIL
INVESTMENT IT'S ALWAYS BEEN
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT IT'S NOT HIGH
SPEED RAIL ALONE BECAUSE WE HAVE
MANY AREAS WERE HIGH SPEED RAIL
WON'T.
REACH THE I WON'T YOU KNOW GET
TO THOSE CITIES SO FAR HAS BEEN
LOOKING AT THE IDEA OF A
STATEWIDE RAIL MODERNIZATION
APPROACH.
AND THAT'S BEEN REFLECTED IN IN
SEVERAL WAYS AND SEVERAL NEW
FUNDING PROGRAMS OF COURSE THE
CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM OF TWENTY
FOURTEEN A SET UP A NEW FUNDING
PROGRAM.
IN SB ONE AUGMENTED THAT AS WELL
SO WHEN WE LOOK ACROSS ALL OF
THE DIFFERENT STATE FUNDING
SOURCES PRIMARILY THE CAP AND
TRADE IN SB ONE WITH ALONG WITH
A LITTLE HIGH SPEED RAIL THAT'S
THE BOOK IN MONEY.
I SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA RAIL
INVESTMENTS ARE ABOUT FOUR POINT
FOUR BILLION DOLLARS -- THAT
WE'VE SEEN OVER THIS PAST PERIOD
DOES SINCE -- TWENTY FOURTEEN
AND IN THAT INCLUDES SAY AGAIN
BUT SOME OF THE NEW SB ONE MONEY
THAT STILL COMING IN BUT THOSE
ARE AWARDED PROJECTS TO IMPROVE
METROLINK -- SURFLINER ALL THOSE
RAIL SERVICES AT THE CENTRAL
VALLEY SERVICE AND MANY
TRAVELERS IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
WILL ALSO CHOOSE TO USE THE
EXISTING BUS CONNECTION TO GET
DOWN TO LOS ANGELES AS WELL.
SO SOME OF THE TRAVELER'S COMING
TO AND FROM SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
WOULD CHOOSE TO USE.
THE CENTRAL VALLEY RAIL AS THEY
DO TODAY BUT IT MUCH EXPANDED
NUMBERS -- GIVE A PROJECTION ON
HOW.
THOSE EXPANDED NUMBERS LAKE YES
THAT'S HOW MUCH.
HOW MUCH DOES THIS REDUCE THE
TRIP TIME SURE CAN ALSO DOES
DOES THAT PEOPLE THAT ARE
WRITING RAIL TODAY THAT TO PASS
THROUGH OR WITHIN THAT
BAKERSFIELD MERCED SEGMENT WOULD
SAVE NINETY TO A HUNDRED MINUTES?
OF TRIP TIME -- ANDY AT THE
RIDERSHIP NUMBERS ARE IN THE THE
EARLY TRAIN OPERATOR REPORT
WHICH IS ON HIGH SPEED RAILS
WEBSITE BUT AT THE TIME HIGH
LEVEL WHAT ABOUT.
DOUBLES THE NUMBER OF PASSENGERS
LOOKING ACROSS THE THREE
SERVICES.
THE EIGHT THE ALTAMONT COMMUTER
EXPRESS THE SAN JOAQUIN'S WILL
BE OPERATING AS HIGH SPEED RAIL
AND THEN THOSE BUS CONNECTIONS
FROM BAKERSFIELD TO SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
BUT WITH THE BUS CONNECTIONS ARE
THEY REALLY SAVING NINETY TWO
HUNDRED MINUTES.
WELL AGAIN FOR THOSE EXISTING
PASSENGERS THAT WOULD START IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND WANT TO
TAKE A A RAIL TRIP TO SAY
SACRAMENTO -- CURRENTLY THERE'S
DICKEY GO THE COASTAL RAIL ROUTE
AND THAT.
TAKES A THINK ABOUT ELEVEN HOURS
TO GET TO HAVE FROM MY LOS
ANGELES UP TO SACRAMENTO
SLIGHTLY SHORTER IF YOU TAKE THE
BUS CONNECTION FROM LA TO
BAKERSFIELD AND GET AND GET ON
THE TRAIN AT BAKERSFIELD TO GO
TO SACRAMENTO.
SO THAT THAT THAT PARTICULAR
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA TRAVELER
WOULD SEE AN INCREASE.
OR DECREASE RATHER IN TRIP TIME
BY THAT NINETY TWO HUNDRED
MINUTES.
YOU KNOW I NOTICED THAT YOUR
PROJECT UPDATE -- HAD NO
ALTERNATIVES PROPOSED OF MEA
THE ONLY OPTION THAT YOUR
PRESENT TEAM.
IS THE MERCED TO BAKERSFIELD YOU
KNOW AS A LEGISLATOR I WOULD
HAVE LIKED TO HAVE SEEN VARIOUS
OPTIONS LIKE.
THE LA -- MENTIONED -- THIS IS
NOW.
OF SOMETHING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS TO CONSIDER --
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE SEEN
MORE OPTIONS IN EUROPE.
PROJECT UPDATE SURE APPRECIATE
THAT YET THE GIVEN THE THE
FRAMING IT WAS COMMITMENTS MADE
AT THE TIME OF THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN BUSINESS PLAN TO LOOK
AT THAT VALLEY TO VALLEY AND
LOOK AT THE BUILD OUT ON EITHER
END OF VALLEY TO VALLEY AND HOW
WE COULD DO THAT IN.
A ROOM SERVICE GET THROUGH OUR
BROADER RAIL MODERNIZATION
EFFORTS WE HAVE DONE A LOT OF
WORK ON IMPROVEMENTS IN THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AREA --
THERE WAS OVER A BILLION DOLLARS
PROVIDED FOR THE CALL THIS THE
SCORE PROJECT THAT METROLINX
LOOKING AT FOR HOW TO UPGRADE A
NUMBER OF LINES INCREASE
FREQUENCY TO SOMETHING LIKE
EVERY FIFTEEN MINUTES ON SOME OF
THE MOST TRAVELED LINES DOWN
THERE.
SO THERE IS WORK BEING DONE ON
ON THOSE TYPE OF IMPROVEMENTS AS
WELL AND AGAIN IT'S THEY'RE NOT
DEPENDENT ON HIGH SPEED RAIL --
COMING INTO THOSE CORRIDORS BUT
THEIR MUTUAL BENEFIT PROJECTS
THAT -- AT THE THE L. UNION
STATION THE ROSECRANS MARQUARDT
WINDOWS FREE OUT MORE GRADE
SEPARATED SEGMENTS IN SOME CASES
ALLOW FOR MORE CONTINUOUS THIRD
TRACK.
OF THOSE ARE ALL THINGS THAT
IMPROVE THE EXISTING RAIL
SERVICES TODAY.
ARE YOU KNOW.
THERE IS NO PROPOSED STOP IN MY
DISTRICT YOU KNOW THE THE THE
RAIL -- JUST GOES RIGHT THROUGH
IT -- AND I'M NOT EVEN SURE --
MY CONSTITUENTS WOULD EVEN BE
ABLE TO AFFORD -- THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL -- IF IT THERE WERE A STOP
IN THE DISTRICT -- IN SO THAT'S
WHAT I THINK OF WHEN I SEE THIS
PROJECT -- I THINK OF OF WHETHER.
YOU KNOW PEOPLE YOU KNOW MY MY
DISTRICT IS MMHM -- PRIMARILY
LOW INCOME -- YOU KNOW THE HOUSE
CURRENTLY NO TRANSIT CORRIDORS
VERY LITTLE -- IN MOST PEOPLE.
ONE TRANSIT WITHIN THIS THE AREA
THE WITHIN THE REGION YOU KNOW
TO GET TO WORK YOU KNOW TO THIS
AFFECTS THE QUALITY OF LIFE --
AND BUT A PROJECT LIKE THIS --
WOULD DISRUPT -- YOU DON'T THEIR
LIVES BECAUSE WE DON'T KNOW YET --
YOU KNOW WHERE WHAT HOMES WILL
YOU KNOW WHICH FAMILIES WILL BE
DISPLACED IN IN THE DISTRICT.
OF IN SO.
THAT'S WHERE.
A YOU KNOW MY CONCERNS ARE --
JUST FOR THE OVERALL VISION OF
THE PROJECT -- BUT AS FAR AS
THIS SEGMENT GOES -- I AM ALSO
CONCERNED -- THE UNCERTAINTY OF
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S
INVOLVEMENT TWITCH I THINK THIS
PROJECT IS HIGHLY DEPENDENT ON
NOT JUST IN.
THE FUNDING OR YOU KNOW THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AS A FUNDING
SOURCE -- BUT THE NEED FOR
REVIEWS THAT YOU MENTIONED IN
YOUR UPDATE ORIGINALLY ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE CONDUCTED.
AT THE SAME TIME AS THE BERMAN
VIA MENTAL IMPACT REVIEWS RIGHT.
AND RIGHT NOW WE DON'T KNOW IF
THAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN AND IF.
IF THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN
CONCURRENTLY.
YOU WON'T MAKE THE DECEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY TWO DEADLINE IS
THAT CORRECT.
THAT'S CORRECT YEAH AND AND FOR
THE ENVIRONMENTAL DOCUMENTS THAT
ARE CURRENTLY BEING -- UPDATED
IN THERE'S THERE'S TWO CENTRAL
VALLEY THERE'S THE BAKERSFIELD
AREA LOCALLY PREFERRED
ALTERNATIVE AND THEN THERE'S THE
Y. WHICH IS IN THE MADERA MERCED
AREA.
SO BOTH OF THOSE CURRENTLY
BECAUSE OF FEDERAL ENGAGEMENT A
GOING FIRST IS GOING FOR TO SEE
FOR FIRST.
SO THERE'S PUBLIC AT HEARINGS IN
PUBLIC PROCESS ON THE SEQUENCE
SIDE BUT WITHOUT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ENGAGING ON THE KNEE
BESIDE WERE UNABLE TO GO FORWARD
WITH THOUSAND THAT.
CREATE THAT DELAY -- WE DO NEED
THEIR RE ENGAGEMENT -- BECAUSE
IT A WE WANNA CLEAR THOSE
SEGMENTS AND THE OTHER
ENVIRONMENTAL DOCUMENTS TO
NEARBY THAT'S THAT THE PLAN.
AT WITH THE GRANT AGREEMENT SO --
YOU KNOW THE FOR THE FEDS --
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS INTERESTED
IN AND HOLDING US TO THE
SCHEDULE BUT WE DEFINITELY NEED
THEIR ENGAGEMENT.
AT TO REVIEW THE NEPA DOCUMENT
OR TO GO FORTH AND I DO NEED BY
ASSIGNMENT WHICH IS A PROCESS
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION HAS IN CALIFORNIA.
WHERE CALTRANS IS ABLE TO ACT AS
THE FEDERAL NEPA LEAD?
AND CERTIFY ON THEIR BEHALF AND
THAT WE'VE APPLIED FOR THAT AS
WELL TO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
FOR A NEAT ASSIGNMENT FOR HIGH
SPEED RAIL.
YEAH I THINK WITH ALL OF THIS
UNCERTAINTY -- NOT JUST AND
FUNDING BUT IN LIKE.
THE THE NEPA -- ENGAGEMENT FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT I YOU
KNOW I DON'T THINK IT'S
APPROPRIATE THAT WE'RE STILL
CONDUCTING THE E. I. R. AS IN.
IN FOR THE WHOLE.
OF HIGH SPEED RAIL INCLUDING MY
DISTRICT IN THE SOUTHERN PARTS
OF OF THE RAIL.
PLAN [inaudible]
WELL I WOULD JUST MENTION THAT
AS FAR AS THE THE BENEFIT OF
DURING THE III OURS IS A A IT.
IT RESOLVE SOME OF THOSE
RADISHES AND OF COURSE THE THE
ENVIRONMENTAL PROCESS THAT'S
WHERE YOU LOOK AT EVERY OPTION
TO MITIGATE AND REDUCE ANY.
UNNECESSARY -- A STRUCTURE AS
BEING TAKEN OR IN -- TRY TO WORK
WITH COMMUNITIES TO FIND THE
BEST ALTERNATIVE SO IN IN GOING
FORWARD WITH THOSE NO HOPE THAT
THAT PROVIDES MORE CERTAINTY.
ON ON ROUTES AND AND THAT --
PROVIDE SOME BENEFIT -- ALSO
DURING THE ENVIRONMENTAL WORK
CAN HELP SOME OTHER RAIL
PROJECTS WE MENTIONED SOME OF
THE SHARED CORRIDORS SOME SOME
INSTANCES OF HIGH SPEED RAIL IS
ABLE TO CLEAR SOMETHING
ENVIRONMENTALLY -- THAT SUBSET
OF THAT PROJECT MAY BE ABLE TO
GO FOR IT UNDER THAT
ENVIRONMENTAL APPROVAL -- FOR
ANOTHER PROJECT TO A SMALLER
SUBSET PROJECT.
HEY WELL YOU KNOW.
THIS IS THE HUGE INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECT YOU KNOW PRIDE THE
LARGEST IN THE COUNTRY -- AND
YOU KNOW THE LOTS OF UNCERTAINTY.
AND FUNDING IN FEDERAL
ENGAGEMENT WHICH IS NECESSARY --
FOR THIS T. EVEN BE A REALITY
EVEN FOR THE SMALL SEGMENT THAT
IS BEING PROPOSED TODAY -- AND I
THINK WE SHOULD HAVE OTHER
OPTIONS -- FOR THIS.
YOU KNOW THIS PROJECT IN -- AND
YOU KNOW THE HISTORY OF IT
ALREADY THE LAST YEAR'S -- HAS
BEEN LOTS OF COST OVERRUNS --
AND EACH YEAR IN OF THE PUBLIC
HEARS.
THE INCREASE IN PROJECTED BUDGET
FOR THE OVERALL PROJECT -- AND I
JUST DON'T SEE HOW WE'RE WE'RE
GOING TO GET.
EVEN OUR OWN STATE ENGAGED IN
THIS -- HUGE INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECT AND THE WILL TO FUND IT --
SO I LOOK FORWARD TO MORE
UPDATES.
AND MORE OPTIONS FOR IT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
MR FUNG.
BUT THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE --
I SAID BEFORE IT THE ONLY
PREDICTOR OF FUTURE BEHAVIOR IS
PAST BEHAVIOR SO I JUST WANT TO
UNDERSTAND.
THAT LOW EVERYONE UNDERSTAND
WHAT THE ORIGINAL.
I INTENT OF PROP WHEN IT WAS SO
DALY OPENED EXPLAINED OR TAKE A
WHAT THE ORIGINAL PROBLEM A
DESIGN SYSTEM WAS WAS TO BE.
SURE SO PROP ONE A ENVISIONED --
KIND OF TWO PHASES TO THE
PROJECT SO PHASE ONE WAS TO GO
FROM THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA
DOWN TO ANAHEIM PHASE TWO IS TO
EXTEND FURTHER.
ON SACRAMENTO IN THE NORTH IN
SAN DIEGO IN THE SOUTH AND SO
THAT WAS THE ON THE GENERAL
BROAD VISION AND THERE IS SOME
ADDITIONAL SPECIFICITY ALSO LAID
OUT SO FULLY ELECTRIFIED
COMPLETELY SEPARATE LINE.
I I BELIEVE IT WAS INTENDED TO
BE.
I DON'T THINK I DON'T KNOW THAT
IT READ IT THAT IT SPECIFICALLY
CALLED OUT WHETHER IT'S TO BE.
FULLY SEPARATED OR NOT BUT
CERTAINLY THE IMPLICATION OF THE
BUILDING UP.
OF RAIL LINE FROM THOSE POINTS I
DON'T THINK IT WAS IT WAS SUPER
STRESSED THAT SPECIFIED IN THE
IN THE MEASURE OKAY SO BUT AT A
MINIMUM WE HAVE A LINE THAT GOES
FROM.
SAN FRANCISCO TO ANAHEIM.
ELECTRIFIED -- SEPARATE OR
BLENDED IN SOME FASHION CORRECT.
I BELIEVE SO YEAH OKAY SO I HEAR
A LOT OF WORDS LIKE -- RE
FOCUSED.
DOWNSIZED -- CHANGE SO THAT I TO
AUTHORITY CAN TELL ME IT HAS THE
GOVERNOR DOWNSIZE THIS PROJECT
WHAT IS TO THE POSITION OF THE
ADMINISTRATION ARE WE GOING TO
STILL DO.
A SAN FRANCISCO IN ANAHEIM AS
PROP ONE A VISION A VISION OR
WHAT IS THE PROJECT IN ITS
CURRENT FORM SURE. FOR WHAT THE
GOVERNOR STATED THE STAY
REFERRED TO NO REGARDING THE
PROJECT IN LOOKING AT THE MONEY
WE HAD AND THAT'S WHAT WE'VE
DONE.
SO -- YOU MIGHT REMEMBER THE
PRIOR BUSINESS PLAN TALK ABOUT
THINGS LIKE EXTENSION OF CAP AND
TRADE TO TWENTY FIFTY THINGS
LIKE THAT SO THIS DOESN'T ASSUME
THAT.
THIS JUST LOOKS AT THE CURRENT
MONEY THAT'S DIRECTED TO HIGH
SPEED RAIL.
AND WHAT'S -- CITED AS IS
EARLIER MENTIONED IS SEVEN ABOUT
TWENTY POINT FOUR BILLION FROM
THE VARIOUS SOURCES WHICH ARE
ONE A TO CAP AND TRADE IN THE
FEDERAL FUNDS ALREADY -- AWARDED
TO THE PROJECT.
SO I GUESS THAT'S THE CONFUSION
I I SAT AND LISTENED TO THE SAY
THE STATE.
AND AND ALL THE REPORTS
AFTERWARDS WAS THE GOVERNOR
DOWNSIZE THE PROJECT SO HAS THE
GOVERNOR DOWNSIZE THE PROJECT.
NO IT THEY WERE RECOGNIZING THE
BUILDING BLOCK APPROACH THESE
ARE THE MONIES WE HAVE THIS IS
WHAT WE CAN GET DONE WITH THE
MONEY WE HAVE.
IN GETTING THIS DONE AND I THINK
THIS GETS TO THIS ISSUE THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PATTERSON RAISED
A CREDIBILITY WHO NEED TO
DELIVER THOSE.
CAPITAL PROJECTS ON THE GROUND
AND HAVING DELIVERED THAT HAVING.
AB DEMONSTRATING HIGHS RAIL
SERVICE BY GETTING THE TRAIN
SETS GETTING THAT UP AND
OPERATING.
NO THAT IS THE FIRST BUILDING
BLOCK AND THINK THAT FOCUS ON
DELIVERY FOCUS ON BUILDING WHAT
WE CAN WITH THE EXISTING MONEY.
THAT'S THE FIRST IMPORTANT STEP
AND THEN ULTIMATELY YES THAT
EXTENSION TO THE BAY AREA THAT
EXTENSION TO SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
THAT STILL PART OF THE VISION
BUT WE DON'T HAVE A FUNDING PATH
RIGHT NOW TO GET THERE.
BUT IN GETTING THIS FIRST
BUILDING BLOCK WERE ADVANCING
THE SYSTEM AND I BELIEVE THAT AT
SOME POINT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WILL RE ENGAGE
BECAUSE HIGH SPEED RAIL AROUND
THE COUNTRY.
YEAH THERE'S INCREASING INTEREST
OTHER STATES ARE LOOKING AT THIS
WELL SO I DO BELIEVE AT SOME
POINT.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WILL
RESEARCH THE SO LET LET LET'S
LET'S FOCUS ON THE FUNDING --
YOU KNOW AS AS MY COLLEAGUE
MENTIONED BEFORE E. WEBER NO
MARGIN OF ERROR -- MAG I GET THE
CONTINGENCY ARGUMENT BUT YOU
YOUR COST FOR THE CENTER VALLEY
IS TWENTY POINT FOUR AND YOU'VE
IDENTIFIED TWENTY POINT.
FOUR BILLION DOLLARS AND AND WE
ALL KNOW WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU
ASSUME.
RIGHT SO [inaudible]
UNDER.
THE ON PAGE THIRTY TWO YOU'VE
INDICATED THAT THE ON GOING
CONSTRUCTION OF MADERA AND WASCO
HAS INCREASED ONE POINT EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS.
THAT'S CORRECT [inaudible]
AND THEN.
YES THAT THE PROJECT IT'S A
DEVICE GOING UP ONE POINT EIGHT
BILLION.
INCLUDE YES INCLUDING THE
CONTINGENCY WE HAVE A BASELINE
COST IS UP ONE POINT EIGHT SO
THAT'S THE BEST LIKE US WHAT IS
THE HIGHER RANGE COST.
IT'S THE HIGHER RIGHTS THIRTEEN
THIRTY THIRTEEN BILLION SO THE
THIRTEEN POINT SEVEN BILLION
THAT ALSO REPRESENTS THE COST
FOR THE CENTRAL VALLEY BUT ALSO
THE BOOKENDS INVESTMENTS.
SO AS IT SO JUST TO BE ACCURATE
WE GOT A RANGE.
RIGHT AS YOU INDICATED A
CONTINGENCY SO THE COST COULD BE.
TWELVE POINT FOUR BILLION OR IT
COULD BE THIRTEEN POINT SEVEN
BILLION NOW LET ME IF I SAID
SOMETHING EARLY I APOLOGIZE THE
RANGERS ARE FROM THE FUNDING.
THE FUNDING RANGES ANYWHERE FROM
TWENTY POINT FOUR FIVE BILLION
TO TWENTY THREE POINT FOUR FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS THAT'S THE RANGE
FOR THE POTENTIAL FINDING.
MAINLY DUE THE CAP AND TRADE
BECAUSE THAT FLUCTUATES.
THE COST OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY
DID GO FROM TEN POINT SIX TO
SEVEN OTHER TWELVE POINT FOUR
THAT'S THE ONE POINT EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS.
THAT'S ABOUT A 17% INCREASE.
AND AGAIN OF THAT 17% ABOUT 10%
OF THAT 9% OF THAT IS THIS
CONTINGENCY THAT WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT.
BUT AT THE PREVIOUS YEAR THE
COST SEGMENT WENT UP TWO POINT
EIGHT BILLION.
FROM THE SIXTEEN EIGHTEEN I
BELIEVE THAT'S CORRECT SO SO WE
ARE NOW SEEING A PATTERN.
YOU DIDN'T DO AGENT DO A COST
ESTIMATE AT THE BEGINNING A
TWENTY TWELVE RIGHT AND THEN NOW
IT'S THERE WAS THE TEN BILLION.
NOW IT'S TWELVE BILLION.
WHAT I WOULD EXPLAIN THAT ONE
POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLAR
INCREASE FOR THE 17% INCREASE IS?
AGAIN YOU HAVE ABOUT 9%
CONTINGENCY I WOULD SAY YOU HAVE
ABOUT -- THREE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
MILLION DOLLARS OF THAT IS SCOPE
CHANGE SO WE ADDED SCOPE TO THE
PROJECT.
WHICH IS THE ADDITIONAL COSTS
AND ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY SEVEN MILLION.
IS WHAT I WOULD CALL COST
INCREASES BECAUSE WE KNOW MORE
ABOUT HOW MUCH SOMETHING'S GOING
TO COST YOU.
BUT YOU CAN'T GUARANTEE YOU CAN
GUARANTEE THAT THERE WILL BE
ANOTHER COST OVER A NO ONE CAN
GUARANTEE IF IT WILL BE COST YOU
CRY THAT'S PART OF THE THE THE
THE BENEFIT OF HAVING A
CONTINGENCY SO THE LIKELIHOOD OF
A COST OVERRUN IS PRETTY.
CERTAIN.
THERE'S A IF IF I AND IF I IF I
OUTLINED WHAT WHAT IS AND READ
THIS IS INDICATED.
IF THE FED THE NEED FOR REVIEW
ISN'T COMPLETED IF THE FEDS
DON'T RE ENGAGE IF THE RIGHT
AWAY ACQUISITION GOES UP IF
THERE'S LAWSUITS THAT SAY THAT
YOU KNOW LONGER -- A BYE BYE
PROP ONE EIGHTY THAT DELAYS THE
PROJECT THAT ALSO INCREASES
COSTS CORRECT THE THOSE WOULD BE
REST YES THAT WOULD.
ALL THOSE ARE ALL ASSUMPTIONS
BUILT INTO THE SYSTEM AND INTO
THIS REPORT.
WHICH IS WHY THE LA L. AS
INDICATED THAT THIS REPORT IS
HIGHLY DEPENDENT ON THE
ASSUMPTIONS BEING MADE AND THE
ASSUMPTIONS BEING MADE IS VERY
VERY.
CONCERNING CORRECT.
THE ASSUMPTIONS BEING MADE OF
THE REST THAT WE CAN IDENTIFY
AND YES THE REFEREE ENGAGEMENT
IS IS A CRITICAL PIECE OF THIS
PROJECT -- WE DID FACTOR IN THAT
PIECE -- AND ALL THE OTHER WRIST
AGAIN WHICH IS WHY WE INCREASED.
AGAIN WITH IMITATE A P. TEN FROM
THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
BUSINESS PLAN. TO A PIECE OF A
NUMBER TO ADDRESS THOSE REST
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
SO THE SO THEN IF YOU DON'T MIND
ME ASKING WHY DIDN'T YOU DO AB
SEVENTY OR OR HIGHER ON THE FULL.
THE FULL ONLINE.
THE WAY I LOOK AT IT IS THE MORE
THIS PROJECT GOES ON THE MORE WE
NOW UTILITY COSTS -- RIGHT AWAY
COST -- WE LEARN FROM THOSE
THINGS AND SO I WOULD SAY
EARLIER ON IN THE PROJECT WOULD
BE DIFFICULT TO COME UP WITH THE
P. -- SEVENTY BUT I THINK WE
FEEL PRETTY COMFORTABLE NOW AT
LEAST IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
PIECE.
A PIECE OF ANY NUMBER IS IS
PRETTY ACCURATE WHICH AGAIN.
WHICH IS THE ONE POINT EIGHT
BILLION DOLLAR INCREASE.
SO YOU SAY THAT YOU KEEP CAN'T
DO A P. SEVENTY FOR THE FULL
ALIGNMENT OF THE FOR ALIGNMENT
IF THAT WERE NOW STIPULATING
THAT THE PROJECT HASN'T CHANGED
WHAT WE WERE.
WERE BOND BY THAT -- THE NEXT
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY BUSINESS
PLAN WE WILL HAVE TO DO ANOTHER
ESTIMATE ON WHAT THE VALUE TO
VALLEY'S GONNA COST AN ACTUAL
CHANGE ONE'S GOING TO COST SO
THAT WILL BE INCLUDED IN THAT
REPORT TODAY WE DON'T HAVE THAT
THAT'S AND TWENTY TWENTY WE'RE
MAKING DECISIONS TODAY.
SO WHY WHY WOULD WHY WASN'T
THERE DECISION BE MADE THAT
MAYBE PROVIDE SOME ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION OF WHY ON THE FULL
LINE.
THE TO DO A PIECE OF ANY OR ANY
TYPE OF ESTIMATE FOR THE VALLEY
VALLEY OR THE PHASE ONE IS GOING
TO TAKE SOME TIME AGAIN THIS
PROJECT OF THE REPORT FOCUSED ON
THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND WHAT
WE'RE CURRENTLY DOING TODAY --
BUT IT IT IS A REQUIREMENT OF
TWENTY TWENTY BUSINESS PLAN AND
IT WILL BE THERE BUT WE DON'T
HAVE THAT INFORMATION TODAY.
SO YOU DON'T HAVE THE
INFORMATION TO DO A AT A COST
ASSESSMENT FOR THE ACTUAL AND WE
DON'T HAVE WE DON'T WE DON'T
HAVE THE ANALYSIS DONE. TO BE
ABLE TO COME UP WITH THAT NUMBER
TODAY AND SO WE HAVE TO WAIT
TILL TWENTY TWENTY TO GET THAT
[inaudible]
YES AS NOW IN TERMS OF WHAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PATTERSON
RELATED TO CAN YOU EXPLAIN TO ME
WHAT.
REGIONAL INNER CITY SERVICE IS
AS USUAL YOU ALLUDED TO IT AND
ON PAGE.
SIXTY FOUR SO YEAH YOU'RE NOW
DOING REGIONAL REGIONAL INNER
CITY SERVICE.
ON THIS A LOT ON ON THIS
ALIGNMENT [inaudible]
SURE [inaudible]
WHAT ARE?
YOU KNOW WHAT'S PROPOSED.
IS -- BEGIN THAT HUNDRED SEVENTY
ONE MILE A HIGH SPEED RAIL
SEGMENT THAT'S FULLY INTEGRATED
WITH THE OTHER RAIL AND IN THE
SOUTH CAN ADD BUS CONNECTING
SERVICE.
AS SO THAT THAT WOULD BE.
DESCRIBED IN THE PLAN IS THE
IT'S SAFE.
WHAT WE'RE DESCRIBING THE
CONNECTIONS OF THE RAIL IS THAT
WHAT YOU'RE LOOKING FOR AND
UNDERSTAND UNDERSTAND WHAT THAT
MEANS IS WE JUST RUNNING A WE
JUST RUNNING TRAINS DIESEL
TRAINS OR ART AMTRAK TRAINS --
CONNECTING THE THE CITIES OR
MAYBE I'M JUST TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT.
WHAT YOU'RE WHAT YOU'RE
DESCRIBING WHEN YOU SAY -- AND
REGIONAL INTERCITY SERVICE IS
GOING TO BE USED SURE.
SO -- PASSENGER GOING TO SAY
FROM BAKERSFIELD MERCED WOULD
GET ON A HIGH SPEED RAIL TRAIN.
AND THAT TRIP FROM BAKERSFIELD
MERCED WOULD TAKE SOMETHING LIKE
AN HOUR AND TWENTY MINUTES. FOR
PASSENGERS THEIR CONTINUING
FURTHER NORTH PERHAPS TO
SACRAMENTO IN MERCED -- THEY
WOULD BE ABLE TO BOARD A EITHER
SAN JOAQUIN OR A STRAIN AND
CONTINUE THAT TRIP FURTHER NORTH
AGAIN EITHER TO SACRAMENTO OR
INTO THE BAY AREA -- AS WELL TO
THE ACE IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
CONNECTION.
THIS.
SO YOU'RE SAYING THAT AND TWENTY
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT
THAT THAT'S GONNA HAPPEN BUT
WELL IN THE MEANTIME WHAT IS
WHAT IS THE WHAT IS THAT AND
LOOK LIKE.
SURE FOR THE MEANTIME WE'RE
CONTINUING TO BUILD THE SYSTEM
WE'RE CONTINUING TO EXPAND SOUTH
AT BAKERSFIELD AGAIN -- BY THE
END OF TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN
THAT'S WHEN THE BAKERSFIELD
EXTENSION WAS HIS PLAN TO BE
COMPLETED.
AND THE HIGH SPEED RAIL TRAINS
WOULD INITIALLY SO YOU'RE
TELLING ME AT NO TIME IS THERE
GOING TO BE -- CONVENTIONAL RAIL
BEING USED ON THIS LINE.
THAT'S CORRECT SO IT'S ALL IT'S
GOING TO HIGH SPEED FROM THE
VERY BEGINNING THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
LOOK CORRECT LOOKING AT GETTING.
BUILDING ON TO BAKERSFIELD
BUILDING ON TO MERCED AND HAVING
THE TRAIN SERVICE BE THE
ELECTRIFIED RAIL SERVICE SO SO
FROM STE WELL I DON'T YOU'RE
GOING TO BAKERSFIELD BUT FROM SO
POPULAR AVENUE. TO HER SAID IT'S
HIGH SPEED RAIL.
THIS ONE AND INITIATE THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL UNTIL THOSE EXTENSION
TO BAKERSFIELD OCCURS AGAIN THIS
IS -- WOULD GO FROM MADERA TO
BAKERSFIELD AS THE FIRST RAIL
SERVICE ON THE NEW AT SYSTEMS
AND THAT INITIATE BY THE END OF
TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN SIR WHEN I
WHEN I READ -- IN THE REPORT.
YOU SAY THAT -- YOU HAVE GAINED
FROM SERVICE SO IN TERMS SERVICE
IS A PASSENGER TRAINS.
BUT I'M NOT HIGH SPEED.
OR THE HIGH SPEED.
NO FOR THAT SEGMENT THAT MADERA
MADERA TO BAKERSFIELD HIGH SPEED
TRAINS AND HOW FAST THEY GONNA
GO.
WELL THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO GO
OUT THE UP TO TWO HUNDRED MILES
AN HOUR AT THAT THAT HIGH SPEED.
OKAY SO YOU YOU'RE GOING TO
GUARANTEE THAT GOES TO HER MILES
AN HOUR THROUGH BUT FROM BAKER
TO THE MADERA -- BECAUSE THEY
THEY GET THIS IS THE WERE
BUILDING THE ALIGNMENT THAT'S
CONSISTENT WITH THE PROP ONE A
REQUIREMENTS ON SPEED SO YEAH
THE SYSTEMS BEING BUILT FOR THAT
SPEED AND THE TRAINS WILL BE
ACQUIRED.
AT TO TO MEET THOSE SOME
SPECIFICATION WHERE THERE'S NO
XIN COME THAT DID SLOW TRAINS
ARE GOING TO PUT ON THIS TRACK.
BUT AGAIN WHAT'S HOSTESS IS FAST
TRAIN SO I'M NOT SURE WITH AS I
MENTIONED WITH THE FEDERAL
RAILROAD ADMINISTRATION OVER
TIME YOU KNOW THEY'VE ASKED FOR
DIFFERENT PLANS FOR EARLY USE OF
THE SYSTEM BUT WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT.
WANTING TO DO ELECTRIFIED
SERVICE AND GO DIRECTLY TO THAT --
NOT THE DIESEL TRAINS IN THE
INTERIM SO THAT'S WHAT HAS BEEN
DISCUSSED WITH FRA IN RECENT --
IN PRIOR YEARS DISCUSSION OF
EARLY EARLY OPERATION OF THE
SEGMENT SO LET ME READ ON PAGE.
NINE SAYS AS PART OF THE FACE OF
LIMITATION THE ASSETS BUILT IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY COULD BE USED
BY AN INTERIM PASSENGER TRAIN
OPERATOR.
UNTIL ADDITIONAL FUNDING BECAME
AVAILABLE.
THIS APPROACH WAS MEMORIALIZED
IN THE FEDERAL GRANT AGREEMENTS
SPECIFICALLY THE DIESEL SAN
JOAQUIN INTERCITY PASSENGER
TRAINS WHICH OPERATE ON SHARED
FREIGHT RAIL TRACKS COULD BE
SHIFTED TO THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
TRACKS TO REALIZE.
A REDUCE PASTOR TRAIN TRAVEL
TIME IN CENTRAL VALLEY.
I THINK THAT'S ASSOCIATED WITH
THE TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY CORRECT
WELL THAT THAT -- DIESEL USE HAS
BEEN DISCUSSED WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IT IS AN INTERIM USE
OPTION.
BUT WHAT IS CURRENTLY BEING
PROPOSED IN INCLUDING TO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS THE
ELECTRIFIED WITHIN A FOLLOW UP
ON PAGE TEN WHICH IS HOWEVER THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUSINESS PLAN
INDICATED THAT THERE WAS NOT
SUFFICIENT FUNDING. TO COMPLETE
THE VALLEY TO VALLEY LIVE WITH
THE CURRENT AVAILABLE COMMITTED
FUNDING THEREFORE THE AUTHORITY
STATED ITS INTENT TO SEEK THE
SUPPORT.
OF THE T. L. UNVEILING THE
POTENTIAL FOR AN INTERIM SERVICE
IN THE CENTER VALLEY REVISED
EARLY BENEFITS CORRECT IN AN
INTERIM SERVICES THE ELECTRIFIED
SERVICE OKAY.
SO THEN ON PAGE FIFTEEN YOU
INDICATED A SIXTY TWO POINT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS SHORTFALL IF
EVEN IF WE RAN.
THIS INTERIM SERVICE IN AN
EXHIBIT ONE POINT TWO IT'S
POTENTIALLY EIGHTY TWO POINT
EIGHT IF YOU DON'T DO IT.
RIGHT IF I'M THE FARE BOX
REVENUE SURE AND WHAT THAT'S
INDICATING AND THIS IS IN THE
EACH YEAR ANALYSIS IS LOOKING AT
THE COMBINED SERVICE AND THE
CENTRAL VALLEY WHICH IS ACE AND
SAN JOAQUIN AND THE INTERVIEWS
HIGH SPEED RAIL SEGMENT.
AND INDICATING WITHOUT HIGH
SPEED RAIL THERE'S A OPERATING
SUPPORT OF ABOUT EIGHTY THREE
MILLION DOLLARS.
WITH HIGH SPEED RAIL BECAUSE OF
THE INCREASE IN RIDERSHIP THE
INCREASE IN FAREBOX RECOVERY.
THAT OPERATING SUPPORT ACTUALLY
FALLS BY TWENTY MILLION TO ABOUT
SIXTY THREE ZERO SIXTY TWO POINT
SIX MILLION DOLLARS SHORTFALL.
WHY DON'T BELIEVE IT'S A
SHORTFALL THE CURRENTLY -- ACE
AND THE SAN JOAQUIN'S RECEIVE --
OPERATING SUPPORT AS DO THE
COMMUTER RAIL AND OTHER
INTERCITY RAIL -- PROVIDERS
RIGHT BUT IS IT DOESN'T COVER
THE COST.
BUT IN LOOKING AT YOUR REPORT IT
DOESN'T COVER THE COST COST IS
TWENTY TWO TO TWO AND A TWENTY
EIGHT POINT FOUR MILLION AND THE
REVENUES IS ONE HUNDRED SIXTY
FIVE ONE EIGHT MILLION.
THERE YOU HAVE AN ARROW SHOWING
AT A SHORTFALL HOW DO YOU MAKE
UP THAT SHORTFALL.
WELL THAT THAT IS THE OPERATING
SUPPORT AGAIN THAT FALLS WITH
THE ADVENT OF HIGH SPEED RAIL
RELATIVE TO EXHIBIT ONE POINT
TWO ON THE RIGHT SO DINNER I I
AGREE WITH ME I I'M WITH YOU.
THE SHORTFALL DROPS FROM EIGHTY
TWO POINT EIGHT MILLION TO SIXTY
TWO POINT SIX MILLION.
SO YOU SAID THAT SIXTY TWO POINT
EIGHT MILLION DOLLAR SHORTFALL.
WHY I WANTED I DON'T BELIEVE
IT'S FAIR TO CALL THE SHORTFALL
SO THESE ARE AS I MENTIONED WITH
COMMUTER RAIL WITH INNER CITY
RAIL?
THOSE ARE SERVICES THAT TODAY
RECEIVE OPERATING SUPPORT SO
FAREBOX RECOVERY DOESN'T FIND A
100% OF THE OPERATE OPERATE
SUPPORT COME SOMEWHERE.
WHEN THE CASE OF INNER CITY RAIL --
THE STATE -- PROVIDES FUNDING SO
THE STATE.
MAKES UP A SHORTFALL.
THAT'S CORRECT IGHT THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN COSTA REVENUE
IS A SHORTFALL CORRECT -- I'M
USING THE LANGUAGE OF THE REPORT
SURE I JUST IN IN TERMS OF YOU
KNOW WHAT WHAT OF A BASELINE
FUNDING IS IS WHAT I'M GETTING
AT THAT WEEK WE FIND THESE
SERVICES TODAY THESE INTER CITY
RAIL SERVICES.
AND IS OTHER SOURCES OF FUNDING
AS WELL FOR COMMUTER RAIL
SERVICES SO THOSE ARE EXISTING.
FUNDING MECHANISMS AND AND I
MEAN FOR THESE [inaudible]
SO.
I THINK WE'RE SAYING I THINK I
THINK YOU'RE TRYING TO TO TRY.
TO NOT REALLY ANSWER THE
QUESTION BUT LET ME READ FROM
THE REBUTTAL FROM PROP ONE A IN
THE ON THE BALLOT [inaudible]
WHICH IS.
IT'S SIMPLE AND FAIR ONCE
COMPLETED THE USERS OF THE
SYSTEM PAY FOR THE SYSTEM.
RIGHT SO THERE'S NO SUBSIDY
THERE'S NO THERE'S NO STATE
FUNDING IN ADDITION TO MAKING UP
THE SHORTFALL.
I MEAN THIS IS WHAT IS ON THE
MEND PATTERSON'S ALLUDING TO
WRITE.
WHICH IS.
WHAT WHO MAKES WHO PAYS FOR THE
SHORTFALL?
AS A STATE AT THE COMMENT.
AND SUBSIDIZE AND BACK FILL.
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE COST
IN THE REVENUES OF THE SYSTEM.
BUT AGAIN IT'S AN EIGHT I THINK
WE'RE I THINK WE'RE GENERALLY IN
IN AGREEMENT ON ON THE STEPS
FACTUAL ISSUES THAT FOR THE THE
FALL -- NON SUBSIDIZED THE READ
THE HIGH SPEED RAIL LINKING --
HIGH SPEED RAIL PROVIDED SERVICE --
THAT IS LOOKING AT A LONGER
SEGMENT THAT WOULD GET VALLEY TO
VALLEY SAN JOSE TO BAKERSFIELD
SAY THAT'S THE SEGMENT THAT
WOULD.
WHERE YOU'D HAVE THE RIDERSHIP --
REVENUE FULLY FUNDING THE
OPERATIONS AGAIN THESE INTERIM
SERVICE OPPORTUNITIES BE A
CALTRAIN ALBEIT CENTRAL VALLEY
SERVICE -- THESE ARE SERVICES
WHERE THERE ARE IS OPERATING
SUPPORT CURRENTLY AND THAT WOULD
CONTINUE WITH THE OPERATE WITH
THE INTERIM SERVICES LET ME ASK
THE QUESTION A DIFFERENT WAY.
DOES.
THE CENTRAL VALLEY PORTION PAY
FOR ITSELF.
IN TERMS OF OPERATIONS IN TERMS
OF EVERYTHING.
BUT THERE THERE WOULD BE ONGOING
OPERATING SUPPORT -- FOR THE
THREE SEGMENTS THAT ARE
OPERATING THE SYSTEM TOGETHER
AGAIN THE A FOR A FOUR BY WHO.
AT THE STATE WOULD BE PART OF
THAT THE STATE WOULD PAY FOR IT
WE ARE TODAY SO THAT IS NOT.
SO WHAT WAS IN THE BALLOT
ARGUMENT IS THAT TRUE.
THE USERS OF THE SYSTEM PAY FOR
THE SYSTEM.
YOU'RE TELLING ME NOW THAT THE
STATE'S GONNA OP THE OFFSET SOME
OF THE COSTS.
WELL AGAIN THIS IS THE
DISTINCTION BETWEEN WHO'S
PROVIDING THE SERVICE IT WOULD
NOT BE DIRECTLY HIGH SPEED RAIL
BE ONE OF THESE OTHER RAIL
PROVIDERS.
AGAIN IS DONE IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN LOS ANGELES WITH
THE THE BOOK IN INVESTMENTS SO
MY LAST QUESTION IS THIS -- AND
I APPRECIATE THE GERMANS
PATIENTS SO IN IN THIS OUR NEWS
ARTICLE I THINK OFF THE NBC IS
NBC STORY.
I WANT TO READ THIS QUOTE AND I
WANT TO GET YOUR ANSWER OR YOUR
PERSPECTIVE.
LUTON SENSORS ON AN INDEPENDENT
PEER REVIEW GROUP THAT OVERSEES
THE HIGH SPEED RAIL PROJECT FOR
THE GOVERNOR AND LEGISLATURE
THOMPSON TOLD NBC BAY AREA HE
BELIEVES THE ENTIRE PROJECT IS
IN CRISIS.
QUOTE THE TRUTH IS THAT THE PACE
OF CONSTRUCTION REALLY WILL HAVE
TO PICK UP RAPIDLY IF IN FACT
IT'S GOING TO BE FINISHED BEFORE
THE TWENTY TWENTY DEADLINE
THOMPSON SAID.
CAN THIS BE DONE.
WE WELL WE NEED TO ASK THE
AUTHORITY AND WE NEED TO MAKE
THEM.
WE NEED TO MAKE THEM MAKE A STE
FOUR SOLID ENFORCEABLE
COMMITMENT ABOUT WHAT THEY CAN
DO.
THOMPSON BELIEVES THAT THE ONLY
WAY THE PROJECT CAN CONTINUE AS
DESIGNED THIS FOR THE STATE TO
RAISE TAXES AND DRASTICALLY
INCREASE CONSTRUCTION.
DO YOU AGREE WITH THAT.
STATEMENT.
BUT THE I AGREE THAT WE NEED TO
ACCELERATE OUR DELIVERY IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY SO I AGREE WITH
THAT A 100%.
SO THAT'S NOT A HARD GO IS THAT
A MAYBE.
GETTY HAVE AGREED WITH THE
STABLE WE NEED TO ACCELERATE OUR
OUR CONSTRUCTION SO THE SAME MSQ
IN HIS THAT THOMPSON BELIEVES
THE ONLY WAY THE PROJECT
CONTINUOUS DESIGNED IS FOR THE
STATE TO RAISE MORE TAXES AND
DRASTICALLY INCREASE
CONSTRUCTION.
IS THAT SOMETHING THAT YOU'D
THAT THE ALREADY AND
ADMINISTRATION IS CONSIDERING.
AGAIN NOT ON THE WE'RE LOOKING
AT THE MONEY WE HAVE INTO
DELIVERING.
A HIGH SPEED RAIL SEGMENT WITH
THE MONEY WE HAVE AN FOR C. TO
HAVE IN THE FUTURE.
WE'RE NOT LOOKING AT INCREASING
TAXES OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
THE IDEA IS TO GET THE DELIVERY
DONE GET THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
TRAINS UP AND OPERATING AND THEN
YES I BELIEVE LOOK FOR THAT
FEDERAL PARTNERSHIP TO RESUME.
SURE THAT WOULD INCLUDE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING IN THE FUTURE
AS WELL.
SO ALL THIS AND WITH THIS
STATEMENT -- THIS THE LAST
RECORD AS WE NEED TO HAVE THAT
THE ALREADY MAKE A FULL SOLID
ENFORCEABLE COMMITMENT AND I
DON'T HEAR A FULL SOLID
ENFORCEABLE COMMITMENT.
THE ASSUMPTIONS MADE IN THIS
REPORT OUR OUR ARE DIFFICULT. TO
BE CUT TO TO ACCEPT IT BECAUSE
THEY DON'T.
YOU THE REPORT ISN'T IN REALITY
RIGHT SO THE COSTS ARE GOING TO
BE HIGHER.
THE MARGINS ARE JEWS ARE YOU USE
THAT YOU HAVE NO MARGIN.
THE CAP AND TRADE FUNDING GOES
DOWN OVER TIME IF CAP AND TRADE
IS GOING TO SUCCEED.
IF IT AND AND THAT IS BEEN
ACCEPTED BY BY BY EVERYONE EVEN
WHO DOES YOU DESIGN CAP AND
TRADE.
NEED BUZZ -- AND UNCLEAR WHETHER
YOU CAN GET A PROPOSAL FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS ENGAGED -- SICK
REVIEWS ARE GOING FORWARD
LAWSUITS ARE GOING FORWARD.
THEY WHAT WAS TOLD TO THE VOTERS
IN TWENTY AND TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
AND WHAT THE DESIGN OF THIS
PROJECT IS NOW IS NOT THE SAME.
IT IS NOT THE SAME NO ONE CAN
TELL ME THAT WHAT WAS TOLD TO
THE VOTERS IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
WHAT THAT SEGMENT WAS SUPPOSED
TO BE.
FROM BAY THE BAY AREA TO ANAHEIM
THAT THIS REPORT DOES NOT
OUTLINED THAT AND SO I CAN WAIT
TILL TWENTY TWENTY FOR YOU TO
TELL ME WHAT THIS NEW ALIGNMENTS
GOING TO BE AND WHETHER WE HAVE
ENVIRONMENTAL CLEARANCE OR NOT.
BUT WE'RE GONNA WAIT TWENTY
TWENTY AND WE'RE GOING TO SPEND
AND YOU GUYS ARE GONNA SPEND A
WHOLE LOT MORE TAXPAYER DOLLARS.
SO I WOULD HOPE THAT AT SOME
POINT YOU CAN GIVE ME A FULL
ANALYSIS A WITH THIS ENTIRE
PROJECT IN A LOOK LIKE AND GIVE
ME SOME RANGES BUT RIGHT NOW IF
I EVEN IF I ACCEPTED THE L. E.
L. ANALYSIS WHICH IS TRUE.
ALL SIX OF FOR ASSUMPTIONS
ARCHER OUR OUR OUR OUR OUR
CONCERNS ARE TRUE.
YOU REFOCUS THE PROJECT WHICH IS
NOT WHAT DOES PROMISE TO THE
VOTERS.
ACTUAL COSTS CAN BE HIGHER THEY
WILL BE HIGHER WE HAVE A 70%
CHANCE OF SUCCESS AT 30% CHANCE
OF FAILURE THERE'S UNCERTAINTY
WITH CAP AND TRADE.
THERE'S NO FUNDING OUTLINED.
THAT IN DETAIL FROM MERCED TO
BAKERSFIELD -- AND THE
LEGISLATURE NOW HAS TO REASSESS
THAT IS PROJECT.
AT A TIME WHEN YOU'RE NOT GIVING
US ANY INFORMATION UNTIL NEXT
YEAR.
AND SO THIS IS REALLY TROUBLING
TO ME AND AT THIS POINT IN TIME.
THIS PROJECT GOT STOP.
AND AND AND IF YOU WANT TO SEE
AS A MEMBER RIVAS OR WHAT IT'S
GONNA LOOK LIKE YOUR COMMUNITY.
I LAYS AS SUGGESTED YOU TALK TO
SOME AND PATTERSON BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
FRESNO RIGHT NOW [inaudible]
MISTER MOM.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND THANK
YOU -- MISS RANDA'SFOR YOUR
GOOD WORK ON A COMPLEX PROJECT
AND FOR ANSWERING THE QUESTIONS
TODAY.
WELL I JOIN THE CONVERSATION
MIDSTREAM HERE ON THE DAY SO OF
MY APOLOGIES IF -- YOU'VE
TOUCHED ON THIS BUT THERE ARE
MULTIPLE REFERENCES -- TO UNDER
THE EARLY -- INTERIM SERVICE
SCENARIO THAT THE SERVICE IS
CONTINGENT.
ON A HIGHLY INTEGRATED RAIL
SERVICE FROM SACRAMENTO OAKLAND
AND SAN JOSE INTO -- THE BAY
AREA DO YOU ANTICIPATE.
ANY DELAY SPECIFICALLY -- WITH
THE BOOK AND PROJECTS
OBSERVATION -- THE JOB CENTERS --
TO THE NORTH AND SOUTH UNDER
THIS SCENARIO DO YOU EXPECT --
DELAY.
NO AND YOU KNOW AS YOU KNOW CARE
CALTRAIN IS IS MOVING FORWARD
WITH CONSTRUCTION AND THE RAIL
CARS I BELIEVE -- ARE BEING
BUILT.
ALREADY AS WELL IN UTAH -- SO
THAT PROJECTS IS CLEARED
ENVIRONMENTAL ALL THE FUNDING
AGREEMENTS HAVE BEEN SIGNED.
MONEY IS BEING REIMBURSED TO
CALTRANS -- FROM THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL PROJECTS SO THAT THAT FIFTY
MILE -- SEGMENT BEING
ELECTRIFIED YEAH ON THE
PENINSULA IS IS GOING FORWARD
AND THERE'S NOTHING IN HERE THAT
WOULD WOULD CHANGE THAT.
I WILL MENTION IN LOS ANGELES --
THE LOS ANGELES UNION STATION
PROJECT.
AS ALSO HAVING SOME CHALLENGES
WITH NEPA -- THEY'RE GOING
FORWARD WITH A SEQUEL FOR
STRATEGY AS WELL AT THIS PERIOD
OF TIME.
BUT AGAIN AS FAR AS THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL FUNDING AND THERE'S
NOTHING IN HERE THAT WOULD
CHANGE THAT COMMITMENT.
TO WE'RE STILL VERY MUCH --
SUPPORTIVE OF THAT PROJECT AND
WANT TO BE A FUNDING PARTNER FOR
THAT PROJECT RIGHT SO YOU'VE
YOU'VE TALKED ABOUT.
NIPAH NET.
TENUOUS RELATIONSHIP -- TO PUT
IT.
A NICELY WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IN A IN. TWENTY
NINETEEN DO YOU EXPECT.
THE BOOK AND PROJECTS
SPECIFICALLY -- YOU'VE TALKED
ABOUT NEPA I THINK YOU SAID
DEEPER FIRST IS THAT RIGHT SO SO.
ARE THERE ADDITIONAL FEDERAL
ENVIRONMENTAL APPROVALS THAT ARE
STILL NEEDED.
OUTSTANDING APPROVALS FOR THE TO
BOOK AND PROJECTS -- FOR THE LA
UNION STATION LA ONLY BUT I
BELIEVE CALTRAIN IS ALL
ENVIRONMENTALLY CLEARED WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OKAY
[inaudible]
AND I WOULD JUST I CONCLUDE YOU
KNOW THIS THIS RELATIONSHIP WITH
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OVER THE
TIME HORIZON OF THIS PROJECT
WE'RE GOING TO SEE MULTIPLE
ADMINISTRATIONS PROBABLY.
WITH PERHAPS A VERY DIFFERENT
VIEW.
FACT THE CURRENT ADMINISTRATION.
LET'S TALK ABOUT TWO TRILLION
DOLLAR INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS
[inaudible]
INFRASTRUCTURE NATIONALLY IS
GOING TO GET.
ADDITIONAL ATTENTION BY MULTIPLE
ADMINISTRATIONS MOVING FORWARD
SO WE'RE LOOKING AT THIS IN A
TWENTY NINETEEN CONTEXT.
BUT THIS IS A LAUNCH TO DON'T
PROJECT.
OF OF MASSIVE SCALE.
NOT AND I ANTICIPATE AT SOME
POINT FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WILL BE
A FULL PARTNER IN THIS AND WE
NEED THAT WE DO.
BUT LOOKING AT THE TWENTY
NINETEEN SORT OF A CONFIGURATION
AND UP AND UP EXTRAPOLATING THAT
OUT -- IN WELL INTO THE FUTURE I
THINK IS IS UP.
A LITTLE BIT OF FOLLY BUT I
SHARE THE ANXIETY ABOUT THE
CURRENT.
RELATIONSHIP -- BUT I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON A VERY
VERY DIFFICULT TOPIC AS CHAIR.
AND JUST TO BE CLEAR AND I THINK
WE'LL TAKE UP PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ON ON ON THE SIDE A BIT BEFORE
WE MOVE ON ISSUE -- FOR SINCE
WE'VE ALREADY SPENT SO MUCH TIME
ON THIS ITEM WE SHOULD ISOLATE
THE PUBLIC COMMENT TOO I THINK.
BUT I WANT TO BE -- A CLEAR IN
UNDERSTANDING -- THE ROLE OF THE
FEDERAL FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
CURRENTLY IS IT CORRECT THAT
WE'RE BEING ASKED -- TO A
DEMONSTRATE THAT THE PROJECT CAN
MOVE FORWARD EXPEDITIOUSLY BY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
CORRECT YEAH THEIR DATES IN A
LETTER OF COURSE -- INDICATING
CONCERN ON ON THE SCHEDULE --
HIGH SPEED RAIL RESPONDED NO
INDICATING WERE COMPLYING WITH
THE GRANT AGREEMENT AND STILL
ABLE TO MEET THE TWENTY TWENTY
TWO DEADLINES FOR THE SCHEDULE --
SO AGAIN THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
IS A IS A PARTNER IN ACHIEVING
SOME OF THOSE DELIVERABLES SUCH
AS THE FEDERAL NEPA -- HAVE
REVIEW AND APPROVAL.
AND YET IT'S ALSO MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT NOW IS -- ESSENTIALLY
REFUSING TO ENGAGE -- ON MOVING
THE PROJECT FORWARD.
WOULD THAT BE AN ACCURATE
STATEMENT THAT'S CORRECT YEAH
THEY HAVEN'T SAID.
THAT THEN PENCILS DOWN ON THAT
THE NEED FOR WORK I BELIEVE
SINCE LAST AUGUST.
AND AS SINCE THE LETTERS CAME
OUT THEY THEY HAVEN'T -- HAVEN'T
MET WITH HIGH SPEED RAIL.
WELL I THINK THAT SPEAKS FOR
ITSELF.
LET'S TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT NOW
ARE THERE ANY MEMBERS THE PUBLIC
WOULD LIKE TO BE.
HEARD ON THE ON THE SIDE OF
ISSUE.
THREE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS THE BIG WITH THEIR NEED
ASSISTANCE FOR THE PROFESSIONAL
ENGINEERS IN CALIFORNIA
GOVERNMENT.
THIS COMMITTEE FOR SEVERAL YEARS
GOING ON TEN YEARS NOW HAS HEARD
ABOUT THESE.
COST INCREASES THAT YOU'VE ALL
BEEN DISCUSSING.
IN ADDITION TO THE NBC --
INVESTIGATION THE LA TIMES ALSO
RECENTLY COMPLETED THEIR OWN
INVESTIGATION OF HIGH SPEED RAIL.
AND WHAT THEY FOUND WAS THAT ONE
OF THE LARGEST REASONS FOR THESE
COST INCREASES.
IS BECAUSE OF THE OVER RELIANCE
FOR ALMOST COMPLETE RELIANCE ON
PRIVATE SECTOR ENGINEERING
CONSULTANTS TO RUN THE PROJECT.
THEY HAVE PRIVATE SECTOR
CONSULTANTS HIRING PRIVATE
SECTOR CONSULTANTS TO OVERSEE
PRIVATE SECTOR CONSULTANTS.
HAVE BEING INSPECTED BY PRIVATE
SECTOR CONSULTANTS ALL AT A COST
OF TWO OR THREE TIMES THE COST
OF WHAT.
THE STATE EMPLOYED ENGINEER
WOULD BE.
WE THINK THAT THE COMMITTEE
SHOULD FIND A WAY OF HAVING THE
AGENCY STAFF UP OVER THE LONGER
TERM SO THAT YOU CAN REDUCE YOUR
COSTS AND GAIN CONTROL OF THE
PROJECT.
AND REDUCE THESE COSTS IN GOING
FORWARD WE DON'T THINK YOU
SHOULD WAIT FOR FUTURE BUDGET
YEAR -- THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY SHOULD HEART START
HIRING DESIGN ENGINEERS AND
CONSTRUCTION INSPECTION
ENGINEERS TO SAVE COSTS ON THE
PROJECT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR BLOOM AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS ROLAND TO
BROWN HI COME FROM SAN JOSE I
HAVE NO AFFILIATION.
I'D LIKE TO VERY BRIEFLY TOUCH
ON THE ALIGNMENT AND THE
DECISION TO START OPERATIONS
CENTER VALLEY.
STARTING WITH THE ALIGNMENT
THERE IS ABSOLUTELY NO WAY.
THAT THE NON ALIGNMENT BETWEEN
MISS SET AND BAKERSFIELD WILL
EVER BECOMPETITIVE WITH A
TRAVEL IN BETWEEN LA AND SAN
FRANCISCO.
SO I URGE YOU TO HOLD ON THE
FOOT OF THE FUNDING FOR THIS
PROJECT.
UNTIL THE AUTHORITY TERMINATE
ALL CONTRACTS SOUTH OF FRESNO.
AND STARTS ENVIRONMENTAL
CLEARANCE ON A DIRECT CONNECTION
BETWEEN ZERO AND FRESNO.
THAT REQUIRES LITTLE TO NO
COMMENT.
WITH REGARDS TO OPERATIONS.
THE BUSINESS CASE FOR STARTING
OPERATIONS CENTER VALLEY.
IS BASED ON INCORRECT DATA.
PROVIDED BY THE AUTHORITY TO
JUDGE THE TRAIN OPERATOR.
INCLUDING INFLATED RIDERSHIP
FIGURES IN CENTRAL VALLEY.
LOW RIDERSHIP ESTIMATES AND
INFLATED COST OF OPERATIONS IN
THE PENINSULA.
AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST.
THERE IS NO MENTION IN THE
RIPPLES OF EMERGING OF EMERGING.
PRIVATE SECTOR INTEREST.
IN OPERATING A HIGH SPEED
SERVICE BETWEEN.
SAN FRANCISCO AND GET WROTE AND
POTENTIALLY HOLLISTER THANK YOU.
SO LET ME -- CLOSE THIS -- ITEM
OUT WITH A COUPLE OF COMMENTS
AND THANK YOU -- MISTRANSLATED
TEAM FOR PROVIDING US WITH --
WITH AN UPDATE HERE TODAY IT IS
JUST AN UPDATE IT'S ONE STOP
ALONG THE WAY -- THE THIS -- AT
IN MY VIEW THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
PROJECT THAT REMAINS -- NOT JUST --
ONE OF CALIFORNIA'S MOST
IMPORTANT -- INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS BUT ONE OF THE
COUNTRY'S MOST IMPORTANT
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS WE ARE --
ONE OF THE FEW INDUSTRIALIZED
NATIONS IN THE WORLD -- THAT
TODAY NOT -- DO NOT HAVE HIGH
SPEED RAIL NOW IS THAT IN AND OF
ITSELF A REASON WHY WE HAVE TO
HAVE IT HERE NO -- BUT THERE ARE
COMPELLING REASONS WHY HIGH
SPEED RAIL IS IMPORTANT TO
CALIFORNIA TO THE COUNTRY OF
THOSE OF ALL BEEN DISCUSSED IN
THE PAST THE VOTERS ACTUALLY
WEIGHED IN ON THIS ALTHOUGH.
I YOU KNOW IT WAS SOMETIME AGO
BUT THEY PROVIDED THE SEED MONEY
FOR THE PROJECT -- OPPOSITION TO
THIS PROJECT HAS BEEN -- AGAIN
OF THIS BIG PROJECT IT GENERATES
OPPOSITION I GUESS I GET THAT --
BUT WHETHER -- THE SAME FOLKS
WERE IN OPPOSITION WHO WERE IN
OPPOSITION TODAY AND NOW THAT --
I THINK A MORE REALISTIC
PROPOSALS BEING MADE -- IN
RESPONSE TO THOSE WHO SAT AND
COMPLAINED -- THERE'S NO MONEY
TO BUILD OUT THE ENTIRE SYSTEM
WE SHOULD BE FOCUSED ON WHAT WE
ACTUALLY CAN DO AND NOW WE HAVE
AN UPDATE THAT TRIES TO DO
EXACTLY THAT.
AND THE SAME CRITICS ARE OF ALL
OVER THE PROJECT SAYING WELL YOU
KNOW THAT'S OUTRAGEOUS -- AND
YOU'RE NOT PROVIDING THE
INFORMATION THAT YOU'RE SUPPOSED
TO BE PROVIDING AND ALL THE
OTHER ARGUMENTS THAT WE HEAR AND
I YOU KNOW I RESPECT THE FACT
THAT THERE.
ARE CONCERNS ABOUT THIS PROJECT
PARTLY BECAUSE IT'S SO BIG AND
PARTLY BECAUSE I'VE IT TAKES.
UGH UGH A LONG TIME UNDER.
ANY SCENARIO TO BUILD OUT A
PROJECT TO OF THIS LENGTH AND
THERE ARE ALSO A NUMBER OF IN
SPEND CERTAINTIES -- WHICH COME
ALONG WITH ANY PUBLIC WORKS
PROJECT OF THIS MAGNITUDE.
OF WE NEED TO WORK THROUGHOUT
THE THROUGH THOSE ISSUES STEP BY
STEP AND STAGE BY STAGE AND I
THINK THAT THE GOVERNOR.
IS TRYING TO DO THAT NOW AND
TAKE A MORE REALISTIC OF OF YOU
OF WHAT WE CAN DO IN THE NEAR
TERM UNDERSTANDING THAT THERE
ARE ADDITIONAL STEPS.
AND THAT THE FULL BUILD OUT OF
THIS PROJECT IS ESSENTIAL -- AND
AND NEEDS TO FOLLOW ALONG WITH
WHAT'S BEING PROPOSED IN THE IN
THE UPDATE -- I DON'T I DON'T
THINK A AND THIS IS STILL TRUE
AND IN EVERY DISTRICT IN THE
STATE I THINK THIS IS A PROJECT
THAT PEOPLE LOOK AT KIND OF
SCRATCH THEIR HEADS AND THINK.
IS IT REALISTIC IS IT NOT COULD
THIS MONEY BE BETTER SPENT IN
OTHER WAYS THERE ARE A LOT OF
LEGITIMATE CONVERSATIONS AROUND
THIS.
BUT THE PROJECT ITSELF THE NEED
FOR HIGH SPEED RAIL AS A
ENVIRONMENTALLY FAVORABLE
PROJECT -- AS A RELIEF VALVE FOR
OUR BE LEADER -- AIR
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM FOLKS OUR
AIRPORTS -- I YOU KNOW I KNOW
MOST OF YOU WHO ARE HERE AND OR
LISTENING -- TO THIS HEARING
TODAY -- TRAVEL BY AIR FROM
PLACE TO PLACE IN CALIFORNIA.
OF OUR AIRPORTS ARE NEAR MAXED
OUT AND WE NEED TO BE THINKING
LONG TERM FOR THE FUTURE OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA -- AIR
TRAVEL -- IS ALSO.
YOU KNOW USES A LOT OF FOSSIL
FUELS AND WERE ABLE THROUGH HIGH
SPEED RAIL TO SHIFT INTO A MORE
SUSTAINABLE.
OF A SYSTEM THERE ARE -- AMIRI
OUT OF OTHER REASONS WHY THIS
PROJECT IS IMPORTANT -- AND I
THINK THE DEBATE IS GOING TO
CONTINUE -- I REACHED SPECTRUM
AS TRANSFER STEPPING INTO THIS
ROLE COMING HERE TODAY AND
SUFFERING THE THE THE SLINGS AND
ARROWS -- WHICH THIS IS OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO PROVIDE THAT
ARE THAT OVERSIGHT BUT YOU'RE
HERE YOU'RE STILL STANDING THE
PROJECT IS STILL STANDING AND I
EXPECT THAT IT'S GOING TO
CONTINUE WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE
TO PROVIDE.
THE OVERSIGHT DEMANDING ANSWERS
FROM YOU THAT -- HELP MAKE THIS
A LONG TERM PROJECT THAT IS
MAXIMALLY SUCCESSFUL FOR THE
PEOPLE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU FOR THOSE COMMENTS --
YOU'RE WELCOME AND WITH THAT
WILL MOVE ON TO ISSUE -- FOR BY
THE WAY -- ISSUE THREE WAS JUST --
FOR THE SUIT DIDN'T REALIZE IT
WAS AS INFORMATION ONLY -- AND
FOR WAS HERE A LOT OF
INFORMATION BUT THE ISSUE FOR IS --
CONTRACT MANAGEMENT FINANCIAL
OFFICE RESOURCES -- AGAIN WE
HAVE A RECOMMENDATION ON THIS
ITEM TO HOLD OPEN AND LET'S SEE
IF WE CAN'T TAKE A LITTLE BIT
LESS TIME ON THIS ONE THAT WE
DID ON LAST.
ISSUE NUMBER.
FOUR THE CALIFORNIA STATE
AUDITOR RELEASES REPORT ON
NOVEMBER FIFTEENTH TWO THOUSAND
AND EIGHTEEN AND AMONG OTHER
FINDINGS FOUND THAT THE
AUTHORITY SHOULD SHIFT.
CERTAIN WORKLOAD ACTIVITIES FOR
THE PRIVATE CAUGHT FROM THE
PRIVATE CONTRACTORS THE STATE
STAFF.
WELL THE THOUGHT IS CONDUCTING A
BROADER REVIEW OF THE ENTIRE
ORGANIZATION.
THE INITIAL REQUEST YOU'VE
WRITTEN FOR THE U. TODAY WILL
REDUCE THE OVERALL PROGRAM COSTS
ABOUT EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
THANK YOU BE IMPLEMENTED FAIRLY
QUICKLY BY REDUCING THE NUMBER
OF ASSAULT POSITIONS SUPPORTING
ADMINISTRATIVE FUNCTIONS SUCH AS
CONTRACT MANAGEMENT.
IN THE FINANCIAL OFFICE AND
REPLACING THOSE CONSULTANTS WITH
STATE STAFF.
THE REQUESTED CLOSE AN INCREASE
OF THIRTY FIVE STATE POSITIONS
AT FOUR POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS.
IN PROPOSITION ONE A FUNDING
WHICH WILL BE OFFSET BY
REDUCTION OF THIRTY FIVE AND SO
ON IF TEAS.
AND FIVE POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS.
THUS FREEING UP THE CONTRACT
FUNDING FOR CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE SERVICES SUCH AS
REAL OPERATIONS ENGINEERING AND
INFRASTRUCTURE DELIVERY -- THAT
CONCLUDES MY PRESENTATION I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS THANK
YOU ANY QUESTIONS SEEING NONE
ALEJO.
HI HOW INCREASING AT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE WE
DON'T HAVE ANY SIGNIFICANT
CONCERNS WITH THE PROPOSAL IT
DOES SEEM REASONABLE -- TO
FOLLOW THE AUDITOR'S
RECOMMENDATION AND START
SHIFTING TOWARDS MORE STATE
STAFFORD FOR THESE TYPES OF
FUNCTIONS WE JUST KNOW THAT
THERE'S NO COMMENSURATE
REDUCTION ON THE CONSULTING
STAFF AND THE REASON.
OF CREATED A FORTY FOR THAT IS
THAT THEY EXPECTED TO BASICALLY
WE ALLOCATE THIS CONSULTING
CONTRACT FUNDS -- TO OTHER
ACTIVITIES JUST WOULD NOTE THAT
THE BUDGET THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT --
THROUGH ITS OVERSIGHT PROCESS
THAT THAT REALLY THE REDUCTION
CONSULTING STAFF IS OCCURRING --
AS PLANNED AND AND AND JUST BE
ABLE BUT MY FOCUS A LITTLE BIT
LESS DIFFICULT AT LAST IT WAS
EASY TO SORT OF MONITOR GIVEN
THAT BUDGETING APPROACH.
THANK YOU BERMAN FINANCE A NO
COMMENT.
RIGHT -- IS THERE ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ISSUE.
FOR SEEING NONE -- THE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO HOLD OPEN SO
WE'LL KEEP THAT -- ONE HOLD THAT
IN ADVANCE AND UP -- DRESSER TO
FUTURE MEETING.
OUR NEXT DEPARTMENT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AGAIN FOR THE
PRESENTATIONS THIS MORNING.
I WE HAVE A THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION NEXT ISSUE.
FIVE ENERGY RESOURCES PROGRAM'S
ACCOUNTS.
WELCOME GOOD MORNING THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MORNING DREW BONE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION.
THIS ITEM DEALS AS YOU NOTED
SHARE WITH THE ENERGY RESOURCES
PROGRAMS ACCOUNT OTHERWISE KNOWN
AS HERBA.
AND IT IS IN A STRUCTURAL
DEFICIT.
HAS BEEN FOR A FEW YEARS.
OVER THE LAST DECADE THE DEMAND
FOR OUR SERVICES AT THE ENERGY
COMMISSION HAVE BEEN INCREASING
WE HAVE GOTTEN -- ABOUT SEVENTY
NEW PEOPLE -- AT THE ENERGY
COMMISSION BY OF THE LEGISLATURE.
AT THE SAME TIME A REVENUES HAVE
BEEN DECLINING.
WHY IS THAT THERE'S TWO MAIN
FACTORS THE FIRST IS BUYING THE
METER SOLAR WE'VE BEEN?
TREMENDOUSLY SUCCESSFUL IN
CALIFORNIA OVER THE LAST DECADE
OR SO IN INCREASING THE AMOUNT
OF ROOFTOP SOLAR.
FACT WE HAVE EIGHT GIGAWATTS
TODAY GIVE OR TAKE WHICH IS
ENOUGH ENERGY TO POWER THE STATE
OF VERMONT.
SO WE DON'T REALLY WELL THERE
SECONDLY WE'VE DONE VERY WELL IN
TERMS OF CONSERVATION WE ARE A
PER CAPITA ELECTRICITY USAGE 44%
BELOW THE NATIONAL AVERAGE.
AND THAT'S DUE TO A WHOLE HOST
OF FACTORS BUT AMONG THEM ARE
THE ENERGY COMMISSION'S A PLANTS
AND BUILDING REGULATIONS THAT
DRIVE DOWN ELECTRICITY
CONSUMPTION.
THESE TWO FACTORS TOGETHER --
HAVE CONSPIRED TO REDUCE OUR
REVENUES THEY'VE BEEN GREAT FOR
CALIFORNIANS IN TERMS OF
REDUCING ENERGY BILLS THEY HAVE
BEEN GREAT FOR HELPING US
ACHIEVE OUR AIR QUALITY IN OUR
CLIMATE GOALS BUT THE ENERGY
COMMISSION HAS SUFFERED BECAUSE
THEY HAVE A DIRECT IMPACT ON OUR
BUDGET.
AND THIS IS WHAT HAS BEEN
CONTRIBUTED OR STRUCTURAL
DEFICIT WHAT IS KEPT US AFLOAT
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS IS THE
FACT THAT WE HAVE BUILT A
RESERVE.
AND WE HAVE BEEN SPENDING DOWN
THAT RESERVE OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS -- LAST OVER THE LAST TWO
BUDGET CYCLES WE HAVE REDUCED
PRESSURE ON THIS -- BUT ACCOUNT
BY TWENTY SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
BUT THAT HASN'T BEEN ENOUGH TO
CLOSE THE DEFICIT ENTIRELY SO
WERE HERE BEFORE YOU TODAY WITH
A SUITE OF MEASURES THAT WILL
REDUCE THE DEFICIT FURTHER.
BY ANOTHER -- APPROXIMATELY TEN
MILLION DOLLARS -- IN THAT IS
WHAT WE ASK TODAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THANK YOU -- ANY QUESTIONS.
IS THERE A REPORT FROM MILLIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN RICH
ROSS BROWN OF THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE OUT WE WE DO
THINK THE PROPOSED PROPOSAL IS A
SIGNIFICANT STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION AND CONTINUES ON SOME
OF THE ACTIONS TO TRY TO ADDRESS
THE ANNUAL DEFICIT ARPA.
AND SO WE DID DO RECOMMENDED THE
LEGISLATURE ADOPTS THE PROPOSED
CHANGES.
WE ALSO THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
NOTE THAT THE PROPOSED CHANGES
ONLY PARTIALLY ADDRESS THE
ANNUAL DEFICIT.
EVEN IF THOSE CHANGES ARE
ADOPTED THEY'RE STILL -- THE
ADMINISTRATION PROJECTS ROUGHLY
SIX TO EIGHT MILLION DOLLAR
ANNUAL DEFICIT -- GOING FORWARD
AND SO -- UNDER THOSE
PROJECTIONS THE FUND WOULD BE
INSOLVENT AND TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY TWENTY THREE A BUDGET
YEAR AND SO -- THE LEGISLATURE
MIGHT WANT TO CONSIDER TAKING
SOME ADDITIONAL ACTIONS IN THE
NEAR TERM A WE WANNA KINDA
HIGHLIGHT A FEW EXAMPLES THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION -- LAID OUT
AS OPTIONS IN A REPORT THAT IT
ISSUED EARLIER THIS YEAR FOR
ADDITIONAL ACTIONS THAT COULD BE
TAKEN TO ADDRESS THE DEFICIT.
THOSE INCLUDE -- EXTENDING THE
SURCHARGE THAT RAISES REVENUE TO
BEHIND THE METER ELECTRICITY
THAT'S ONE OF THE THE MAIN --
CAUSES OF OF THE STRUCTURAL
DEFICIT IS THE DECREASE IN
REVENUE ASSOCIATED WITH --
ROOFTOP SOLAR BEHIND THE METER
ELECTRICITY -- DIRECTING THE PC
TO REMOVE THERE'S CURRENTLY A
CAP ON THE AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT
THEY WILL PROVIDE TO THE ENERGY
COMMISSION TO ADMINISTER THE
EPIC PROGRAM ON BEHALF OF THE
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES AND
THAT DOESN'T COVER ALL OF CECE'S
CURRENT COST ADMINISTER THOSE
PROGRAMS AND SO -- AT THE BUT
KIND OF PICKS UP A PORTION OF
THOSE COSTS AND SO THE
LEGISLATURE COULD LOOK AT CAMP
DIRECTING PC TO REMOVE THAT CAP
SO THEY CAN FULLY REIMBURSED CC
FOR THE COSTS -- ALL AS WELL AS
LOOKING AT JUST -- FIFTEEN
FUNDING SOURCES FOR OTHER
ACTIVITIES FOR EXAMPLE
DEPARTMENT WATER RESOURCES ARE
RECEIVE SUMMER BUT FUNDING FOR
WATER EFFICIENCY ACTIVITIES AND
SO THE LEGISLATURE COULD LOOK AT
OTHER FUNDING SOURCES FOR
EXAMPLE THE GENERAL FUND TO FUND
THOSE.
ACTIVITIES SO WE THINK IT -- THE
LEGISLATURE MY ONE ASKS THE
ADMINISTRATION'S REPORT ON THE
FEES OF THE FEASIBILITY OF SOME
OF THESE OPTIONS IN BUDGET
HEARINGS.
AND TO THE EXTENT THE
LEGISLATURE DOESN'T TAKE
ADDITIONAL ACTIONS TO FULLY
ADDRESS THE DEFICIT -- WE
RECOMMENDED A MINIMUM THEY
DIRECT THE ADMINISTRATION TO
ISSUE ANOTHER ANOTHER REPORT IN
PLAN NEXT YEAR TO FULLY ADDRESS
THE ANNUAL DEFICIT -- AND SO
THAT THE LEGISLATURE CAN KIND OF
HAVE THAT AVAILABLE IN FUTURE
YEARS ARE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU PARIS FRANCE KATHY
MACLEOD DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE
HAVE NO ISSUES WITH THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION.
THANK YOU -- AND LET'S SEE IF
THERE'S ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THE SIDE OF A ONE ONE SPEAK TO
THIS ITEM.
SEEING NONE -- THE
RECOMMENDATION IS TO APPROVE --
WITH A PLACEHOLDER SUPPLEMENTAL
REPORTING LANGUAGE -- THERE ARE
ADDITIONAL ACTIONS IT'LL -- NEED
TO BE TAKEN TO FULLY ADDRESS THE
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT HAS BEEN
REFERENCE AND OF COURSE WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH THE ENERGY COMMISSION -- TO
A ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM AND WITH
THAT IS THERE A MOTION TO
APPROVE WITH A PLACEHOLDER
LANGUAGE.
THE MOTION AND A SECOND THANK
YOU.
BLOOM HI FONG [inaudible]
GARCIA [inaudible]
MULLIN [inaudible]
PATTERSON [inaudible]
YES RIVAS.
THANK YOU OUR NEXT ITEM IS --
ISSUE.
SIX THE CPUC RESPONSE TO UTILITY --
BANKRUPTCY.
AND THE GUY IN THE COURSE OF
YOUR PRESENTATION IF YOU CAN
JUST ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF WHY
YOU CAN'T - ABSORB THE COST
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE
WITHIN YOUR CURRENT BUDGET THAT
WOULD HELP EXPEDITE THINGS
[inaudible]
HELLO CHAIRMAN.
AND ASSEMBLYMEMBERS MY NAME IS
BERNARD AS A VETO.
I AM THE ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES
DIRECTOR FOR THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION TODAY I
HAVE WITH ME MISTER JEFF ADDRESS.
DRIVEN SIDE HERE TO DISCUSS
ISSUE SIX PC RESPONSE UTILITY
BANKRUPTCY AND TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING THANK
CHAIRMAN JEFFORDS OF INSIDE FROM
THE LEGAL DIVISION.
THIS IF YOU SEE IS REQUESTING
FUNDING FOR LEGAL SERVICES
CONTRACT TO ADDRESS THE P.
JEANNIE BACKUPS IN RELATED
MATTERS.
THE AMOUNT OF FUNDING IS TWENTY
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS OVER THREE
YEARS.
THE LEGAL SERVICES CONTRACT
ISN'T UNANTICIPATED COST FOR
ADVICE AND REPRESENTATION ON
RESTRUCTURING FINANCE AND
BANKRUPTCY MATTERS.
AND TO YOUR POINT DE OF ABOUT OF
SERVICES THAT WE ARE PRO CHOIR
TO PAY FOR THESE SERVICES.
IS TOO LARGE THAT WE WOULD BE
ABLE -- TO I THINK OBSERVER
WITHOUT REQUESTING -- APPROVAL
FOR THESE FUNDS.
WE ARE ASKING FOR APPROVAL FOR
THE FUNDS BECAUSE THE PC IS AN
IMPORTANT STATE PARTY WAS
STANDING IN A SIGNIFICANT ROLE
TO PLAY.
IN THE PGA BANKRUPTCY.
THE CPC REGULATES MANY ASPECTS
OF P. GENIES OPERATIONS
INCLUDING ITS RATES ITS
FINANCIAL TRANSACTIONS ITS TERMS
AND CONDITIONS OF SERVICE.
AND SO WE NEED WE ALSO
IMPLEMENTED IMPORTANT PUBLIC
POLICY INITIATIVES AND PROGRAMS
SUCH AS CLEAN ENERGY.
ELECTRIC VEHICLE INFRASTRUCTURE
ENERGY EFFICIENCY AND PUBLIC
PURPOSE PROGRAMS.
BECAUSE OF ITS ROLE OVERSEEING
P. JEANNIE.
ANY PLAN OF REORGANIZATION OR P.
O. R. THAT IS PROPOSED IN THE
BANKRUPTCY PROCEEDING.
WOULD NEED TO BE APPROVED BY THE
CPSC AS WELL AS THE BANKRUPTCY
COURT AS IT WILL MOST CERTAINLY
INVOLVED RATE MAKING ISSUES.
AND ANY EXIT FINANCING WILL
REQUIRE THAT AGENCIES APPROVAL.
THE P. GINNY BANKRUPTCY IS A
LARGE DOLLAR VALUE CASE AN
EXTREMELY COMPLEX DEBT HOLDERS
EQUITY HOLDERS WELL FOR VICTIMS
AND OTHERS ARE ACTIVE IN THE
BANKRUPTCY PROCEEDING.
AND WILL BE THEMSELVES
REPRESENTED BY EXPERT COUNSEL.
BANKRUPTCY AND RESTRUCTURING ARE
SPECIALIZED AREAS OF LEGAL
PRACTICE AND IN THIS ENVIRONMENT
THE CPC MUST THINK A SPECIALIZED.
EXPERIENCE COUNSEL TO REPRESENT
OUR INTEREST AS A REGULATOR.
AS A RESULT THE CPUC MUST HAVE
FUNDS IN ITS BUDGET TO PAY FOR
EXPERT REPRESENTATION IN
BANKRUPTCY COURT.
COUNSEL FURTHER MUST BE ABLE TO
RELY ON AN EXPERT ADVISOR TO
EVALUATE THE COMPLEX FINANCIAL
CONDITIONS AND ARRANGEMENTS.
AND TO MONITOR THE FLOW OF
INFORMATION IN THE CAPITAL
MARKETS.
THE ESTIMATED COST OF THE
CONTRACT IS BASED ON OUR
EXPERIENCE IN THE PRIOR
BANKRUPTCY WHERE WE SPENT
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS WHICH IS ABOUT
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
TODAY'S FUNDS.
I CAN ADDRESS ANY OF THESE
POINTS IN MORE DETAIL OR ANSWER
ANY SPECIFIC QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE SO THAT -- THIRTY MILLION
DOLLAR EXPECTATION -- AND THE
TWENTY EIGHT MILLION DOLLAR ASK
YOUR TO IS THAT TWO MILLION
DOLLAR -- DELTA IS IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT THE DEPARTMENT
EXPECTS TO ABSORB -- AND IT'S
ONGOING OPERATION -- NO I THINK
WE BASED THE TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN PART ON A BACK OF THE
ENVELOPE LOOK AT THE PRIOR
PROCEEDING AND THAT ON SOME
ESTIMATES THAT WE RECEIVED FROM
OUR COUNCIL.
A WE CAN'T SAY HOW MUCH.
I DON'T THINK WE CAN PREDICT
WITH CERTAINTY HOW MUCH THIS
WILL END UP COSTING BUT RIGHT
NOW WE FEEL THE TWENTY EIGHT
MILLION.
IS A REASONABLE AMOUNT.
FINANCE I'M IN MY DEPARTMENT THE
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS IS WHAT
THE LAST BANKRUPTCY WOULD HAVE
ADJUSTED TO IF IT WERE HAPPENING
TODAY THAT'S NOT BE ESTIMATE OF
TWENTY EIGHT MILLION IS BASED ON
THE NUMBER OF HOURS.
AGAIN AN ESTIMATE THEY THINK
THAT THIS -- THAT THIS
PARTICULAR BANKRUPTCY WELL IN
HER SO IT'S IT'S IT'S A LITTLE
BIT APPLES AND ORANGES THERE BUT
IT DOES GIVE YOU A REASONABLE
NESS.
OF THE AT THAT LEVEL OF EFFORT
IT WAS NEED TO COMPARING THE
LAST BANKRUPTCY TO THIS.
ONE IS THIS ALL -- PREDICATED ON
THE USING CUT OUTSIDE COUNSEL OR
CEMEX OR I'M SORRY.
OUR IS IS PREDICATED ON USING
OUTSIDE COUNSEL OF VERSES IN
HOUSE YES THIS IS PREDICATED ON
USING OUTSIDE COUNSEL AND
OUTSIDE FINANCIAL ADVISER.
AN OUTSIDE COUNSEL ON THE
BANKRUPTCY -- AND A FINANCIAL
ADVISER ON THE AREAS FOCUS THE
BANKRUPTCY FOR WHICH PC DOESN'T
HAVE EXPERTISE THAT DOESN'T MEAN
THAT THEIR EXISTING LOCAL
COUNCILS ARE OUT OF THE PICTURE
OBVIOUSLY THEY HAVE EXTENSIVE S.
EXPERTISE AND RATE MAKING WILL
BE WORKING WITH THE OUTSIDE
COUNSEL BUT BANKRUPTCY IS NOT.
SOMETHING THAT HAPPENED HOUSE.
UNDERSTOOD LA -- ANY COMMENTS
YEAH -- I MEAN AS AS NOTED
THERE'S A LOT OF UNCERTAINTY
ABOUT AND EXACTLY HOW MUCH MONEY
WILL BE NEEDED FOR THESE
CONTRACTS SERVICES ARE WE DID
LOOK AT THE ESTIMATES NAY SEEMS
REASONABLE TO US ON WE DO WANT
TO JUST KIND OF HIGHLIGHT THAT
THE ESTIMATES ARE KIND OF OVER.
A THREE YEAR PERIOD AS WELL SO
THIS IS KIND ONE CHUNK OF MONEY
THAT THEY WOULD HAVE AVAILABLE
FOR A THREE YEAR PERIOD -- IF
THEY SORT OF FIND IN THE FUTURE
YEAR THAT THING ACOSTA COMING IN
HIGHER THAN THAT THEN THEY CAN.
COME BACK FOR A REQUEST FOR SOME
ADDITIONAL MONEY AT THAT TIME --
ALSO JUST WANT TO NOTE -- JUST
FOR THE COMMITTEES -- KNOWLEDGE
THERE IS A BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
ASSOCIATED WITHOUT THIS
ALLOCATION THAT RESTRICTS THE
FUNDS JUST TO KIND OF THESE
TYPES OF ACTIVITIES THAT ARE
PART OF RELATED TO THE
BANKRUPTCY CASE AND THEY
WOULDN'T BE AVAILABLE FOR OTHER
PC RELATED ACTIVITIES.
ALL RIGHT.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
IS THERE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THIS ITEM.
YOU'RE STANDING WE HAVE A HOLD
OPEN RECOMMENDATION.
SEEING NONE WE WILL -- WAIT.
WE WILL HOLD SAFE MODE VOTE BUT
WE'RE GONNA GET ONE COMMENT --
WILL HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN AND TO
TAKE ACTION AT A LATER MEETING
AND OUR NEXT ITEM IS -- OF
VARIOUS INVESTMENT REQUESTS --
MEMBER REQUESTS -- FOR
INVESTMENT DOLLARS.
AND I'M SEEING NO MEMBERS HERE
YET SO -- NOW WOULD BE THE TIME
FOR FOLKS TO COME UPSTAIRS WILL --
AT ALLOW MEMBERS -- TO MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE TO DO ADD ON
BOATS -- WHILE WE'RE WAITING I
WOULD LIKE TO POINT OUT MEMBERS
ARE STARTING TO ARRIVE NOW I
WOULD LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT --
AS I'VE TOLD INDIVIDUAL MEMBERS
AND MADE ANNOUNCEMENTS IN THE
PAST MEMBERS ARE FREE TO MAKE
PRESENTATIONS WILL TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT AFTER THEIR
PRESENTATIONS ARE COMPLETE --
THE FUNDING DECISIONS THAT
ULTIMATELY ARE MADE ARE NOT
PREDICATED ON THE PRESENTATIONS
THAT ARE MADE HERE BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE WE TAKE A A FAIR LOOK
AT ACROSS THE BOARD WITH THE
MAKE A PRESENTATION.
OR NOT SO I WANT TO MAKE THAT TO
A CLEAR FOR MEMBERS WHO MIGHT BE
LISTENING ON MY GOD I DIDN'T
PREPARE MYSELF FOR PRESENTATION
TODAY IT'S OKAY -- WERE GOING TO
CONSIDER ALL OF OUR ITEMS AND TO
MS AGUIAR-CURRY IF YOU CAN JUST
HOLD ON FOR ONE YOU'RE WELCOME
TO SET UP BUT WE'RE GONNA JUST
TAKE SOME QUICK BOTH HERE -- AND
THEN WE'LL MOVE ON WITH YOUR
ITEM.
OKAY WHEN JESUS WENT TO CALL THE
CISCO GUARD.
ONCE.
THESE ARE IN THE VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR.
AND THIS IS TO APPROVE AS IT
APPEARS IN THE AGENDA ITEMS.
1-457-810-1112 THIRTEEN AND
FIFTEEN GARCIA [inaudible]
MULLIN [inaudible]
PATTERSON.
NOW WILL TAKE THESE NEXT THE
ITEMS UP INDIVIDUALLY.
AND ON THESE NEXT TWO ITEMS THE
TEARS VOTE AS IT IS TO APPROVE
AS IT WAS ON THE PRIOR GROUP.
OF ITEMS THAT WE APPROVE -- THE
FIRST ISSUE IS NUMBER
[inaudible]
TWO GARCIA [inaudible]
MULLIN [inaudible]
PATTERSON.
THE NEXT ISSUE IS NUMBER THREE
GARCIA [inaudible]
MULLIN [inaudible]
PATTERSON.
THERE WE HAVE ISSUE NUMBER
[inaudible]
SIX GARCIA [inaudible]
MULLIN I PATTERSON.
AND THE LAST OF THESE ISSUES IS
NUMBER NINE GARCIA [inaudible]
MULLIN [inaudible]
PATTERSON.
AND THEN WE HAVE ONE REMAINING
ISSUE ON ITEMS TO BE HEARD.
THIS IS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION ISSUE NUMBER
[inaudible]
FIVE THE MOTION WAS TO PROVE HIS
PROPOSED AN ADOPT S. R. L. AND
THE CHAIR.
VOTED I MOTION WAS I PATTERSON
[inaudible]
RAMOS.
GREAT.
THANK YOU ALL.
AND MS AGUIAR-CURRY.
WE'RE ASKING GOD MEMBERS TO KEEP
YOUR PRESENTATIONS TO ABOUT TWO
MINUTES THANK YOU THE CLOCK ON
THAT YOU'RE ALL CAPABLE OF THAT
HELPING YOURSELF TO THAT TIME
LIMIT THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME
SOME TIME TO PRESENT THIS YEAR
I'M OFFERING NINE A. B. NINE
FIFTY EIGHT WHICH CREATES A
CALIFORNIA.
ORGANIC TO SCHOOL PILOT PROGRAM
THIS PILOT WILL ALLOW SCHOOLS TO
APPLY FOR UP. TO FIFTEEN CENTS
OF ADDITIONAL FUNDING PER MEAL
TO PURCHASE ORGANIC CALIFORNIA
GROWN LOCAL FOOD.
COSTS AND AVAILABILITY ISSUES
PREVENT MANY COMMUNITIES FROM
ACCESSING THESE HEALTHY FOODS
BUT MEALS PROVIDE IN THE SCHOOL
SETTING ARE A PRACTICAL WAY TO
INCREASE CHILDREN'S NUTRITION.
AND EXPOSED TO THESE A HOLE IN
MINIMALLY PROCESSED FOODS IN
ADDITION TO HAVING SCHOOLS
PURCHASE ORGANIC FOOD THE PILOT
WILL IDENTIFY BARRIERS THAT
PREVENT SCHOOLS FROM EX ASSESS
ACCESSING.
ORGANIC AND FACILITATE
ACTIVITIES THE SIR TO MAKE THE
SHIFT.
TOGETHER WITH A BROAD RANGE OF
AGRICULTURAL AND EDUCATION
SUPPORTERS I REQUEST A TWO
MILLION IN ONE TIME FUNDS FOR
THIS PROGRAM. TO BE ADMINISTERED
THROUGH THE OFFICE OF FARM TO
FORK WITHIN CDFA.
WITH THIS FUNDING THE SECRETARY
WILL BE ABLE TO ADMINISTER THE
PILOT AND THE PROVIDE AT LEAST
FIVE GRANTS TO SCHOOLS THE GRANT
MONEY WILL MAKE COVER THE
PREMIUM ACOSTA PURCHASING
CALIFORNIA GROWN ORGANIC FOODS.
BUT MAY NOT REPLACE FEDERAL
FUNDING BY RECORD REQUIRING A
REPORT BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE
WE'LL BE ABLE TO REVIEW THE
CHALLENGES THE BENEFITS.
AND THEN USE THIS INFORMATION TO
DETERMINE WHETHER INVESTING IN
PROVIDING KIDS A HEALTHY LOCAL
AND ORGANIC FOOD MONEY IS WELL
SPENT.
I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT. FOR
INCLUDING THIS IN YOUR BUDGET.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
PRESENTATION NEXT UP WE HAVE --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU.
OF FOLLOWED BY -- O'DONNELL
RIVAS AND OBERNOLTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
COLLEAGUES -- I'M HERE TO
REQUEST SOME ADDITIONAL FUNDING
TO HELP US TRANSITION FROM DIRTY
DIESEL SCHOOL BUSES TO CLEAN
ELECTRIC SCHOOL BUSES.
IN OUR STATE WE HAVE ALMOST
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND SCHOOL
BUSES ON A ROAD.
MOST OF WHICH ARE DIRTY OIL --
OLDER DIESEL FUEL MODELS THAT
WILL SOON AGE OUT OF THEIR
USEFUL LIFE SPENT -- THESE ARE
MODELS THAT -- CAUSE RESPIRATORY
DISEASES AND WORSEN EXISTING
HEALTH CONDITIONS LIKE ASTHMA
AND PARTICULARLY IMPACT CHILDREN
WHOSE LUNGS ARE STILL DEVELOPING.
NATIONALLY IT'S ESTIMATED --
THAT THEY'RE OVER FIVE POINT
THREE TONS MILLION TONS OF
GREENHOUSE GASES EMITTED EVERY
YEAR BY THESE DIRTY SCHOOL BUSES.
WE ALL KNOW THAT CLEAN
ELECTRICAL BUSES WILL NOT ONLY
PROVIDE CHILDREN WITH THE HEALTH
YOUR COMMUTE.
THEY WILL ALSO OFFER VALUABLE
SAVINGS TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS --
BECAUSE OF TECHNOLOGY THESE
BUSES ARE A MUCH MORE VIABLE
COST EFFECTIVE OPTION AND IN
FACT THE OVER THE LIFETIME OF AN
AVERAGE SCHOOL BUS.
EACH OF THESE BUSES COULD SAVE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS A YEAR IN REDUCED FUEL
AND MAINTENANCE COSTS COMPARED
TO THEIR DIESEL COUNTERPARTS THE
CHALLENGES.
THE UP FRONT COST FOR THESE
BUSES ARE MORE SIGNIFICANT THAN
THEIR COUNTERPARTS -- ALLEGED
BUSES CAN ALSO PROVIDE ELECTRIC
GRID AND FINANCIAL BENEFITS FOR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS BY DISCHARGING
ENERGY AT CRITICAL MOMENTS.
I AND I'LL JUST MENTION AS A
DATA POINT.
IN THE TWIN RIVERS SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN SACRAMENTO WHICH IS
MOVING TOWARD AN ALL ELECTRIC
BUS FLEET.
EVERY MILE DRIVEN BY AN ELECTRIC
SCHOOL BUS COST LESS THAN TWENTY
CENTS PER MILE WHERE IS A
STANDARD DIESEL MODEL COSTS
AROUND EIGHTY CENTS PER MILE.
SO WITH THAT -- WE'VE A BUDGET
ASK OF SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS --
AS PART OF A BROADER ASKED THAT
I KNOW AROUND CLEANER
TRANSPORTATION AND VERY MUCH
HOPE THAT CLEAN SCHOOL BUSES
WILL BE PART OF THIS AND WITH
THAT TO APPRECIATE THE
CONSIDERATION OF THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU MISTER TO MISTER
O'DONNELL EUROPE NEXT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS GOOD -- GOOD
MORNING AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY PRESENT MY BUDGET
REQUEST TODAY I AM REQUESTING
15% OF CAP AND TRADE REVENUES.
BE ALLOCATED TO OUR HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLES OFF ROAD EQUIPMENT
INCENTIVE PROGRAMS FROM THIS
FISCAL YEAR THROUGH.
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE THIS PROPOSED
AMENDMENT WOULD FUND A WIDE
VARIETY OF MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLES AND EQUIPMENT USED BY
THE IN VARIOUS APPLICATIONS BOTH
ON AND OFF ROAD.
THIS INCLUDES FREIGHT TRUCKS
TRANSIT BUSES PORT EQUIPMENT
AGRICULTURAL EQUIPMENT AND
ACTUALLY SCHOOL BUSES AS WELL
WHICH WE JUST HEARD ABOUT.
THE STATE IS WORK DILIGENTLY TO
COMBAT TRANSPORTATION EMISSIONS
ACROSS MANY PLATFORMS AND WE
HAVE MADE SOME GREAT PROGRESS.
UNFORTUNATELY STATEWIDE
TRANSPORTATION EMISSIONS ARE
STILL ON THE RISE AND MANY
COMMUNITIES STILL SUFFER FROM
HARMFUL POLLUTION AND POOR AIR
QUALITY.
IF WE TRULY WANT TO BE
SUCCESSFUL IN ACHIEVING OUR
CLIMATE GOALS THEN WE MUST
DELIVER THE RESOURCES NEEDED TO
TRANSFORM THE TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR SECTOR.
THAT IS THE PLACE TO ADDRESS
THIS IN OTHER WORDS WE NEED TO
PUT OUR MONEY WHERE OUR MOUTH IS
AND ALSO WHERE THE POLLUTION IS.
WE NEED TO DEDICATE MORE FUNDING
TO ACCELERATE THE DEPLOYMENT OF
COMMERCIALLY AVAILABLE YET STILL
EXPENSIVE TECHNOLOGY TODAY WHILE
ALSO SUPPORTING NEW TECHNOLOGIES
THAT ARE IN THE EARLY STAGES OF
DEVELOPMENT.
I WOULD LIKE TO EMPHASIZE THAT
ONGOING FUNDING IS ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL TO THE STATE'S OVERALL
STRATEGY FOR USING FINANCIAL
INCENTIVES TO SUPPORT NEW
TECHNOLOGIES OVER THE NEXT FEW
YEARS WE SHOULD NOT JUST
REGULATE BUT WE SHOULD AND OF
EIGHT THIS MONEY WILL DO THIS.
FOR EXAMPLE FLEET OPERATORS
LOOKING TO PURCHASE NEW
TECHNOLOGIES MY SCHEDULE THE
RETIREMENT AND REPLACEMENT OF
THEIR EXISTING VEHICLES --
SEVERAL YEARS AHEAD SIMILARLY
FLEET MANUFACTURES NEED SEVERAL
YEARS TO IMPLEMENT A SERIES OF
INVESTMENTS WHEN BRINGING NEW
TECHNOLOGIES TO MARKET.
IS EXPONENTIAL ESSENTIAL THAT
THE STATE LINES IT'S FUNNY
INCENTIVES TO THESE BUSINESS
CYCLES TO PROVIDE CERTAIN
CERTAINLY THAT INVESTMENTS WILL
BE AVAILABLE.
THIS BUDGET ALLOCATION
REPRESENTS A CRITICAL DOWN
PAYMENT TOWARDS ACHIEVING THE
STATE'S NEAR TERM AND LONGER
TERM CLIMATE CHANGE IN AIR
QUALITY GOALS -- THERE ARE
NUMBER OF MEMBER OTHER MEMBERS
IT ALSO SUPPORT THIS REQUEST I
KNOW SOME REMEMBER RACE WAS
GOING TO BE HERE TODAY BUT IS
PRESENTING OF LEAVE ANOTHER
COMMITTEE ISSUES SUPPORT AS WELL.
AND I THANK YOU IN THE COMMITTEE
MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
MR RIVAS.
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THANK YOU AND I'M HERE TODAY --
TO RESPECTFULLY REQUEST FIVE
MILLION FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSERVATION TO FIND THE
REGIONAL ECONOMIES IN EQUITY IN
AGRICULTURAL LAND PROGRAM
OTHERWISE AND IS THE REAL
PROGRAM -- ESSENTIALLY THIS
PROGRAM IS ABOUT CREATING
OPPORTUNITY -- NEW OPPORTUNITIES
FOR SOCIALLY -- THE DISADVANTAGE
FARMERS AND RANCHERS TO GAIN
ACCESS TO AGRICULTURAL LAND --
THE REAL PROGRAM WOULD CREATE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESERVE
AGRICULTURAL LAND -- SOMETHING
THAT'S CRITICAL IN IN IN THIS
STATE -- THAT LOSES AN AVERAGE
OF FIFTY THOUSAND ACRES OF
FARMLAND RANGE THAT PER YEAR --
SUCH LOSSES POSE A SERIOUS
THREAT TO AGRICULTURE AND
CERTAINLY TO OUR AGRICULTURAL
ECONOMIES AND STATEWIDE FOOD.
PRODUCTION -- NOW THIS PROGRAM
THE REAL PROGRAM WOULD --
PROTECT AGRICULTURAL LAND AND
SURE IT IS ASSESSABLE TO
SOCIALLY -- DISADVANTAGE FARMERS
AND RANCHERS THROUGH OWNERSHIP
OR LONG TERM LEASES THROUGH FREE
TITLE ACQUISITION AN
AGRICULTURAL CONSERVATION
EASEMENTS ADDITIONALLY THE REAL
ACT ESTABLISHES AN EQUITABLE --
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM TO AWARD
GRANTS A SOCIALLY -- THE
DISADVANTAGE FARMERS THE GRANTS
HELP FARMERS WITH DOWN PAYMENTS
INTEREST RATE ASSISTANCE AND
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR LAND
IMPROVEMENT.
THIS FUNDING WOULD CERTAINLY
HELP SOCIALLY -- THE
DISADVANTAGE THE THE
DISADVANTAGE FARMERS AND
RANCHERS WHILE SAFEGUARDING THE
FUTURE OF AGRICULTURE IN THE
STATE WHICH IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT TO SO MANY REGIONS --
IN OUR STATE SO I RESPECTFULLY
URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND REQUEST -- TO
FIND THE REAL ACT OF TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE CONSIDERATION.
THANK RESEARCHER THANK YOU
MISTER AVIS [inaudible]
MR OBERNOLTE.
GOOD MORNING.
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE ALMOST
AFTERNOON.
I REPRESENT.
OF THE VERY SMALL COMMUNITY AND
DISADVANTAGED MEDIA BIG BEAR
LAKE IT'S WERE USED TO BE THE
MAYOR BEFORE BEING ELECTED TO
THIS JOB IT'S SMALL COMMUNITY AT
THE TOP OF A MOUNTAIN 1100% OF
THE WATER FOR THAT COMMUNITY
COMES FROM GROUND WATER.
BOB RIGHT NOW THAT WATER IS
TREATED UP TO A MINIMUM STANDARD
WHEN IT'S COLLECTED AND THEN
PIPED OFF THE MOUNTAIN -- IS
WASTE WATER. 1100% OF BIG BEAR'S
OUR WATER COMES IN THE FORM OF
RAINFALL AND SNOWFALL THAT'S THE
ONLY THING THEY CAN REPLENISH
THE GROUNDWATER SO OBVIOUSLY --
PIPING ALL OF THIS WATER OFF OF
THE MOUNTAIN IS NOT
ENVIRONMENTALLY SUSTAINABLE --
THIS PROPOSAL WOULD REQUEST
FORTY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS FOR
TERTIARY WASTE WATER TREATMENT
PLANT THAT WOULD TREAT THAT
WATER UP TO A LEVEL SUFFICIENT
TO BE ABLE TO BE PUT INTO THE
LAKE AND EVENTUALLY PERCOLATED
BACK INTO THE GROUND WATER.
THIS PROJECT HAS BEEN DESIGNED
IN A VERY INNOVATIVE WAY TO ALSO --
SATISFIED BAR MENTAL STEWARDSHIP
GOALS THE WATER WOULD FLOW
THROUGH THE STANFIELD MARCH
WHICH IS A SANCTUARY FOR
MIGRATORY WATERFALL AND ALSO
THROUGH PERCOLATION PONDS THAT
BENEFIT A NUMBER OF OTHER --
THREATENED SPECIES INCLUDING THE
LARGEST -- POPULATION OF
WINTERING BALD EAGLES IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
SO I THE COMMUNITIES ACTUALLY
THAT THE MODERN IN THE REQUEST
IS ABOUT FORTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE PLANT OTHER
COMMUNITIES ACTUALLY SUCCEEDED
IN SECURING.
OF LOCAL AND FEDERAL FUNDS TO
FOR ABOUT HALF OF THAT SO IF THE
STATE TO COME UP WITH THE OTHER
TWENTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS WE
COULD DO SOMETHING THAT.
IS REALLY INNOVATIVE HERE THAT
NOT ONLY SATISFIES SEVERAL OF
THE STATE'S PRIORITIES OF OF
INCREASING -- RESILIENCY OF
GROUNDWATER IN RENEWABLE WATER
BUT ALSO I ADMIRE MIDDLE
STEWARDSHIP SO I'D RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT WITH THAT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THE STROLLER.
FOLLOWED BY MS KAMLAGER-DOVE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- I ACTUALLY HAVE THREE
REQUESTS. TO MAKE A TO YOU TODAY --
FIRST IS THE GAME ARE MARKED YOU
STILL ONLY HAVE TO THE SAME TWO
MINUTES EVERYBODY ELSE I
APPRECIATE THAT I'LL GET IT
ORDERED INSPECT ME TO BE FAIR
AND BENEVOLENT.
AS ALWAYS -- I'M ASKING FOR TWO
POINT ONE MILLION FOR THE CITY
OF CLAREMONT TO FUND A PILOT
PROGRAM TO CREATE A LOCALLY
OWNED NONPROFIT SOLAR.
PANEL ASSEMBLY FACTORY.
KIND OF PROJECT THAT YOU WOULD
SEE MAYBE IN SAN FRANCISCO AND
SANTA MONICA [inaudible]
AND BAKERSFIELD.
OF THE CITY OF CLAREMONT LOCAL
COLLEGES THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF GOVERNMENTS AND
RESIDENTS OF POMONA OR JOINING
TOGETHER.
WITH THE NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
COMMUNITY HOME ENERGY RETROFIT
PROJECT. TO BUILD A SOLAR PANEL
PROGRAM OR FACTORY THAT
EMPLOYEES AND SERVES THE PEOPLE
OF CLAREMONT AND MONA.
THE PANELS ARE MORE EFFECTIVE
AND COST LESS THAN MOST SOLAR
PANELS SO TODAY AND BECAUSE THEY
ARE MANUFACTURED BY A NONPROFIT
WILL NOT MARK UP TO TURN A
PROFIT.
THIS WILL BE THE WORLD'S FIRST
REPLICABLE NONPROFIT SOLAR PANEL
ASSEMBLY FACTORY THEY CAN BRING
BACK MIDDLE CLASS MANUFACTURING
JOBS.
ADDRESS OR VINYL OF OUR MIDDLE
JUSTICE ISSUES AND CUT
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AT THE
SAME TIME.
THE FUNDS WILL GO TOWARDS ALL
EQUIPMENT MACHINES TOOLS
MATERIALS AND HIRING NEEDED TO
BUILD A FACTORY.
THAT CAN PRODUCE FIFTY THOUSAND
PANELS A YEAR.
THE SECOND REQUESTED FOR THE
CITY OF PASADENA SIGN MONUMENT.
A LANDMARK OF THE CITY OF SOUTH
PASADENA MY DISTRICT HAS BEEN
THE MONUMENT SIGN.
A LARGE SIGN NESTED IN THE HILL
IT'S BESIDE THE ONE TEN FREEWAY.
THE SIGN IS MADE OF THE NATIVE A
ROYAL STONE AND READ CITY OF
SOUTH PASADENA.
IT WAS ORIGINALLY BUILT IN THE
NINETEEN THIRTIES AND WAS A
SOURCE OF PRIDE BUT IT RECENTLY
HAS BEEN OVERTAKEN BY BRUSH AND
OTHER SIGNS OF WEAR AND TEAR.
THE BRUSHES AND CALTRANS RIGHT
AWAY BUT IS NOT CLEARED REGULATE
DESPITE REQUEST BY THE CITY.
THE CITY'S PUBLIC WORKS
DEPARTMENT AND VOLUNTEERS HAVE
DONE WHAT THEY CAN TO MAINTAIN
IT BUT THE YEARS HAVE TAKEN ITS
TOLL.
THAT IS WHY I REQUEST IN ONE
TIME FUNDING OF NINETY THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO RESTORE THE ICONIC
SIGN AND FIFTEEN THOUSAND ON
GOING. TO MAINTAIN BRUSH
CLEARANCE.
STUDENTS TRANSIT PASS.
STUDENT LIFE IS INHERENTLY
UNSTABLE IS THE SUBJECT OF
FLUCTUATING INCOMES.
INCONSISTENCY GOGGLES AND A
PREDICTABLE EXPENDITURES
OFTENTIMES RESTRICTING FUNDS FOR
TRANSPORTATION.
ALTHOUGH SUBSIDIZE STUDENT
TRANSIT PASS PROGRAMS ARE COMMON
AMONG SCHOOLS AND TRANSPORTATION
AGENCIES A STATEWIDE FUNDING
SOURCE WILL STABILIZE POSTER AND
EXPAND THESE PROGRAMS.
GUARANTEEING AFFORDABLE AND
RELIABLE PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION
WILL RELIEVE FINANCIAL STRESS.
OPEN OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PROFESSIONAL GROWTH AND INCREASE
RIDERSHIP OF ALL THE WHILE
REDUCING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS.
AS WHY WE'RE ASKING FOR SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION TO HELP TRANSIT
AGENCIES FUND THESE PROGRAMS AND
OFFSET THE COSTS.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK THE
COMMISSION'S CONSIDERATION OF
THESE THREE REQUESTS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR SHE AT
THE AND MS KAMAGRA OF THANK YOU
GOOD.
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS I AM
REQUESTING A TEN MILLION DOLLAR
GENERAL FUND APPROPRIATION FOR
THE NATURAL HISTORY MUSEUM OF
LOS ANGELES COUNTY. FOR OVER A
HUNDRED YEARS THIS MUSEUM HAS
BEEN A CRITICAL RESOURCE AND THE
FOUNDATION FOR CULTURAL
SCIENTIFIC KNOWLEDGE.
AND RESEARCH NOT ONLY FOR LA IN
CALIFORNIA BUT FOR THE WORLD.
THE FUNDS WILL GO TOWARDS THE
FIRST PHASE OF THE EXPANSION
PROJECT WHICH WILL UPDATE AND RE
ORIENT THE MUSEUM'S ENTRANCE
INTO EXPOSITION PARK.
AND TO CREATE A STRONGER
CONNECTION TO OTHER AREA
INSTITUTIONS AND PROVIDE MORE
CONVENIENT ACCESS FOR THE
COMMUNITY AND OTHER VISITORS.
IT -- IS WEDDED.
BETWEEN THE CALIFORNIA SCIENCE
CENTER AND ALSO THE CALIFORNIA
AFRICAN AMERICAN MUSEUM WITH THE
LUCAS MUSEUM NOT FAR BEHIND AND
SO.
THIS IS PART OF AN APPROPRIATION
REQUEST TO HELP MAKE SURE THAT
IT MAINTAINS ITS VISIBILITY AND
ITS ABILITY TO PROVIDE THE KIND
OF CULTURAL EXHIBITIONS -- AND
TO DO THE KIND OF RESOURCE A
RESEARCH THAT WE'VE COME TO ADAM
NEED FROM THEM.
EARLIER THIS WEEK THE UNITED
NATIONS REPORTED THAT A MILLION
SPECIES ARE AT RISK OF
EXTINCTION.
IN THIS EVER CHANGING WORLD IT'S
EVEN MORE ESSENTIAL THAT MUSEUM
SUCH AS A NATURAL HISTORY MUSEUM.
USER UNIQUE RESOURCES AND
POTENTIALS TO PROMOTE AND FOSTER
THE BEST CULTURAL AND
ENVIRONMENTAL IDEALS OF OUR
STATE AND COUNTRY.
I SHOULD ADD THAT THE MUSEUM
CONDUCTS SCIENTIFIC RESEARCH ON
MORE THAN THIRTY FIVE MILLION
SPECIMENS DATING BACK FOUR POINT
FIVE BILLION YEARS.
IT HAS EXHIBITIONS RANGING FROM
THE NEW DINOSAUR HALL --
BOASTING TWENTY COMPLETE
DINOSAURS TO THE BECOMING LA
EXHIBIT IT ALSO TRACKED -- THE
MOUNTAIN LION P. FORTY SEVEN
BEFORE IT SUCCUMBED -- TO DEATH
THROUGH RHODEN SIDE AND IT'S
CURRENTLY SERVES ONE POINT THREE
MILLION VISITORS AND THEY
ESTIMATE THAT THE EXPANSION
WOULD ALLOW THE MUSEUM TO SERVE
AN ADDITIONAL FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND PATRONS EACH YEAR. FOR
THESE REASONS I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THIS FUNDING TO ENSURE
THE CONTINUED GROWTH OF A ONE OF
A KIND SCIENTIFIC AND CULTURAL
DESTINATION HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU YOU THE COLLECTED TO
NOTE THAT THE MUSEUM OF NATURAL
HISTORY IS ALSO THE HOME -- OF
AUGUST IN A LAW OFFICE MORE SEE
THE CALIFORNIA STATE DINOSAUR
THANK YOU I WAS WAITING FOR YOU
TO ADD THAT AS YOU HAD DONE ON
THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE SAME
REASONS -- I THINK THE MISTER
PATTERSON YOU HAVE -- PRISON
TASTED LIKE MAKE.
NOW WOULD BE THE TIME AND OF
THEM WILL TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT TO
IF THERE'S NO OTHER MEMBERS WHO
ARE PRESENTING.
THANK THANK MISTER APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY AT THREE TO
PRESENT I'M GONNA TRY TO MAKE
HIM.
A QUICK AS MY UP -- COLLEAGUE
GUESS -- MISSED MR HOLDEN DEAD
SO HERE WE GO OUT THERE TO
RELATED.
ASKED TO PRESENT TO THE
SUBCOMMITTEE DAY WITH RESPECT
CAL FIRE THE FIRST IS A FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS TO BE
APPROPRIATE FROM THE GENERAL
FUND TO CAL FIVE FOR THE PURPOSE
OF RESEARCH.
THIS MONEY WOULD ALLOW CAL FIRE
TO OFFER GRANTS TO SCHOOLS OF
THE CSU SYSTEM TO STUDY AND
PUBLISH FINDINGS.
ON THE PHYSICAL MENTAL AND
EMOTIONAL TOLL THAT LONG INTENSE
FIRE SEASONS TAKE ON
FIREFIGHTERS IN THE WILD LAND IN
THE WILDLAND URBAN.
INTERFACE -- WE KNOW THAT MANY
MANY FIRE FIGHTERS IN THIS.
NEW ERA I JUST WORK HOURS AND
HOURS DAYS ON END -- THIS MEANS
THEY DON'T GET ADEQUATE REST
THERE'S NUTRITIONAL ISSUES UP
BATHROOM BREAK ISSUES AND MUCH
MUCH MORE BUT ADDITIONALLY THERE.
EXPOSED TO HARMFUL POLLUTANTS --
FOR THE ENTIRETY OF THE FIRE --
BUT THAT SO FAR THE STATE I
THINK HAS FAILED ADEQUATELY TO
STUDY AND UNDERSTAND -- THESE
DIFFICULTIES AND FIREFIGHTERS IN
THESE SITUATIONS -- I HAVE MANY
CAL FIRE AB MEMBERS THAT RESIDE
IN SEVERAL CALIFORNIA WHO FIGHT
FIRES UP AND DOWN STATE.
AND THEY ARE STRESSED AND AS
I'VE NEVER SEEN AND MANY OF THEM
ARE FRIENDS OF MINE.
THAT I'VE KNOWN FOR A LONG
PERIOD OF TIME.
OBVIOUSLY THE TWENTY FOUR FORTY
EIGHT HOURS OF THE FIRES LIKE A
CAMPFIRE THEY GET NO SLEEP
THEY'RE BATTLING THIS BLAZE IT'S
NOT UNCOMMON FOR FIREFIGHTERS TO
STAY ON THE FIRE LINE FOR DAYS.
ON END.
AND SO WE WERE WERE ASKING -- IT
IS POLICY MAKERS THAT WE TRY TO
BE ABLE TO UNDERSTAND THOSE
DEMANDS WE PLACE ON OUR
FIREFIGHTERS AND POTENTIAL
LIMITATIONS TO AND SIDE EFFECTS
OF THESE.
EXPECTATIONS FOR THOSE REASONS I
REQUEST THE FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
TO BE ALLOCATED TO COP CAL FIRE
FOR THE PURPOSE OF STUDYING
UNDERSTANDING.
THE PHYSICAL EMOTIONAL AND
MENTAL EFFECTS OF THE GROWING
FIRE SEASONS.
ON OUR FIREFIGHTERS A SECOND
REQUEST WITH RESPECT TO CAL FIRE
IS FOR EIGHTY NINE MILLION IN
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND MONEY TO
PURCHASE AND STAFF.
THIRTY ONE CAL FIRE [inaudible]
ENGINES -- I'M GONNA CUT. TO
JUST THIS -- IN TWENTY TWELVE
THE MUTUAL AID SYSTEM HAD JUST
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FOUR REQUESTS.
FOR ENGINES ARE WATER TENDER AGE
GO UNANSWERED.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN THAT NUMBER
WAS OVER.
THREE THOUSAND NOT ONLY DOES
THIS FORCE THE STATE TO BORROW
FROM PRIVATE ENGINES IT'S A MUCH
HIGHER COST.
BUT IT ALSO INCREASES THE NUMBER
OF CIVILIANS FIREFIGHTERS HOMES
AND STRUCTURES WE PUT IN HARM'S
WAY THAT THE LONGER.
UP THE FIRE.
BURNS -- LAST YEAR ALONE
WILDFIRES IN CALIFORNIA RESULT
RESULTED IN A HUNDRED DEATHS
MORE THE TWENTY TWO THOUSAND
BUILDINGS.
AT STAKE CAN'T CONTINUE TO FIGHT
FIGHT THIS GROWING CRISIS --
WITH LIMITED THE TRUCKS AND
LIMITED EQUIPMENT AND PERSONNEL
SO WITH THAT THESE REASONS I'M
ASKING FOR CONSIDERATION OF THE
EIGHTY NINE THOUSAND FROM THE
GENERAL EIGHTY NINE MILLION.
ZEROS MATTER.
FROM THE GENERAL FUND THE
CALIFORNIA FOR THE PURPOSES OF
PURCHASING THIRTY ONE ADDITIONAL
ENGINES.
HIRING THE NEEDED STAFF FOR
THOSE ENGINES AND FINALLY --
THEY WAS CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
OF A BIO MASS REQUEST -- FOR
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUN TO
THE NATIONAL BUT NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY FOR THE PURPOSE
OF IMPLEMENTING A GRANT PROGRAM.
TO OFFSET THE IMMENSE COST OF
TRANSPORTING FORCED FUELS TO BUY
A MASS ENERGY THE FUNDING WILL
BE USED TO FINANCE PROJECTS
PROPOSED BY COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
IN ORDER ME CRITICAL GHG
REDUCTION AND FOREST MANAGEMENT
GOALS.
IT IS PROVEN THAT USING THESE
BIOMASS FACILITIES REDUCES THE
RISK OF LARGE CATASTROPHIC FIRES
IT PROTECTS WATERSHEDS IMPROVE
THEIR QUALITY AND PUBLIC HEALTH
HOWEVER.
THE THE GROWING INCREASE IN THE
COST OF TRANSPORTATION.
OF THE REMAINS THE SINGLE
GREATEST BARRIER THE IDEA FOR
THIS PROGRAM WAS IN FACT
PROPOSED TO THIS LEGISLATURE
ABOUT A DECADE AGO IT PASSED
UNANIMOUSLY ON THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR.
BUT IT WAS IT NEVER HEARD
INSTALLED IN THE SENATE.
AND SINCE THEN CALIFORNIA NOW
HAS OVER A HUNDRED AND FORTY
NINE MILLION DEAD TREES IN THE
STATION DEADLY.
RECORD SETTING WILDFIRES EACH
YEAR ASKING FOR THAT THE TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS. FOR THE PURPOSE
OF HELPING THOSE THOSE
TRANSPORTATION COSTS -- TO BE
MITIGATED SO THAT THAT MORE UP
SO THE THE FORCE CAN BE CLEARED
THE CAPACITIES -- FOR THE USE OF
THIS CAN BE UTILIZED BY REALLY
TAKING DOWN ONE OF THE BIGGEST
BARRIERS TO THE SUCCESSFUL IN
AND EFFICIENT USE OF VIOLENCE
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
AND THANK YOU MISTER PATTERSON --
WILL TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT NOW AND
TO YOU MAY WISH TO COMMENT ON
ONE OF THE PROPOSALS THAT YOU'VE
HEARD TODAY OR A PROPOSAL THAT --
WASN'T SPECIFICALLY BROUGHT
FORWARD I DO ASK -- ESPECIALLY
SEEING HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE
GETTING UP -- IDENTIFY THE
PROPOSAL THE AMOUNT AND MAY BE A
SENTENCE OR TWO ABOUT THE
SUBSTANCE WILL GET IT WE
UNDERSTAND THAT -- YOU KNOW THE
ESSENCE OF MOST OF THESE
PROPOSALS -- AND RUN ON
SENTENCES ARE FROWNED UPON.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- MATT
ROBINSON ACTUALLY OF THREE
PROPOSALS I WANT TO COMMENT ON
BUT I'M GONNA DO IT VERY QUICKLY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSIT ASSOCIATION AND THE
CEMETERY COUNTY TRANSIT DISTRICT.
FULLY IN SUPPORT OF MR
O'DONNELL'S PROPOSAL AS YOU KNOW
WE NOW FACE A REGULATION FROM
THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD.
WHICH REQUIRES US TO ADOPT ZERO
EMISSION BUSES BY A SCHEDULE
TARGET DATE NOT FUNDING WILL OUT
A LOT OF SECURITY -- TO
ACHIEVING THAT GOAL FOR OUR
MEMBER AGENCIES THE SECOND WOULD
BE AN EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
STORM WATER -- PROJECT --
FUNDING REQUEST THE CAPTURE AND
PROJECT FUNDING REQUEST BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN ON BEHALF
OF SAN MATTEO CITY COUNTY
ASSOCIATION OF GOVERNMENTS.
THAT HAS THE SUPPORT OF THE
COUNTY AS WELL AS ALL TWENTY
CITIES IN SAN MATEO COUNTY.
AND THEN FINALLY -- I WOULD BE
REMISS NOT TO MENTION THE TWO
MILLION DOLLAR REQUEST BY MISTER
MURATSUCHI AND OTHER MEMBERS --
FOR THE GREEN BUSINESS PROGRAM
WE ENCOURAGE YOU TO CONTINUE
THAT FOLKS FUNDING FOR THAT
PROGRAM AS YOU'VE DONE LAST TWO
YEARS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEDIOCRE JOB.
NEXT.
WE ARE ALL GOING TO GET RATED.
MISTER CHAIRMAN TERRY MCHALE
WITH THEIR IN READING ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING CDF FIREFIGHTERS.
TO EIGHT EIGHT ONE ONE I THINK
MISTER PATTERSON FOR THAT
PASSIONATE.
A REQUEST BY THE TRUTH IS WE ARE
A GENERATION BEHIND IN STUDYING
WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH OUR RURAL
FIREFIGHTERS AND THEY ARE OUT
THERE FOR SIX EIGHT TWELVE WEEKS
WITHOUT GOING HOME.
AND THE IMPACTS ARE DIVORCED THE
IMPACTS ARE PHYSICAL IN THE
IMPACTS ARE LONG LASTING SET
FIVE MILLION WILL BE WELL SPENT.
HIGHER SUPPORTING MR PATTERSON'S
REQUEST FOR FIVE MILLION YES SIR
YES I'M ALSO SUPPORTING MR --
PATTERSON'S REQUEST FOR EIGHTY
NINE MILLION DOLLARS. FOR NEW
ENGINES THANK YOU WE HAVE IF YOU
ARE ALREADY PRESENTED ON IT SO
VERY GOOD AND AT LAST I WANT TO
SAY IS WE HAVE AVOIDED GETTING
INTO THE VERGE MANAGEMENT ISSUE.
BUT I DO BELIEVE THAT MISS
WALDRON HAS WILL BE COMING IN
LATER WILL BE PRESENTING WE ARE
SENDING A LETTER BECAUSE WE
THINK IT'S CONSISTENT WITH WHAT
WAS HAPPENING BEFORE THE NEW
NORMAL.
THANK YOU AND JUST REPEAT MIKE --
EARLIER -- A STATEMENT TO IF YOU
DIDN'T PRESENT TODAY THAT
DOESN'T PREJUDICE CONSIDERATION
OF OF YOUR REQUEST.
A GOOD MORNING TERRIBLY MEMBERS
THE COMMITTEE I AM A RYAN KENNY
WITH CLEAN ENERGY AND WE'RE IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL SO I REQUEST. FIFTEEN
PERCENTAGES YOU'RE OUT FOR THE
CLEAN BUS AND TRUCK -- PROGRAM
IT WILL ACCELERATE THE A
DISPLACEMENT OF I DIESEL TRUCKS
TO CLEANER ZERO IN YOUR ZERO
VEHICLES.
I WANNA MAKE A QUICK POINT.
WHERE ALMOST GOING TO GET IN A
OKAY GO AHEAD I JUST WANT TO
MENTION THE LA REPORT THAT THAT
THIS COMMITTEE ACTUALLY
HIGHLIGHTED ON APRIL THIRD?
THIS REQUEST IS CONSISTENT WITH
THOSE CONCERNS EXPRESSED IN THE
LA A REPORT AND WE LOOK FOR TO
RESOLUTION THANK YOU THANK YOU
[inaudible]
A PLUS.
HI I MERRY REEVES FROM BIG BEAR
CITY COMMUNITY SERVICES DISTRICT
AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF A IT'S
ASSEMBLY MEN OVER NOLTE'S.
REPLENISH BIG BEAR PROJECT -- WE
RESPECTFULLY ASKED FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND SUPPORT IN THE
PROJECT PERFECT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M ALSO PART OF
ASSEMBLY WOULDN'T BUILD THESE --
GANG.
AND I SUPPORT THE REPLENISH BIG
BEAR PROJECT AND WE WOULD
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION ON
MAKING THIS PROJECT ECONOMICALLY
FEASIBLE THANK THANK YOUR HE
APPARENTLY HUNG AROUND TO MAKE
SURE YOU ALSO THE LINE.
AND I'M GONNA SAY DITTO EXCEPT
THAT MY NAME IS DAVID BOREN TIME
SUPPORT OF SEC -- MR OBERNOLTE
IS -- REQUEST THANK YOU.
MIKE STEVENSON JOURNAL MEASURE
THE BIGGER MISSILE WATER
DISTRICT AND IN SUPPORT OF THEIR
PENALTIES REQUEST THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON ALLOWS US LEASE
ON BEHALF OF THE INTERNATIONAL
LONGSHOREMEN WAREHOUSE UNION IN
SUPPORT OF THEIR QUEST. TO
ALLOCATE CAP AND TRADE FUNDS TO
PORTS FOR ZERO NEAR ZERO
EMISSION EQUIPMENT DIAL W.
SUPPORTS CLEAN UP OUR
COMMUNITIES AS OUR WORKERS LIVE
THERE.
THESE FUNDS ARE FUNDAMENTAL SO
THAT WE CAN UPGRADE THE PORTS
INFRASTRUCTURE WHILE REDUCING
EMISSIONS THANK YOU.
DAVE BRONSON POLICY DIRECTOR FOR
COMMUNITY LINES THE FAMILY
FARMERS -- WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY WOMAN I GEAR
SCURRIES EIGHTY NINE FIFTY EIGHT
TRYING TO GET.
ORGANIC PRODUCE -- INTO LOW
INCOME SCHOOLS IN CALIFORNIA AND
WE ALSO SUPPORT THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RIVAS IS AB.
NINE EIGHTY SIX MATT REMARK OUT
MY TRUCKING ASSOCIATION HERE IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL 15% REQUEST FRIEND
YOU'RE OFFENDING I HAD.
IT WILL GO A LONG WAY TO GIVE
OUR COMPANY CERTAINTY IN ORDER
TO YOU -- TURN OVER OUR POLICE
THE CLEANEST MOST BILL OR CLEAN
IS THE BEST MOBILE TECHNOLOGY.
CHAIR MEMBERS RJ SAID ON THIS ON
BEHALF OF THE PORT OF LOS
ANGELES HERE IN STRONG SUPPORTER
MR O'DONNELL'S REQUEST THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
STEVE KERR'S WITH PRE STRATEGIES
ON BEHALF OF SAY COG ASSEMBLY
MEMBER COOLEY WAS GOING TO BE
HERE TO PRESENT AND FORCING CAN
MAKE IT SO.
I'M GONNA READ BATTERY PRETTY
QUICKLY BECAUSE I IT'S A BIG
ITEM.
THIS IS THE GREEN MEANS GO --
PILOT -- SAY COG DEVELOP THE
GROOMING GO.
PROGRAM TO ENHANCE
IMPLEMENTATION OF SB -- THREE
SEVENTY FIVE AND HELP THE REGION
ACHIEVE ITS GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSION REDUCTION TARGET OF 19%
BY.
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE CAR BUT STEP
WAS THE 19% TARGET ACKNOWLEDGING
THE CHALLENGES FOR SAY CARD
REGION TO BEATS THIS TARGET AND
DIRECTED SAY **** TO DEVELOP A
PILOT PROGRAM. TO MEETS THIS
AMBITIOUS GOALS OF THE PILOT.
IS DESIGNED FOR THAT PURPOSE --
EFFECTIVELY WITH ESTABLISHED THE
STATE LOCAL PARTNERSHIP TO
IDENTIFY HOW TO BEST MAKE THE
TRANSPORTATION HOW THESE HOUSE
INVESTMENTS NEEDED -- TO MEET
HOUSING AND CLIMATE GOALS
INCLUDE ACCELERATION FEEL
DEVELOPMENT -- MOBILITY OPTIONS
AND ELECTRIFICATION OF THE M. T.
SO IT'S A IT'S A BIGGER CRASS
IT'S FORTY MILLION DOLLARS OVER
MULTIPLE YEARS -- BUT AGAIN WITH
THE THE COGS AROUND THE STATE
YOU KNOW FACED WITH THE
CHALLENGE OF TRYING TO MEET THE
REDUCTIONS IT'S IT'S BEEN
DIFFICULT AND SO WE WORK WITH
CARBON.
HOW CAN BE PUT TOGETHER A
PROGRAM I TO DEMONSTRATE HOW
THIS CAN BE DONE ACROSS THE
STATE IN SACRAMENTO WAS IT -- WE
WE THOUGHT A GOOD WAY TO DO IT
GIVEN THAT WE WERE SORT OF A
MICROCOSM OF THE STATE'S GOT
URBAN AND RURAL AREAS SO WE
THINK THIS IS IMPORTANT --
PROGRAM TO HELP US GET THERE
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AS CHAIR MEMBERS INTO ANTS WE
WISH I ORDER AND WE HERE TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SANTA
MONICA AND THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY.
IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL'S REQUEST.
415% OF YOUR F. OF PROCEEDS ON
ANNUAL BASIS DEDICATED TO LOW
CARBON TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM OF
POSSIBLY A TRIP.
IN THE CASE OF SANTA MONICA BIG
LOSSES BUS HAS DECIDED.
TO ACCELERATE THEIR OWN TIMELINE
BEYOND WAS GOING TO BE MANDATED
BY THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD TO
TURN OVER THEIR FLEET BUT
THEY'VE EXPERIENCED A DELTA.
THE BUSES ARE HIGHER THAN
ANTICIPATED ESPECIALLY WHEN.
PAIRED WITH THE NATURAL GAS
VEHICLES THAT THEY HAVE IN THEIR
FLEET TODAY AND SO THIS COULD GO
A LONG WAY COULD BE CRUCIAL.
AND LA METRO IS ON THE SAME
EXHILARATED TIMELINE AND FOR THE
SAME REASONS WITH SUPPORT AND
MULTI YEAR WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL.
THANK YOU AND MS REYES WANTS TO
ADD A COMMENT -- THAT'S SPECIFIC
TO THIS SAME ISSUE SO IF YOU'D
LIKE.
TO ADD THOSE COMMENTS NOW THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I I ALL I WANT
TO ALSO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL FOR HIS PRESENTATION --
FIRST PROPOSAL ON SUCH AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE -- AS MANY OF US
KNOW CALIFORNIA'S FREIGHT SYSTEM
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR OVER ONE
THIRD OF THE STATE'S ECONOMIC
OUTPUT OF OVER FIVE HUNDRED
BILLION DOLLARS IN GOODS.
COMING THROUGH ITS PORTS OF
ENTRY.
MANY OF THE THESE GOODS TRAVEL
FROM THE PORTS IN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER O'DONNELL'S DISTRICT TO
THE WAREHOUSES IN MY DISTRICT
DISTRICT.
FORTY SEVEN BRINGING WITH WITH
THIS CONCENTRATED SOURCES OF
POLLUTION THE POPE THAT BOTH
EXASPERATED OUR CURRENT CLIMATE
CRISIS AND HAVE.
DETRIMENTAL PUBLIC HEALTH
CONSEQUENCES WE MUST TAKE ACTION
NOW.
IT IS CRITICAL FOR THE STATE TO
DEPLOY AS MANY CLEAN VEHICLES AS
WE CAN TODAY WHILE SETTING UP A
FRAMEWORK TO CONTINUE TO
INNOVATE AND PUSH ZERO EMISSION
TECHNOLOGIES TO TRULY ADDRESS
THIS CRISIS LONG TERM.
BY MAKING A DEDICATED MULTI YEAR
INVESTMENT THIS FUNDING PROPOSAL
PUTS IN PLACE CRITICAL
INCENTIVES THAT WHEN COMBINED
WITH ADDITIONAL STATE ACTION AND
AGGRESSIVE GOAL SETTING WILL
TRANSITION US INTO A CLEAN
FREIGHT SYSTEM.
AND I AGAIN WANT TO THANK --
MISTER O'DONNELL FOR PRESENTING
THIS PROPOSAL ON THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENTS AS WELL.
THANK YOU.
BILL MADERA THE COALITION FOR
CLEAN ARE ALSO IN SUPPORT OF MR
O'DONNELL'S REQUEST 450%
CONTINUE APPROPRIATION FOR THE
TRUCK BUS AND AFRAID EQUIPMENT
PROGRAM.
AND A COMPLETELY AGREE WITH
EVERYTHING ASSEMBLY MEMBER REYES
SAID AND WHAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL SAID EARLIER AND WE
HEAR BALLS FROM VEHICLE
MANUFACTURERS AND FROM COMMUNITY
GROUPS ABOUT THE NEED.
FOR SUFFICIENT SUSTAINED.
MULTI YEAR FUNDING FOR THIS
PROGRAM AND WE ALSO SUPPORT --
MISTER CHOOSE REQUEST FOR QUEEN
SCHOOL BUSES.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS -- TEAR CRYO
CHROME HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FOOD AND FARMING NETWORK -- IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS
IS FIVE MILLION DOLLAR QUEST --
FOR THE REAL ACT A. B. NINETY
SIX ON THERE A LOT OF US
SOCIALLY DISADVANTAGED AND
HISTORICALLY UNDERSERVED.
GROUPS AROUND THE STATE THAT
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO
TRADITIONALLY ACCESS -- FEDERAL
STATE GRANT PROGRAMS AND SO WE
TO SEE THIS AS A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU.
REVENUE IS THE CHAIR BREADING
RCL WITH CAL STAR WE ALSO WANT
TO ECHO SOME MEMORY AS IT IS
SOMETHING WE'RE GONNA SUPPORT
FOR FOR THE PERCENTAGES ARE
ASKED. FOR CLEAN MEDIUM HEAVY
DUTY VEHICLES CRITICAL SENSE
FROM MARKET SIGNALS MANUFACTURES
LOOKING FIVE TO SEVEN YEARS OUT
ROBUST MULTI YEAR FUNDING IS THE
ONLY WAY TO ENSURE WE HAVE A
VITAL PART OF THE PRIVATE SECTOR.
THANK YOU.
ERICA MARTINA SOME BEHALF OF
EARTH JUSTICE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU SEVENTY
MILLION DOLLAR REQUEST FOR
SCHOOL BUSES.
THE INVESTMENT IN SCHOOL BUSES
WILL PRE REDUCTIONS IN
COMMUNITIES THAT NEED THOSE
REDUCTIONS NOW THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN CHARLES WATSON
ON BEHALF OF PREPARE ZERO
EMISSION BUS MANUFACTURE ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL'S REQUEST THANK YOU.
SURE MEMBERS NIKITA CROWDED WITH
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL -- AN RTC ALONG WITH THE
COMMUNITY ALLIANCE WITH FAMILY
FARMERS AND STRONG SUPPORT OF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ON YOUR CURRY'S.
TWO MILLION DOLLAR BUDGET
REQUEST FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ORGANIC TO SCHOOLS PILOT PROGRAM
THIS INITIATIVE IS REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR THE HEALTH OF
SCHOOL CHILDREN TO PROMOTE
AGRICULTURAL PRACTICES THAT
PROMOTE SOIL HEALTH AND FOR THE
ECONOMIC VITALITY OF ORGANIC
FARMERS THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS LEAH SO REFORM WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL'S PROPOSAL FORWARD
YEAR FUND REQUEST THANK YOU.
HELLO JOHN KENNEDY WITH RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA I'M HERE TO SUPPORT
TO MEASURES THE FIRST IS MISTER
PATTERSON'S REQUEST -- FOR
TWENTY MILLION G. G. R. F. --
FOR BIOMASS FUEL TRANSPORTATION
SUBSIDY THIS IS IMPORTANT
MISSING LINK FOR MAKING A LOT OF
THESE VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
PROJECTS WORK TO REDUCE THE RISK
OF FIRE -- ALSO -- ALIGNING IN
THE FORESTRY ASSOCIATION IN THE
BIOMASS ENERGY ALLIANCE WITH MY
COMMENTS ON THAT AS WELL AND THE
SECOND IS MS WALDRON'S REQUEST
FOR TWENTY FIVE MILLION FOR
LOCAL ASSISTANCE GRANTS TO
ACQUIRE EQUIPMENT. TO GO OUT AND
DO VEGETATION MANAGEMENT ALONG
STREETS AND ROADS TO REDUCE THE
RISK OF WILDFIRE IGNITION THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
NAME IS ANDY NATURI SOME THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
AGRICULTURAL INSTITUTE OF MARIN
AND I'M HERE EXPRESSING SUPPORT
FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEVIN'S
REQUEST FOR FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
TO FUND THE CENTER FOR FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE.
WHICH WILL BE A YEAR ROUND
FARMERS MARKET AN EDUCATIONAL
CENTER TO HOUSE.
OVER TWO HUNDRED FIFTY SMALL
FAMILY FARMERS FROM FORTY
COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA AND
GENERATE A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN ANNUAL ECONOMIC
ACTIVITY TO SUPPORT AGRICULTURE
THANK YOU.
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBER I'LL HAVE
ANOTHER RUN WITH THE WIDENING
GROUP HERE ON TWO MEASURES --
THE FIRST ONE IS ON BEHALF OF BE
Y. DE -- WERE AN ELECTRIC BUS
MANUFACTURER I'M AND HEAVY DUTY --
VEHICLES AND EQUIPMENT AND THE
SECOND ONE IS ON BEHALF OF NEXT
GEN CALIFORNIA HERE IN SUPPORT
OF MR CHOOSE -- REQUEST FOR A
CLEAN SCHOOL BUS AS WE THINK IT
THAT'S JUST ANOTHER TO ANOTHER
APPROACH TO REDUCE --
TRANSPORTATION POLLUTION THANK
YOU.
REBECCA MARK AS REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA CLIMATE IN
AGRICULTURE NETWORK AND THE
AMERICAN FARMLAND TRUST IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW
MOANS TWO MILLION DOLLAR REQUEST
FOR PRACTICAL ADAPTATION TOOLS
FOR FARMERS AND RANCHERS.
I'M ALSO HERE REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN FARMLAND TRUST AND
CARBON CYCLE INSTITUTE IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ROBERT RIVAS IS A FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR REQUEST FOR THE REGIONAL
ECONOMY.
IN EQUITY AND AGRICULTURAL LANDS
PROGRAM AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSERVATION.
GOOD AFTERNOON NIGGLING AT AN
HONEST GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FOR
SAN DIEGO GAS AND ELECTRIC IN
SUPPORT OF THE SUMMER MARIE
WALDRON I REQUEST FOR TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO CAL
GRANTS FOR LOCAL SYSTEM FUNDING
FOR VEGETATION MANAGEMENT THANK
YOU.
ERNESTO MEZA WITH THE NATIONAL
FARMERS COALITION IN THE
CALIFORNIA FORMER JUSTICE
COLLABORATIVE.
HERE SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ROBERT RIVAS IS -- FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR QUEST FOR SOCIAL DESIGNS
FARMERS LIKE IT.
HELLO MORGAN COMEDIAN ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA TROUT OCEAN
CONSERVANCY AND LAND TRUST OF
SANTA CRUZ COUNTY.
I IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EDUARDO GARCIA IS A REQUEST FOR
FOUR HUNDRED MILLION INVESTMENTS
AND THE STATE'S NATIONAL WORKING
LANDS.
OTHERS REST REQUEST REPRESENTS A
COORDINATED APPROACH AN
AGREEMENT BY LEGISLATORS AND
STAKEHOLDERS LATER CRITICAL
INVESTMENTS PROTECTOR STATES
NATURAL RESOURCES.
AND THE COMMUNITIES RELY ON THEM
AND WE WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT
THIS REQUEST I'M ALSO HERE AND
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION COURSE FOR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK SILVA AS REQUEST
FOR FOUR MILLION DOLLARS FOR
WRAPAROUND SERVICES -- TO HELP
THE CORE MEMBERS THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON DANIEL LYNCH --
ON BEHALF OF A COUPLE CLIENTS ON
TO BUDGET ITEMS THIS AFTERNOON
I'M THE FIRST IS ON BEHALF OF US
SAVE THE REDWOODS LEAGUE IN
CALIFORNIA TROUT -- IN REGARDS
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOODS TEN
MILLION DOLLAR REQUEST TO BUILD
A VISITOR CENTER AT THAT
ABANDONED ORIC MAIL SITE.
AND THE SECOND ON BEHALF OF MID
PENINSULA REGIONAL OPEN SPACE
DISTRICT -- IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN'S REQUEST
FOR NINE POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS TO PERMANENTLY PROTECT
TO COASTAL -- PROPERTIES THANKS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- THAT --
BRINGS US TO THE CONCLUSION OF
OUR MEETING I THINK EVERYONE HAS
HAD A CHANCE TO DO THEIR ADD ON
BOATS AND SO.
THE MEETING WILL STAND ADJOURNED
THANK YOU ALL